the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
to be amazed at the U.S women's and U.S
open championships in St Louis vicious
veterans are quickly clawing their way
back into contention after a slow start
Ray Robinson brought his title chances
back from the break of Extinction after
winning three in a row for Clear second
behind front-runner Fabiano caruana
Megan Lee continues her meteoric rise
devouring her competition and inheriting
sole lead of the women's section clever
players are always evolving what new
ideas will they dig up today day nine of
Titanic chess coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everybody to day 9 of the
2022 us chess championships and U.S
women's chess championships there's so
many cool things to do here in St Louis
including learning more about the fierce
creatures behind me that lived millions
of years ago well the players will have
to be fierce over the chessboard to get
ahead in the standings as well let's go
to the studio and start today's action
with Yasser and Anastasia
from the home of Chess in the United
States welcome to the Saint Louis chess
club and the ninth round of the U.S
chess championships and the U.S women's
chess championships
foreign
[Music]
by my brilliant co-host Grandmaster
four-time U.S Champion Yasser ceremon
awesome Anastasia good to be with you as
well it's been wonderful it's been
wonderful exactly great stuff hello
everyone and thank you for joining our
show it's been tumultuous in the U.S
Women's Championship as the leadership
keeps changing hands but it's been
smooth sailing in the open event for
Juan Fabiana caruana even if in his
draws he's had the favorable side
Anastasia do the honors tell us about
the leaders and the ladies I believe
this standings we have a Megan Lee on
the top of the board six points well
done she won the game and that's how she
appeared here on the first position
Irina crush and Jennifer you share the
second place with five and a half points
and then we have Alice Lee 13 years old
girl who is on the fourth position right
now well done Alice and in the open
section are leaders there Fabiano
caruana is in the solid look look at him
I mean
ahead of his nearest rival Ray Robson
who is on the second position both of
them have actually quite good distance
from the third place it's one and a half
for Fabiano and one for a Robson linear
Dominguez Jeffrey is wrong
savian and a Wonderland have four and a
half points right now with the Positive
score and our format for our two
national championships in each
championships we have 14 players its
round rubber system we have 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves followed by 30
minutes for the rest of the game and
then we have also 30 seconds increment
from move one no draw first fighting
until the end Anastasia tell me about
the schedule I am ready for a free day
I'm sure the players are ready too so we
have two rounds ahead of us today and
tomorrow and then we have the rest day
on Sunday October 16th then we have
three more rounds to go the last ones
and if we need playoffs it will they
will happen on 20th of October as well
at the closing ceremony tell me more
about the closing ceremony
if anyone would like to attend the
closing ceremony you can just buy
tickets for 25 dollars per person and
then the food schedule will follow you
can attend first of all a cocktail party
at 6 PM uh then we'll have closing
ceremony and what is very important
after party with DJ and the other and
Christian dancing we promise and nothing
right Christian good to see you I'm not
sure
tell us about the leaders and their road
ahead it's great uh to see you guys
great to be back in the studio calling
the shots here at the U.S chess
championships and Yasser you mentioned
smooth sailing for Fabiano caruana up to
this point but there is one Ray Robson
who is picking up the pace as well and
right now he is only half a point behind
the leader I want to highlight these two
amazing players and we're going to start
with Ray Robson and his line score after
eight rounds we've seen in the first
five rounds well draws all the way to
the fifth round but after that and he
mentioned it in the interview as well he
was saying that yeah I wasn't getting
any chances I was playing great chess I
was just simply not getting any winning
chances but once he got the chat those
chances he managed an incredible
hat-trick in rounds six seven and eight
just an incredible performance and right
now he is standing in 35th position in
the world live rankings and let's take a
look at the road ahead for Ray Robson in
the final five today a big chance a
golden opportunity with the white pieces
against let's say the struggling
Alexander uh landerman round 10 against
sam7 against a Wonder Liang 12th against
the youngster Christopher you and in the
final championship round he will be
playing with the white pieces against
Jeffrey Sean so definitely an
interesting road ahead for Ray Robson
and listing look at his best finish at
the US chess championships it came in
2015 and he mentioned yesterday during
the interview that one of his Big Dreams
is to win this event well he right now
has a great chance of doing so he took
second place in that 2015 Championship
seven and a half out of 11. right now
he's standing on five and a half out of
eight definitely an impressive score for
this young man and there you have it he
is our leader in the open section
arriving early as he should he will not
be losing any single minute on his clock
due to those uh very uh thorough checks
and let's take a look at his line score
after eight rounds well he's been having
not only a solid event absolutely no
losses but also he scored four important
victories just an impressive performance
by Fabiano caruana a rating performance
close to
2900. wow just a juggernaut of an event
he's been having and let's take a look
at his role ahead as well well today he
will be having the white pieces against
the youngster a wander Liang so
definitely a big opportunity for him as
well to maintain his uh lead or perhaps
even extend his Lane in round 10 against
Christopher u11 against Jeffrey Sean Sam
Shanklin the 2018 U.S chess champion in
round 12 and in the final championship
round against his good friend Levon
aronian and which one was his best year
at the USS Championship you might be
wondering that was actually his first
year after his swished federations from
Italy he won the championship became the
U.S Champion with eight and a half out
of 11 points guys we still have five
rounds and the tournaments are just
hitting up well I tell you lots and lots
of things can happen but first do the
iron owners and tell us about the
pairings for today starting with our
ladies Anastasia and the ladies so we
have the leader Megan Lee who'll play
against beg him for her dronella today
with black pieces and a big Marquee
match-up game I'm sure about that and
then also Arena Crusher who shares
shares the second place she will face
Alice Lee our young player yes and then
also
yes with Jennifer and we're looking
forward to watching this absolutely and
there we see our leader Megan
getting ready for her game and again
it's nice to see the players arriving a
little early because we have seen a
backup of the players 28 players getting
scanned and wanted in our fair play
rules and in the open section one of our
what are the key pairings the key
bearings listen already mentioned that
Fabiana carono will play with a
Wonderland a young player an American
player and he has a good tournament so
far no questions to be easy at all and
then also we have Ray Robson face and
Alex landermann also just pay attention
to those matches between linear and
Dominguez and sam7 yeah both players
undefeated both players are to the
positive score yes and also will be
interesting match between I hope so with
enhance Neiman and Wesley so as well as
Sam Shanklin and Christopher you and
maybe darush is looking at Opportunity
as elshon is having a very bad uh event
the players are fighting very hard and
they'll be fighting for another week
what are they fighting for
into oh there you see a Wonder Liang on
the black side against Bobby uh what are
the ladies uh fighting for in terms of
prize money Anastasia really good price
is 160 thousand and what is also
important five plus five hundred dollars
five hundred dollars more yes
and then we have first place forty
thousand and second place Thirty
Southern third place also great price
for twenty thousand dollars and um or in
an open section yes in the open section
I think for 260 plus two well done
surprise for the really decent great
price function do you remember Wesley so
mentioned yesterday that the price fund
has been increased and it's really
important for the players so 60 000 is a
great price for the champion absolutely
and there again you see the players uh
getting wandered Arena crash ready to
get to her boards the the Bell has
sounded and the games are underway begum
opened up with Knight F3 D5 G3 and I
really like this move G7 G6 uh by uh
Megan I really want to credit uh most
especially vishwanathon and nand for
playing this particular move order as he
did it against Magnus Carlson in their
world championship in the days that uh I
played I was really attracted as black
to these variations uh we called it the
London system by the way this was uh but
it was all the rage yeah it was all the
rage on the black side and what I really
particularly liked about this particular
line of defense was that you would play
the move H6 and Tuck the bishop back on
the Square H7 I prefer to play with
Bishop G4
played Bishop G4 and captures on F3 very
early I always thought that was a real
surprise to me but I like this one of
the things that I like about this move
G7 G6 is it really asked white what they
want to do in the center from Black's
point of view Bishop G7 E5 clear if I
play Bishop G7 and E5 I'll be slightly
better I'll have occupied the center and
if you end up playing the move d2d4 to
stop that yes then the idea of Bishop G2
with the pawn on D3 means you're not
playing D3 and E4 or D3 and C4 to open
up the bishop and the players are
actually transposing into would you call
this a groomfelder king's Indian that's
a hybrid a hybrid that is a hybrid yes
okay in in general especially if we see
the moves C4 and C6 we call all that a
roofer slav hybrid
grunfels love hybrid yes just rolls off
the tongue it's sort of
nice let's jump to ashwitha versus
please you jump into that I think we
have some quite intriguing opening
choices let's do it take a look at what
the Wonder is doing e45 Knight F3 Knight
F6 sure okay I'm going to go there with
a real Lopez you want to play a very uh
tame opening a very solid opening might
take C5 Knight takes E4 really but this
is non-queen I've learned this line when
I was six years of age right and I know
that Queenie too I cannot go back with
my knight because I lose after Knight to
C6 and this is over right right you
never take on e4 after the move Knight
takes E5 a one or two only four and
right now what I'm expecting most likely
after Queen to E2 is this idea of Queen
to E7 give the Knight D6 and uh after
this D4 or F4 are two couple of options
if you go D4 I'm going to take take a
knight to C6 we've seen a Wonder play
very uh weird stuff in this tournament
successfully so he uh played very weird
stuff against Levon aronian very
successfully in that one against Sam
Shanklin yesterday quite successful
opening as well he did not manage to win
that but he was putting a lot of early
on uh pressure on his opponent and you
can see immediately played 27 years old
he's smiling a little bit inside when is
the last time I looked at this Knight
takes E4 when you were six years old
this is unbelievable Yes actually I was
wondering once I was showing to one of
my students this easy trick right is
nine to six and I was I was wondering
actually what happens if you play Queen
is 76 I thought about it by the way it's
really funny that it appeared on The
Voice it's very funny so what do you
think it was just a blunder you know
I absolutely prefer this is preparation
okay but now that we we we've had a time
to chuckle and smile and laugh about uh
the opening what is the state of the
theory of this line because for sure it
has been played before absolutely it has
been played countless of times now there
is a bunch of options for White Once
Again D4 this is the big main option uh
right now after the move D6 F4 D4 how
are you going to defend that night D4
seems to be the main line bkc5 D takes
C5 Knight to C6 of course I'm
threatening to take uh the pawn on E5 so
you have to do something uh and create
new threats so what is the weakness in
Black's position probably the pawn on C7
especially after after trade of the
Queens so how do I gather really quickly
with the move a knight to C3 if you play
the move Bishop to B5 I think Bishop to
D7 and even if you take take you still
have the G2 Pawn to worry about now you
gave me the two Bishops this is not good
this is not the idea so you cannot do
that before I do believe that in general
Bishop 5 and Bishop D7 do we have Bishop
perform no no I meant instead of Bishop
B5 let's just defend the pawn with
Bishop oh Bishop to F4 okay I will go G5
in fact ah G5 yes wow yes and this is
the line G5 and now if you go Bishop to
G3 F5 take a look at this and F4 and
actually you're just simply losing so
yeah this is a piece this is a trap in
the position
you cannot ambassad of course because
you lose the wins so uh and if you don't
if you we draw the queen metaphor
perhaps the bishop on G3 so you cannot
play like this you have to be a bit
careful now what seems to be the best
move is just simply develop okay go
towards the weakness
Queen takes E5 take on E5 take on E5 and
Knight to B5 and it's a bit awkward for
black to defend this Pawn on C7 you can
do so with the move King to d8 but that
King is probably going to be subject to
a lot of attacks right even something
like Bishop to G5 followed by long cast
or this could be an idea as well right
so
I'm wondering what a Wonder prepared for
uh this one and I'm sure we will uh see
what he did uh will Fabiano caruana try
to save that pawn as you are doing with
the move Bishop F4 or will he say okay
you take it back but in the meantime I'm
going to set this nice Knight on B5 and
put a lot of pressure on your position
and take a look at Hans fashionably late
10 minutes late well he might have got
stuck behind that uh
security checkpoint
probably and it looks like Wesley's uh
prepping a no I was about to say Berlin
one thing I want to say about piano the
opening choices of a wonder is you need
guts to actually play these type of
things right 750 plus players right wow
yes Sam Shanklin now we see that the
same thing basically the same type of
opening
um very sidelinish against carwana I
think
never ever you could imagine in your
life
you know you study these deep lines and
25 moves you know these variations and
then you have this one which you learned
when you were a kid it's funny because I
think we looked at it during the World
Championship no no way really really I
think we looked at it for about 30
minutes
this is not going to happen just because
uh Fabi is actually stopping and staring
it's kind of caused me to do the same uh
you mentioned that D4 is the main move
and I can quite understand why but now
that I'm seeing that in many lines I'm
simply returning the pawn I imagine that
I try to be very very greedy and simply
maintain the pawn with F4 what's the
what's the
um
uh Theory there's a couple of ways which
I can play after refwork most likely I
will take on E5 and I'll take recapture
with the f-part with the F Pawn and now
once again I have a couple of options F6
or F5 but let's say f
well F6 is kind of what I was hoping you
would do because I was going to go
Knight C3 and if you recapture with the
queen with a queen I was just thinking
that
well I mean I'm not even forced to take
on e4 I might play on E5 sorry I might
even play something like Bishop C4 and
just tried to say why did you play the
move F6 well absolutely yes absolutely
so white needs to have a couple of ideas
in which he's going to be strategically
better by giving up the pawn back right
right he needs to have some ideas in
this type of positions that's why Knight
takes C4 is not being played
level right there there is a way maybe
multiple ways to get an advantage with
the white pieces but we don't know how
deep actually a Wonder uh analyzed all
of these lines right and if you did go
deep enough maybe you need Super precise
moves with the white pieces to maintain
a slim Edge maybe 0.5 and a Wonder
things that okay I have the knowledge
I've been analyzing this for a few hours
with the help of the engines I'm going
to be able to neutralize your openness
possible yes this is really possible
otherwise you normally don't play it and
you don't feel so confident at this
moment right he's walking around waiting
for the move
yeah I remember it was a game of Sam
Shanklin I believe it was in fact the
the the the tournament that Sam Shanklin
won the U.S Championship Sam Champion
was white a Wonder Liang was black and
uh in a variation of the Karo Khan that
I had actually paid played you know like
my whole life I wonder uh played A
variation that I'd never seen even never
mind you know and it was like they both
played a la Tempo like Sam Shanklin
incredibly well versed in his opening
preparation knew even What a Wonder did
this incredible sideline and we're
seeing the same today with this very
strange sideline that well I'm with
Christian 100 haven't seen it since I
was 12. I mean I I we all understood
what what happened and I think well I'm
I may have won a Scholastic game or two
as has everybody else yes yes
discovered check and you pick up the
Queen Once the Knight goes back but of
course we need to and uh here we are
Fabi uh considering his uh choices D4 uh
the main line F4 uh might be might be
more challenging we'll keep an eye on
that uh now that we're here in the open
section that is to say let's take a look
at the game of Ray Robson Ray Robson
again comes into this round as the
hottest player in the tournaments he's
won three in a row yes
it's not a joke it's not a joke it's so
hard to win in chess against the very
very very top today remarkably he's
three in a row and he's got the white
pieces yes uh maybe Opportunity Knocks
against Alex Slenderman we've seen this
line of the this is
a number Bishop E2 I remember
vessel and topolov World Champion vessel
on the toplov playing Bishop D2 Queen B3
in his practice Bishop B2 and castles
that's a little confounding by Rey
because this whole plan of white is to
play Knight takes E4 you know getting
written Knight H4 takes G6
this whole idea of opening up that H
file and putting your king under assault
wow that's uh
it's all standard stuff though I mean
this is how folks are playing this this
opening
intriguing uh
and uh just the lifetime score between
many times right let's see lots of U.S
championships yes three weeks okay
actually a little nice surprise from uh
Linderman is he's got an edge over Ray
Ray with uh four losses four draws uh
poor Ray there and Linderman I mean
right now he's around 26 uh 10 perhaps
well maybe even less than that but he's
been around 2660 for a very long time
he's a player who can beat anyone
absolutely he has no problems with like
you know too much of respect to the
players who play stronger than him he
just plays against anyone then just
could do his best he's a great player of
course and especially in the opening
phase he's very well prepared uh tell me
about the approach that Rey has taken in
this particular position uh Christian he
just I was just about this is the key
actually yeah is there a question is the
key yeah after the movie Knight to H4
because black not only has this move
Bishop to G6 but also this is the bishop
to E4 and we've seen this game before I
I think in the ladies section yeah this
tournament and now you usually go with
F3 Bishop to G6 and now the setup is a
bit different because you already played
the move F3 so what you're going to do
as white you're actually going to Castle
long side you're going to go Queen to B3
Bishop to D2 whenever you see uh this
potential attack Brewing on this side so
for example Bishop to D6 you go ideas of
G3 right G3 you take on G6 go a long
castle and try to put I think it was
Jennifer you versus Alice Lee and
Jennifer had a tremendous position she
spoiled her advantage and almost lost in
that one so those were the options now
let everyone played the move Bishop to
G6 directly you're not forcing this Pawn
to go to F3 so now the potential of uh
castling on the short side is much more
appealing for white because you haven't
moved uh F3 in front of your king so you
go Bishop to E2 Bishop to D6
or Knight bd7 Castle Bishop to D6 G3 and
now we see short Castle Knight takes G6
we expect H takes G6 there is absolutely
no reason why you would take with the F
Pawn H takes G6 and these are the type
of positions that we're going to see
right now uh for a black black wants to
play either C5 or E5 open up in the
center white is going to enjoy uh his
two Bishops Advantage for a while right
now so I'm definitely liking what Rey is
doing nevertheless the theory goes a
long way in this type of positions and
it's going to come down to who analyzed
better this in ceiling middle game very
very true the depth of the and the
quality of the preparation is all
decisive turning our attention to the
game between Lanier and Sam Savion I
must say I'm really stunned by Lanier's
Choice okay it's this open Spanish Sam
had played it earlier in the tournament
against Sam Shanklin so it's not a
surprise for Lanier what's surprising
for me Is Lanier's Choice he decided to
Simply take on G5 and I'm looking at
that and I'm going okay Bishop takes F4
Bishop back to E7 Queen to F3 and I'm
thinking to myself what is it about this
position in particular that attracted uh
Lanier because after Rook d8 Rook D1 I'm
looking at it I'm seeing Bishops of
opposite color yes exactly and I'm
thinking this is like a dream come true
for black I mean Bishops of opposite of
color middle game
a lot of things will probably be traded
down the D file like you can imagine for
example a move like C4 just putting this
move on the board and if you play Rook
D2 and I go be sure Jack and you move
your king you can imagine that after D4
a lot of hacking yes and black makes a
very comfortable draw I mean you know
your event your opening Advantage is
white is gone as far as I can see so
Lanier a great theoretician has
surprised me by playing a move a line
that I find well Frankly Speaking rather
tame I'll see if I'm wrong about this I
don't think so but maybe he wants to
play some time maybe like A4 maybe he
has something in his mind maybe it would
like to open the position a little bit
no question that A4 is very standard way
of getting uh the I mean he didn't play
Rook A1 to D1 he left his Rook on A1
with uh that very specific ID here
Anastasia that you just mentioned that
hey maybe I will play in this case you
just have to consider that black uh has
that but also may just ask you the same
question great congratulations you got
in A4 and I'm going to help help a
moment I'm not going to do anything
crafty like D4 D3 just great you've got
your Rook on the open a file but how
important is it good question yes it's I
mean if I could manage to somehow play
B3 at certain point and open my Bishop
maybe it will be something but I don't
see the way actually so I'm trying to
I'm struggling to see Bishops there's a
color uh not too much going on this is a
no no no this is actually an extremely
uh testing line please for black yeah I
remember I looked at this uh with one of
my students Gregory Oparin and we were
surprised to see it also in one of
Alejandro Stevens star uses virtues book
with uh the white pieces so he was
developing this position for quite a
long time in fact you want to put a lot
of pressure on the pawn on D5 how do you
uh defend that as black the main line
seems to be going after C4 yes C4 so you
go C4 yes I want to play Bishop to C5
and then double up on the D file clear
this is the plan so let's keep going
with that C4 let's say Rook to D2
Rook D1 it's very standard stuff okay
D4 let's go D4 I think
what if I just take with the point take
and let's say am I doing this in the
right way or the wrong way I think that
particular position is not good yeah no
then I have to do it the other way
Bishop C5 Check Yes okay
King H1 D4 no no no no I go King F1 in
fact oh excuse me F1 I will go King F1
okay and I think this is the most
testing if I remember uh the analysis
I've done it like a year and a half ago
but
um D4 I take I have to take yes
you don't want to allow this three no
absolutely not no mistake take Rook D1
Rook to D1 right so you really are
challenging uh you have a rook D6 I do
have a rookie six yeah okay yeah and
let's take a look actually uh what the
engine is recommending okay because I'm
curious I do believe that yeah D4 is
wrong yeah D4 I remember this is is
wrong take take yes and Rook to D1 Rook
to Da yeah this is already problematic
and G4 this was the key G4 if you take I
have Queen E4 attacking the bishop this
is the key yes this move G4 is the key
now the main line goes and this already
has been played quite a few times it
goes something like this King to F1 Rook
to D7 or Rook to F7 with the same idea
on the D file Rook today E1 Rook to d8
and if I remember correctly H3 was
played but we were looking at H4 and
this is a novelty so maybe linear found
the same ideas that we did and he will
go for this novelty with the move H4 in
case Sam Savion follows the main line H3
was played in uh the previous games
just showed the novelty yeah maybe you
are not allowed to do so
it's fine it's fine it's okay Missouri
isn't patenting any of this
I mean immediately I started to think
like maybe you shouldn't we'll see it
it's fine it's not such a big novelty I
think a lot of the top players already
know it because this one has been played
quite black has to delay D5 D4 not rush
yes don't rush it because you have this
move G4 and and this is the key G4 ft G4
and queen E4 this is what I'm talking
about
um yeah so it's very interesting the
position which looks so simple in the
way to announce it it's so complicated
and with so many knowledge oh my
goodness thank you so much for
explaining the details easy to fall into
uh under duress because again it just
looks so simple you go Bishop C5 check
you go D4 you put your Bishop on for and
you're thinking what the worst can
happen and I just wanted to see it
double check okay I take a pawn yes yes
I understand I should never allow such
things but uh how bad or good is it F5
is coming under duress so like if I just
drop my queen back uh Queen D5 D5 check
is the problem that I'm facing and I
don't really have okay here's what I'm
looking at I'm trying to you know maybe
get at whites King 2 right but
um how would this line continue you
could take a pawn
nothing wrong with grabbing a pawn but I
was hoping that Queen
jumped foreign
just clear the comments maybe just just
G3
you're very right
just stopping me just like that yeah and
I was thinking that I could bring my
Bishop around but okay just Bishop
a37. so Bishop A3 Rook D7 yeah now that
Queen cannot go to H4
you can go Queen to C5 unless it is
Queen B7
you're already lost right now wow yes
you're so easy to fall into such a a
trap and I guarantee you this is Lanier
knows all of this of course of course he
knows all of these moves yeah wow so
great stuff all right we're keeping
so after all of his prep and trickiness
uh the guy who's staring at the board is
a Wonder Liang let's just jump to Fabby
this was this look at his face emotions
actually I think he's I'm just trying to
remember he's trying to remember uh his
his prep okay so Fabi did play D4 yes
takes Knight C6 Bishop B5 the move you
mentioned
um Christian Bishop D7 Knight C3 and
we're we're stopped for the moment okay
it's clear yeah
right okay nice and it's probably clear
that Knight takes is also a blunder no
um something on B7 but not immediately
because actually maybe not look at this
time
yeah no that that that's a clear card
yes pressure so you have to Castle and
say okay I'm deferring my captures here
um
okay so what's nice that's what I think
that's move yes Knight D5 again but if
you go 95 I can take only five right no
then I can take on exactly no then I'm
then I'm happy all right oh with black
yeah yeah yeah I'm happy with black so
yeah so I have to play bishop and I
think actually that's worth mentioning
why are you happy and why can't I why
can't I take on E5 after castle
that Bishop takes C6 no no no no with
Castle yes precisely with castles Knight
D5 now Queen takes E5 you don't have
Bishop C6 yes because you close this
diagonal nice and I don't protect my
queen in this case here I just have to
trade queens and I have nothing as white
there's so much just defend the pawn
right yes but what if I go Queen to B4
now this is the question but
are the tactics just enough yeah
take take and take only five and take
only five yes but it's not it's not the
end of the story because F7 is still a
little weak yes
whoops is this
not good for
that is a great question uh looks good
yeah that looks really good for white
okay let's let's try to be clever
yes you mentioned it just did you find
this move before it doesn't work anymore
or what well G5 I can go Knight D5
like also yes and actually just even if
I will not be the same thread because
you can just take it yes but even in
this case I I mean at least I do have
that but yeah 85 might hurt I don't know
and then I was hanging or not no right
okay so it's funny please over to you
Chris let's go towards at the end of
that line that we were discussing with
Queen before so once you land on G5 I
actually have this move Bishop to E7 wow
I thought you can take on F7 but now I
got 88 you take and I take on F4 and
then I will trap the knife wow is it so
sure it seems to be it yes you can go
rookie one and I go King d8 I don't open
up the E file because you have Rook to
E8 so I go King to d8 let's say Rook 2
E6 I go back let's say you attack it
right or you can go yes if you attack I
have check and then pick it up right or
you can go Knight to G6 Knight to G6 and
then we will have this end game which
seems to be equal
this can be considered equal I will go
Bishop F6 King E7 Knight to E5 despite
the fact that you have two pawns uh my
two pieces are quite active and they can
get quite active it's a balanced end
game but I do think uh the the main line
probably will end in a draw so wow but
of course you see all of this and if you
don't know the theory and maybe a Wonder
actually doesn't know the theory and I'm
saying that a diary is Theory because
there have been games played in this
line all the way to Bishop to E7
so Bishop to E7 has been played three
times in fact by some pretty known Grand
Masters so quite an intriguing line
let's see if a Wonder remembers what he
studied at home he should have studied
this position at home because I mean you
didn't expect it you dictated what you
wanted to see in this game the type of
positions and the type of opening that
you wanted to see in this game you have
to be ready for it absolutely uh just
turning our attention to the game of
darush and elshon for this moment again
uh boldly stating the obvious al-shan is
having a woeful event he's been in a
spin cycle where he's been
blundering games away and even just
being soundly outplayed as was the case
yesterday so darush is sitting there
saying okay I need one more point to go
with my plus score I've got you Alshon
in my sights I'm white
and I am going to play for a win Alshon
says do your worst so we get to this
position and after Bishop Ace 6 93
and I always like these positions
interesting enough for black yes or
black and the reason why I like these
positions for black is so very often
it's not easy for white to develop this
bishop you might think to yourself oh
great I'm going to play E4 and win a
Tempo I have a central Bond my Bishop
comes out
where
it's not so effective on F4 G5 is
protected and E3 it looks good yes it
looks what exactly is it doing so elshon
with the position after Knight C6 he
says you know what I have in my sights
the C4 Square read a nice course like go
ahead if you like and kick me I will
occupy E4 and go ahead and if you like
uh exchange
um queens and at the end of the day
again I ask you a question where is your
Bishop going to be really effective
right well it's not E3 anymore F4 looks
good but maybe I'll just castle and then
again I'll ask the question what your
Bishop is and if you go to G5 I get that
that's actually a pretty decent Square
for now and um well you might be trading
your Bishop very shortly for my knight
but it is one of those positions that I
end up liking look no I also like it I
mean also with this Knight on C4 can be
really unpleasant exactly exactly we'll
keep in mind everything on that one uh
just checking in on our defending
Champion uh Wesley sub not having a good
tournament we'll leave it at that he is
up against Hans Neiman today and it's a
Joko piano it's A5 don't ask me why
that's there are different you should
say 506 my goodness choose A5 stopping
before ideas and so on Clever and he
brought his Queen to A7 rookie two now
A4 basically is a way of trying to
isolate this bishop and saying okay I
might play Queen A5 trap the bishop and
he did uh forced uh White to give up the
light Square bishop and revoked C4 my
goodness I will just say that we're
probably in some very very
deep preparation of the players they
both playing pretty quickly says
Neiman's actually just blitzed out 26
minutes one hour 26 minutes just one
hour 19. so he's happy about his
preparation Jeffrey Zhang one of our
players was having another another one
of our players having that undefeated uh
tournament uh just picked up a point uh
Scotch
yes yes it's it is and f4d5
well the venerable Scotch comes and goes
waxes and Lanes uh D4 uh pardon me uh D5
attacking Pawn on C4
oftentimes you really don't want to
capture and it's sort of like it's one
of those positions where after a move
like D3 for example you're kind of happy
that your opponent is captured because
these pawns you know they have a have I
mean white does some very very strange
things in these positions and somehow
gets an advantage we'll keep an eye on
this one let's go to the ladies I was
very anxious to see what uh Arena Crush
was going to do against her 13 year old
rival and guess what she played a very
complicated
[Music]
um
opening with this I want to say
invitation shall we dance to uh Bob
vinic Pond sacrifice uh variation okay
well Allison no thank you
let's go into the Miranda
with Bishop E2 B3 this is a quiet system
uh I I usually prefer his white to put
my develop my Bishop on D3 let's see
what Alice had in mind
and we have caught up to the players
after the move H7 H6 well all the pieces
are on the board we can get one of those
who we call hanging Pawn structures in
the center of the board C5 and D5 is not
an isolated
pawns they have different groups exactly
exactly I don't know what the rules are
I have no idea also but I remember that
once you push one of them
my rule if there is a rule of hanging
ponds is when I have them yes I want to
keep as many pieces on the board as they
can yes exactly when I'm playing against
them let's play major peace endings I
think it also applies for a isolated
bone though
that's why I remember it so well it
works for for both it's good when some
rules work in different situations you
don't you don't need to remember too
much exactly exactly okay well keep an
eye on that uh let me go to Megan's game
uh where she is up against vegan let's
see what's happened here okay this was
this was the hybrid the the neo-grunfeld
Indian hybrid big love between something
C7 C6 uh Knight C3 takes takes takes and
that's a little a different approach
than I'm used to E4 Bishop to G4 Queen
E2 gift me the pawn back yes P5 no and
we stop okay uh the clock times who's
played it slower I think Megan is
thinking Megan's slightly slower yes one
hour and 14 minutes for Megan one hour
and 20 minutes for uh begging
the preparation yes yeah okay can you
help us what what is the story on this
position yeah absolutely absolutely so
it all started uh somewhere around here
yeah and of course sure Castle is the
main line right just copy whatever your
opponent does castle castle and we're
going to play this type of position C4
and C6 of course C4 is not even uh uh
well it is the main line but it's not
forced you can play Bishop to F4 you can
start with Knight D2 you can go C3 you
can even go things such as A4 and try to
take more space on the queen side but C4
Remains the main line now Knight to E4
immediately places this Knight in the
center but also this Knight could become
a liability because I I'm going to
attack it immediately after move C4
which was played C6 and Knight to C3 now
if you Castle
I have ideas of even taking taking a
knight to E5 I don't have to do this
Knight to G5 as well and the potential
exchange of the D4 and E4 pawns but
after Castle
I can also just simply put more pressure
on D5 and take advantage of the fact
that you already removed this Defender
from F6 or Leon and I can start with the
move Queen to B3 that is going to ask
some very important questions how are
you going to defend this Pawn on uh D5
if you go to move E6 well the problem is
you play the movie six you solidified
the center but the bishop C8 is still
not out it's not on F5 it's not on G4 so
the bishop on C8 is going to be
problematic for the remainder of the
middle game that's why black decided to
go Knight takes C3 B takes C3 and
accepted this Pawn sacrifice with the
move D takes C4 I'm not sure if I like
what black is doing right now Bishop to
G4 was her move and queen to E2 it seems
like H3 which is very typical in this
type of situations would have been much
better H3 Bishop takes F3 I take in one
move I don't lose a Tempo with Queen to
E2 I go Queen to F3 in one play and
right now if you go Castle I'm going to
shut down this bishop with this move uh
E5 you are a pawn up I understand that
but you have huge problems on the king
side and I'm going to exploit them very
easily whatever you do Knight D7 Queen
to D7 Queen to C7 I'm going to go H4 for
example
Knight to D7 H4 you have to defend
against H5 if you allow me to go H5 then
I'm going to open up things on the king
side on my terms and most likely you
will get checkmated so if you do play
the move H5 then G4 is going to come
there is no way to break with F6 because
whenever you go F6 I go E6 and you're in
deep deep trouble right we can see the
bishopone G7 suffering in the position
and also you don't have enough Defenders
around your king side so this one is
already extremely problematic for black
a nice Pawn sacrifice an ideal situation
for a pawn sacrifice for white she did
not do that she played the move Queen to
E2 which makes a lot of sense also right
you're attacking the pawn on C4 you
actually want to recapture the pawn as
fast as possible but it's not as
aggressive and not as decisive and let's
take a look at our soul leaders road
ahead Megan Lee's World ahead
today well she's uh facing Tokyo Nova
with the black pieces tomorrow against
Cervantes with the white pieces back
against riyan Yang White against the
struggling Sophie Maurice Suzuki and she
finishes it off in round 13 Championship
round with the black pieces against the
youngster Alice Lee that's a difficult
route that is definitely a marquee
matchup you can almost see that round
13. I don't know if it's a train wreck
or whatever it is but that's going to be
a clash that round 13. now this move
Queen E2 I heard everything you were
saying about those Pawn sacrifices yes
but if I'm sitting there in Megan's
shoes oh don't tell me you want to play
B5 I do just let's check it I mean I
mean why I'm playing this love playing a
slav defense the move B7 B5 is a very
standard I mean I could go into a kind
of grunfell which oh
I wanted to open it directly with the
movie five ah just like just just right
now yes E5 okay
um
A4 is a good move as well but what if I
go E5 and then H3 like how do you
respond well I just just just just hold
your horses life is good
uh I know you're ready to uh Rumble here
Rumble in the Jungle uh gonna try to
borrow a page out of the book of uh
Robert Byrne and David bronstein I want
to play Knight A6 okay okay so what if I
go H3 and I go back oh you drop back
but now I go Knight G5 no no no no no no
no no no no
sir
in big trouble this is this is the
Robert Byrne method you know you just uh
you just roll with the punches how how
bad is it
huh if I can put a knight on D5 okay
let's go F4 I I want to compare four
steam yeah steamrolley over yes F4 coach
coach uh you know
[Laughter]
um F4 G4 F5 I'm coming I'm coming after
you yeah
yes no no no you're not no you're not do
you have nothing I thought maybe in some
Mauritius but no no it is only maybe
after five
this is I've
I'm cramped I'm cramped can I show a
nice line I want to play give me the
pleasure of showing them yes please yes
please what if you go Knight D5 and by
the way A4 was played by Tokyo channel
oh yes which is very very standard
absolutely 95 you know my students
play it automatically and then you start
thinking I think okay D5 now I take on
D5 right okay this is at least what I
wanted I don't know if I should start
with taking on D5 or no five five and if
you take with the bishop I'll take that
Bishop as well and then I'll go E6 and
then I'll pray that I'm going to check
I'm not sure but it looks nice well I
mean you could also play six no it
definitely looks uh frisky but are you
sure you're checkmating me no no I'm not
sure of anything I haven't checked this
with uh engines or anything with my good
friend but stockfish yeah I have not oh
no no no
E6 it's E6 okay I want to preserve the
night okay so now I'm thinking of taking
on G6 okay wow actually it's all very
exciting but I just don't know if it's
uh
you don't see it yeah
yes but nothing is because
one should we start with Bishop ah but
this P3 seems a bit too slow right
Bishop E3 kind of gives me the tempo I
need just to kind of okay let's go
Bishop F4 location
P5 and actually exchange your dark
Square Bishop okay I'll uh and now G4 G4
I'll invite you to sacrifice yeah which
you probably will
okay okay
uh you'll take it right this is called
chess boxing yes well I played this one
yeah well one of the things that we're
doing is just playing what we see as a
standard Orthodox patterns for these
types of positions and again we're just
kind of throwing the patties here a
little bit uh but I must say that for me
if I was in white shoes I would find the
move A2 A4 the most attractive yes I
would just probably play it kind of
automatically which is what bacon did
for example it completely Cuts this idea
of Knight A6 like you cannot wait
that's one of the one of the benefits of
the move A4 but now I can you know
because you haven't played the move E5 I
can start thinking maybe I should be the
one playing E4 like if you play like
this let me just do this on the board
because your Pawn's not on E5 I start
thinking aha maybe you can okay maybe
but now we're gonna get some
really really seven scary Five For
example oh you don't need to play H3 I
can now play E5 okay hoping to play now
you don't have seven also sometimes
exactly right so well as Bobby Fischer
said you know to get squares you got to
give them I mean and this the this uh
fight that we're seeing uh is well it's
it's great I mean it's fun I I like the
material myself but other players will
like the dynamic attacking chances when
you've played the move E5 by the way do
don't forget that after you move age
three I'm coming back
oh really okay
like don't think that you're just going
to
flatten me you know like with uh so
perhaps let's do this yes sir what if we
start with H3
you're making a great Point yes yes
yeah because in this moment maybe you're
not happy so let's go back before E4
right so I'm gonna go Knight D7 and now
H3 and now H3 right away and because you
created this idea I will take with the
queen probably it was a queen yes with
the queen okay and now you go E5 right I
did five or what no I actually wanted to
go [ __ ] pay three yeah this is infer
penny in for a pound second and if I
take
it's too complicated what you give a
check I go King the eight
you go on E7 at the end of it but I go
C6 and I'm still two pawns up you you
take a few but
you're making an argument for me to
continue the attack
we don't need to play quinces it's
really beautiful but well thank you it's
really nice but maybe we can just keep I
think it's not going anywhere okay one
first and then same idea Queen C6 is not
it's heroic yes I I liked it yes
this is completely lost yeah of course
yes
okay well boy boy we're getting excited
over this one well we're going to keep
an eye on Megan Lee our our leaders game
one thing as a coach that finally in
round nine yes as the good coach that I
am realized is that my student always
gets off the board
after she makes a move oh really so
that's something that I will have to
address with her because she's losing so
much time of thinking right right and uh
that was one of her pitfalls in this
event she was in time travel in a few
games right and she did not act
correctly during those games but we were
not and by the way we don't have access
to the playing hall right because
Spectators are not allowed no but so we
don't know exactly I didn't know at
least once no no you can if you really
want to go it's possible because they
said about it like you you will be
accompanied with someone from the chess
club but I mean you're like VIP of
course you're ready see that's what I
mean that's why I like my my job I I
have a front row seat and they actually
call me VIP like I'm a very important
person or something like that
thank you thank you
we're gonna we're gonna keep an eye on
our tournament leader no question about
it we saw the game of in a crash against
Alice Lee that was the hanging pawns if
you will but I we didn't pick up on
Jennifer Jennifer is half a point out of
uh the first place as well and this
looks like it comes from a Karo Khan
uh this um
normally have two possibilities right
yes so the one I liked and I played it
uh very often in my career is the David
bronstein method of recapturing and
whereas this recapture is considered the
most solid and by the way I remember
Arena crash on the black side playing
against tatv in a U.S Women's
Championship where she played a
brilliant game tatev is a really really
aggressive opponent she likes to go all
out and Arena ended up playing this
incredible move H7 H5 in that game and
what a model game as black let's see how
Jennifer handles her business c2c3 no
Bishop D6 for Jennifer Jennifer
understands that White's ideal
development scheme of development is
Bishop on D3 Queen on C2 Knight on on E2
notice that if you did in this position
play the move Knight F3 the Knight would
like to ask you a question what's my
next move yes I'm not going here and I'm
not going here so all the good squares
that I want to go to are protected so
that's why we want to put the Knight on
E2 and Jennifer said look when you play
the move C3 I'm going to play Bishop F5
in order to cross you up yes so that you
can't get the scheme of development you
want ashwitha said okay my Bishop's
happy on C4 maybe I'll go Queen B3 go
ahead actually
she ended up putting her Knight on F3
usually that's not the best Square for
the night Knight to D7 already I start
to think well since I've already messed
you up with putting your night and queen
maybe I should just
trade actually yeah so you would lose
the Tempe and you'll just play Bishop
G40 well yeah but the bishop will go
back to C4 and we'll go back to E2 but
you're right I hate losing Tempe 2.97.
okay first we took with the King uh I
always say the opening is over when
either player has connected their Rooks
so from Jennifer's point of view hey
she's ready to play the middle game
castles rookie eight night Bishop wow
they played so quickly I almost have the
the feeling that they must be in some
kind of preparation here because they've
been playing it very quickly and I think
Jennifer's fine I'm not sure what the
night on H
um four is really doing maybe she wants
to play F4 and the five
four white yes and that's why then at
least I can understand why what why the
Knight is doing an age
interesting that would be very
aggressive I mean you you take some
responsibility with these uh of course
you know uh pushing uh pushing uh
according to the king side but look at
him and if I manage
for example just to demonstrate and if
you play F4 uh I don't like my
configuration so I'll just uh I on a
good day I'm thinking I'm gonna move the
bishop and play Knight to E6 try to
tickle yes the fact that the pawn on D4
doesn't have a Defender that's a good
point yes I mean but let's say if I play
a five you're already you just move the
bishop right let's see just to show it
yes and I have to play Bishop D2
something like that right exactly and
Away you go
um
I don't know I mean do you want to play
G5 sometimes that's a good question too
exactly
exactly so this point on the file can be
weak at a certain point but for the
moment it's cramping yeah I mean I would
love to have my knight on E6 and I don't
have that so some space for white uh
we'll leave it there uh of course uh
once again a big shout out to our
audience thank you so much for joining
us and sharing your day with Anastasia
Christian and myself but we also like to
invite you to join our show ask
questions yes and how can our audience
do that our audience can follow our
social media accounts and especially
Twitter account of St Louis chess club
and then you just use hashtag us chess
Champs and then you will come directly
to the studio if your question is nice
it's good so subscribers get preference
right and we do have some questions
let's let's uh get one from Al to here
yes and the question is which chest
tactical theme is the most appealing to
you oh for me it's not even close I I
fell in love with chess because of the
smothered mate the one I go Queen check
night Check Yes night double check yes
give up the queen smothered mate yes
when I saw that for the first time it
was like
explosions
oh everything I mean it was like
fireworks Galore I loved it what about
you I don't know I remember when I was a
kid I lost this game where my opponent
made Three Forks in a row and basically
all my pieces you know with the knife
then another room imagine I had all this
I had all these pieces had extra pieces
the green
wasp and lost his Queen probably
somewhere on the way so I had all this
pieces and suddenly I lost all of them
so I mean guys watch out this works
there
we call it intermediate move right in
English but I like how it sounds right
and also
it's funny that many what I noticed even
on chesscom website they have these
themes yeah
intermediate to move they write a
decision to get nobody knows what does
it mean and nobody ever checks this kind
of tactical tricks so but but this is a
very important actually idea yes and
chess because let's say you can improve
your Tactical Vision by solving those
kind of puzzles you know looking for
those kind of intermediate moves it's
really important to improve your skills
yeah yes
two questions to you first of all what's
your favorite tactic and then with your
students what do you find that they
gravitating to in their favorite tactics
that's a difficult one
um I guess my favorite tactic my
favorite uh pattern must be the double
attack the double the double attack
especially the double attack with the
Knight
is forking yes I like that I really like
that now related to my students
everybody is different right and I don't
think I I don't think I've ever asked
them what's their uh favorite pattern
but yes for me myself double attack with
the Knight yeah and another a good
question from uh thank you yeah I like
that one uh this one is from sassa
Petrov or
yes yeah some just names yes something
like that yes so Mr Yasser what's a
trendy opening nowadays that wouldn't
we've been considered a theoretical
um Harrison back in your days oh easily
it's not even close uh thank you for the
question it's not even close this
vashnikov
uh today you know is absolutely accepted
as an iron-clad solid uh chest defense
and Magnus Carlson used it to great
effect in neutralizing fabi's one E4 in
their world championship match I mean
you couldn't ask for greater endorsement
but this vashnikov you can look at Bobby
Fischer playing against tigrant
petrozian in the candidates Bobby
Fischer transposed into a position a
Tempo down against this vashnikov
because he thought White's position was
so good so the Old Masters would look at
the special coffin roll in their grave
saying you can't play like this the
square D5 is too weak so that's one
um it always seemed to me funnily enough
that the Dutch defense went through
these gyrations where the Dutch defense
was considered at one time just simply
unplayable you couldn't play it's just
like tigrant Petrosian would take a
square in the center and you're dead
you were just trying to delete it don't
even go there but now you see that even
modern players uh even sharp uh modern
players Nigel short vessel and Topo of
Magnus Carlson has played the Dutch
defense and you go and go
wow uh the Dutch defense was almost
unplayable it was almost dead but now
it's a reincarnation we have fashion
kind of waxes and Lanes what about Queen
syndrome
all all of these old long time solid
defenses again uh waxes and Lanes uh
Queens Indian uh was one time the rigor
and uh today people are playing all
kinds of other systems jump in here
coach with your with your assessment of
a modern opening that today is
considered quite decent versus uh old
old school how about what we've seen in
a wonders game
how about this yeah I believe it's going
to probably become a staple of a defense
for black in upcoming years right this
was heresy 15 minutes ago before we
started the broadcast but I know one is
definitely showing what he's got to be
because he actually equalized he went
into that variation with Queen to B4 and
maybe we can take a look
on your board absolutely but I think
that's boy talk about about being up to
date 15 minutes ago yes
wow situation came just on time right
yeah exactly we want to keep make sure
our audience is on The Cutting Edge of
Chess development as what did happen we
did hold on let me refresh my board for
a second and see what has taken place
Queen before you said it uh he equalized
why did he equalize uh well we've seen
the variation uh with the move Knight to
G5 that we initially yeah that it's
winning right right but it's not and
that one is almost forced this is the
one with the bishop to E7 variation
again
reminders
I talk about uh by the way tactics that
I enjoyed and I always thought this was
really funny uh the player player one
and player a plays Bishop to B5 pinning
the Knight player B breaks the a pin and
gets to play this kind of a capture I
always thought that was hilarious yes
right and this one is actually pretty
funny so everything is forced up to this
moment I saw the move Knight to G5 and I
simply kind of shut down yes
but but Bishop E7 Knight takes Rook to
f8 and it kind of actually just turns
the tables
well enough uh that black actually is
even in this position the Knight is
trapped we actually followed all the way
up to this moment and the engines
politely informed as triple zeros or
something like that all very very very
forcing and we do have this current
position on the board Queen before
Castle is not the only move Christian or
is it
um I mean you can also take on B4 and go
Castle after that we've already oh no
I'm sorry we don't have tassels on the
board before first so you can go Queen
you can do this yeah Queen takes before
Bishop takes before and now Castle
Bishop takes C3 B takes C3 and now
Knight takes uh E5
most likely into this end game take on
B5 you can take on D1 first or take on
G7 let's say uh take on G7 take on D1
Rook takes D1 Rook to G8 Bishop to F6 I
understand I'm not going to be able to
recapture my Pawn with
so you cannot do that but you can just
simply defend with the move Bishop to E7
you are a pawn down but the pawn
structure on the queen side is quite
damaged for white and that allows the
opportunity for me to attack your
weaknesses for example after G3 I go
Rook G6 I swing this Rook all the way to
A6 I put this bishop on E6 defending uh
the pawn on F7 nicely anchored on E6 and
then I'm going to put a lot of pressure
on the A2 Pawn this seems to be leading
uh to pretty much an equal end game
let's wait and see what Fabiano comes up
with but the Wonders opening worked once
again no but once again it worked I
don't want to build history it's an
early gamble right can you imagine like
if somebody plays like that and
equalizes easily with black like I think
it's just he will be really shocked
especially fabric who knows everything
yeah yeah it's really good
um in music after times you have the one
hit Wonder Christian was this going to
be a one-hit wonder
or is it going to be a standard most
likely a one Heath Wonder yeah you you
just kind of trotted out for somebody
you unexpected they look really good in
Blitz and Rapid turns Christian guys you
are a wander you you're actually a
student at University of Chicago you
write papers to submit you probably had
a paper busy busy busy busy super busy
you don't have a lot of time right catch
up in the main lines with this 2800
level no way you can't zero chance yeah
you cannot compete in those lines no so
you have to find something offbeat
something that's going to imbalance your
uh opponent early on and this is exactly
what he did yes yeah good for him and uh
turning our attention to the game
between Ray Robson and Alexander
Lindeman for those who you are joining
us late we mentioned that they're head
to head is actually a smidge in favor of
Alex Slenderman when we left it I was
kind of happy with what Ray had done
he's managed is to win the two Bishops
uh he's got his fair share of the center
maybe even a little bit more of a toll
uh he can look forward to the game for
to the future with confidence until I
saw this move Bishop B2 and I S not a
big fan not a big fan why because Alex
immediately responded Bishop A3 and
denied white the advantage of the two
Bishops and we're catching up with the
players Rook FDA Rook fd1
and the only imbalance that I'm seeing
at this moment Anastasia is the bishop
versus the knight uh the verdict which
minor piece is better well I'll tell you
when the position is closed that is
there's 16 pawns on the board I like the
Knight yes when the position is
semi-closed that is to say 14 pawns on
the board more or less it's about even
and when the position is open I prefer
the bishop so if I'm black in this
position I'm playing the move 94. I'm
very happily forcing the trade of
knights now you may think to yourself
well why did you do that didn't you
double the bonds well yes I did but at
the other hand
I I took away what I think at least is
your best minor piece and I left you
with what I think is a lesser minor
piece now you can look at this position
and you can say oh I see that you want
to go 95 and night
to have three check I can sidestep but
then you start to say to yourself okay
but what are my breaks in the position
well you you probably don't want to play
it no no no no no no no no no just about
the only break you have in the position
is D5 and I can you can imagine for
example Queen C3 you can imagine that I
can easily stop the break uh D5 I'm not
even sure I I might even want to
encourage you I start to think well
maybe I should try to open up the
position on the king side bottom line I
think with the move Knight E4
Lenderman takes a lot of the scare
factor out of the position yes and he
says basically I'm doing fine
and I will mention it again uh three in
a row for Ray Ray what what do you call
four in a row I think
hat trick is three in a row I mean
uh quads
poker poker yes
Bingo five in a row Bingo how do you
call five draws in the row bingo I don't
know
and what do we call Bobby's seven in a
row oh yeah here it comes ready yep the
streak
that was just the streak there was
nothing else to say about it I remember
how much was called it depressing
one of the great lines uh what do you
have for us Christian well I'm looking
at uh this game between linear and Sam
sevion and actually my student that we
were discussing texted me he was like
yeah H4 actually is not a novelty it was
played in the game between Darius Verge
versus grigorio party my student so they
actually played this line Darius came up
with the novelty H4 we don't have it in
the database because I do believe it was
played in one of the Collegiate events
that are generally not transmitted on
leeches so that was a big game and he
actually sent me a screenshot of all the
analysis and it was pretty significant
now what happened in the game was
actually G6 not the move C4 Rook to D2
what we were discussing G6 Rook to D2
let's take a look at what happened Rook
D7 you have to finally set up the
defense of the Pawn on D5 otherwise
you're just simply too late you don't
have any more moves to catch up rook to
d8 and now the move H3 of course and
this is the plan that we were discussing
uh so much and I'm looking at the
position I really like what white is
doing now in general
let's take a look at this move C4 which
was the main line the problem was also
that of the King right the king had to
go either to F1 or H1 and after that
most likely had to lose another Tempe to
let's say go to E2 open up the first
rank to be able to uh put the Rooks on
the G file once the G file opens up but
what we have in the position right now
it's another Square for the King on H2
so for example if you go something like
C4 G4 Bishop to C5 I can go to H2 now
and this is a much better Square for a
my king much more active I'm going to go
Rook to G2 next you're going to have
huge problems with this Pawn on F5 so
I'm starting to look at the position and
I'm seeing real chances for linear to
potentially take the full point in this
big Clash against himself and Sam
sevillan who Sam Savion started off
blazing hot but recently he slowed down
a little bit he hasn't lost the game up
to this point if I'm not mistaken
nevertheless yesterday he was shaky
against Fabiano caruana with the white
pieces he barely escaped that one very
good defense but right now he's
definitely on the back foot and linear
you know knows exactly what to do in
this type of positions and how to apply
pressure against the pawn on D5 and the
pawn on F5 this one is going to be
another tough defense for young Samia
thank you for that Christian and
Anastasia as we get ready for break tell
us about our good friends at Q Boutique
and what is this today's special today
we have this special special mug look at
this yes with the St Louis uh chess club
Crest on it and actually sometimes it
can be with St Louis chess club
sometimes it can be with World Chess
Hall of Fame
um you know logo yes and it feels like a
good mud too yes so sometimes you can
screen printed we'll just Hall of Fame
logo depends on the situation it's
dishwasher safe by the way so you can
wash it everywhere outstanding I was
just about to ask so you can find it in
our cubic yes no microwave so I saw that
all the players were having tea the
other day and I guess they were sure
they had there this is actually this mug
so the players are using as well as
commentators when they want to drink
some tea so please feel free to come to
and shop online right now
all right we're gonna take a break and
we'll see you all on the other side
[Music]
as part of the World Chess Hall of Fame
lecture series author and international
Master John Donaldson will be doing a
live presentation on the 1972 Fisher
spasky match examining their early lives
and careers leading up to their classic
match you can join John live on October
18th at the World Chess Hall of Fame or
watch the live stream on the World Chess
Hall of Fame YouTube channel that's
October 18th John Donaldson live more
information at St louisjessclub.org
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the World Chess Hall of Fame in St Louis
is nothing you'd expect and everything
you love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the World
Chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
can you hear it it's the sound of Hope
and health
and strength it's the sound of
compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear when you really
listen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to round nine of U.S
championships let's check and remember
the standings Megan Lee is leading the
tournament with six points out of eight
and uh Irene across Jennifer you share
the second place only half a point
behalf so they can have good chances to
catch up with the leaders absolutely
close the top yes
on the first place she's playing Arena
Crush today in a marquee match-up that
we're eagerly uh following yes and Bay
game actually plays against Megan Lee
but that's also a very big clash and in
the open section coming into eight
around we're in round nine but after
eight rounds of play Fabiano Carana is
leading the field with six points and
Ray Robson is on the clear second place
with five and a half points thanks to
his Trifecta three wins in a row Ray Ray
Ray is in second place yes they're doing
really great and they managed to have a
gap with third place so I mean they
increase it to one point
and in that third place you would have
seen Lanier and Sam sevillan very very
close and they're playing today we've
got some action we've got action in the
game and between Sam Shanklin and
Christopher you and I've got to say I
don't like what Christopher has done uh
In This Very topical line of the English
he took took and I really like White's
uh decision right here Sam's decision to
recapture with the pawn normally
speaking you don't like the double pawns
but in this particular case it's coming
with a gain of tempo the bishop on C5
under attack was forced to move and now
we start to see why Sam was so eager to
play after the move Bishop G5 the queen
on d8 you don't want to play Queen D7
yeah stepping in the way of the bishop
in the way of the night but yeah we
really want to play the move F6 either
after f six you really compromised your
king site structure and immediately Sam
said well let me go after the spawn on
H7 and here maybe a bit of a
controversial call there to make the
move F5
the problem is remember what I was
saying about effective development you
play Knight A6 and you go yeah yeah
I developed my night you pat yourself on
the back for understanding that you
should develop but then you just said it
Anastasia so very well where is your
night going you don't want to play
Knight to D7 and step in the way the
protection of the pawn maybe it was time
to play Queen F6 G6 something but
sacrificing this Pawn uh I don't think
so I can't imagine that this is at all
any good
move h2h4 reminds me a little bit of
what happened yesterday Ray Robson had
one of the ugliest structures you're
ever going to see in a chess game had
like two sets of double pawns and one
set of triple pumps exactly yes but he
was killing uh elshon because he had all
of the attacking uh uh trumps and in
this position had uh Christopher just
captured yes once again just take a look
at the awful white structure but on the
other hand white is white is the one
with all of the attacking potential H5
Bishop G6 H6 and going after Black's
King so we saw instead the move after H4
D7 so actually Christopher who
sacrificed his Pawn but at least he
thought that now white has no chance to
make Gosling but look this King on that
one he is still feeling quite good on
this position right exactly I think that
it's a good idea to ruin the plans of
your opponent but he didn't achieve the
same white actually enjoy is the fact
that his Rook is on each one exactly and
I think these ideas maybe you start with
Bishop G6 just so that the Rook can't
slide over to A8 but essentially White's
plan is as as straightforward as it
looks you want to go Bishop
play the move Bishop to E3 Bishop to C5
Bishop D2 Bishop B4 Bishop B3 Bishop C5
and so on and so forth and this one this
is how it ended in a draw a fair result
for both of these players a fair result
but a result that injures both of their
chances to get back in the tournament
because neither Hans or Wesley are
defending Champion is doing particularly
well so as a competitor in the
tournament I'm very happy if I was in
the leadership position to see those two
players drawing and nobody is coming up
so to speak at the top let's just
quickly go to a game of Fabi before we
turn to our ladies for a moment because
when we left it Fabi had actually gone
down that whole away yeah that we saw
from afar including up to Knight G5
Bishop E7 and it kind of makes you
wonder how deep
uh the preparation of the players were
because I I'm guessing that h2h4 was a
bit of a novelty exactly at this moment
and it basically says to Black well I
invite you to trade your Bishop for my
knight but if you do I will uh open up
the H file maybe I'll get i'll get a
weakness that I can nibble on and this
is what has happened uh the move F7 F6
by a window and basically a Wonder of
saying is no no you're not scaring me if
you uh these two pawns versus these two
pawns feels very very even Anastasia yes
absolutely I don't I think that a
wonders
um opening uh try worked really well
absolutely yes it worked great to
equalize was that was the player of such
a caliber as Fabiano carono who knows
basically everything yes
it does not easy
and uh
and just because we left our doors
unlocked we got a special guest in the
studio
take a look who's here We snuck in
Maurice Ashley in the studio with us
Maurice welcome welcome St Louis welcome
back to the show what brings you here
St Louis is the chess tournament
happening right I figured I would show
up there is absolutely and you've
participated as a commentator in U.S
championships all throughout the years
for so many years uh how do you feel
about this year's championship what's
different
um well there's some slight controversy
that was preceded this tournament and so
certainly a lot of people are interested
in seeing how that developed it's a
whole new world now I mean I left chess
for one year to go do my writing and and
my chess courses and oh I had problems I
mean it's been wild so I think that that
has kept people on their edges of their
seats and now we're seeing delay 30
minute delay going on and all the new
security measures it's some of it quite
sad for me but it's it's what it seems
like it's needed talk to me about that a
bit did you go to the plane hole at all
did you get uh checked no I'm not
getting bonded
all the craziness no I haven't been to
the playing Hall I literally just landed
and then Tom said get in the chair so
yeah that's why I'm here but uh it I
think it's kind of strange I mean it's
we used to just basically trust people
and now the paranoia is complete and it
just I think a very sad thing for our
game how do you feel all these new
measures change the dynamic of the game
follow players for the commentators
maybe even for spectators I think with
the spectators it's the worst thing I
think the players will just take it in
stride they are just playing chess as
they always have I think for us as
commentators or for you as commentators
you you're probably more assured that
you know it's legit and you get to talk
about a little bit more interesting
stuff stuff that's just crazy though I
mean admittedly when when people are
taking pictures of people being wanded
in certain body parts like that's over
the top I can't but for the spectators I
think it's the worst part because as a
fan you used to be able to go into the
room see the players soak up some of the
atmosphere see these great Giants that
you're you love so much
and now it's like no you're not allowed
in you can't have that and we we've been
dying for years and years as chess
commentators as ambassadors of the game
we want to bring the fans in and now
it's no you can't walk in so I think
that's for me the saddest part of the
whole thing it's definitely a new Chess
World now uh we're going to work you a
little bit yeah I don't even know what's
happening in the position I told you I
just landed first of all this is what
happened in the game between Fabiano and
a Wonder check this out Knight F6 Knight
E5 Knight takes E4 usually a rookie
blunder what is this that's what we
thought as well and take a look he
actually equalized out of the opening I
wonder that is I Wonder has been playing
some funky stuff you gotta admit you
know he keeps saying I'm just a student
yes I'm not really serious and then he
bashes the Ronin over the head uh you
know all these these crazy openings
we're seeing I think when you're free
you can just play chess and it's a nice
place to be no pressure I don't have to
win uh I don't have to win the
tournament big deal I'm a college
student you could just play and you can
experiment and that's not I don't think
the veterans
like to see the young guys being like
this like I don't care I'm just gonna
play anything I want against you I mean
poppy doesn't win this game it'll be
embarrassing like who plays 94 against
you at the Metro and equalizer speaking
of Fabi uh how do you feel about his
performance so far he's been having a
rough year the Olympia the candidates
but now finally it seems like he's back
do you feel the same way the world's not
right without Fabiano caruana playing
good chess like the chess world's just
not right we need to see him playing
well he was a number two player in the
world cemented as such for so long he
was a great Challenger to Magnus uh
fabi's got to be playing well you see
Fabian number what did he drop the
number 12 once or I think he's back at
number five but I mean but he drops I
mean he dropped out of the top ten
Fabiano caruana that's outrageous so to
see him back in the hunt the thing
though about Fabi that's crazy is he
only won one U.S Championship like when
he won his first one we said oh man this
is it he's going to just run them up
he's the best player in the U.S he
hasn't won one since which is insane so
the world's be settle right if he keeps
this up and does what he needs to do and
wins again no surprise to anybody it's
good to see him playing good chess that
was actually the first year he came and
represented the United States that's in
one instantaneously yeah that was his
first one and the last one Let's uh wait
and see whether he has to be able to win
this one as well hasn't Wesley won like
a couple in between
exactly that's crazy
despite him being the number one player
in the country Maurice what are you
doing nowadays you were talking about
courses writings what's uh what's he
says exactly what I'm doing I did a
course for chessable the secrets of
Chess geometry doing quite well I also
wrote a children's book that's going to
be coming out next year I'm in the
process now of writing another book on
chess and uh and then next about to sign
a deal to do yet another but it looks
like I'm fully in content creation mode
I'm like yes everyone
as many books as he has so I'm having a
lot of fun with that I also I'm doing a
lot of corporate speeches corporate
engagements and some traveling as well
coming up in November I'll be going to
Senegal with my two children I've been
to Africa many times but now I finally
get to take the youngins on our first
family trip if you will to Senegal to
Africa so that's something I'm really
excited about and if I'm not mistaken
you also have a trash talking chess app
oh that's correct
[Laughter]
it's okay it's okay you know apps are
tricky things to make any money off but
it has some of my best teaching ideas in
it absolutely yes sir well first of all
good to see you welcome back welcome
back it is the U.S Championship would
have been incomplete without your
Maurice so uh welcome welcome welcome uh
expand a little bit on the children's
book uh how are you going to inspire
kids uh with your children's book what
do you what are you what are you
teaching well it's not a it's not a
chess book per se like specifically I
don't know where my camera should be
right now am I looking at this camera
it's not it's not a chess book per se
it's uh it's a book about my early life
so it's more of an inspirational
motivational book gotcha and that way I
talk a little bit about growing up in
Brooklyn getting the trash talking as
you mentioned from back in the day when
I was playing in the hustlers in the
park and also my first time playing
chess and uh and you know so if I'm
writing actually includes you in it yes
me yeah exactly one little scene between
me and you uh when I met you remember
Mikhail tile that game that I I showed
that sacrifice when he was playing
against komsky yes with kamsky yeah
defected in that tournament New York
open right yes exactly exactly so I I am
definitely going way back but to talk
about
humble beginnings and focusing on loving
something being passionate about
something and becoming successful at it
nice okay an inspirational book well
Anastasia do you have any questions for
our colleague of course of course I
wanted first of all to ask Maurice how
many calls he got during these times
when this drama has started and maybe
something interesting any story behind
the scene for you with this whole uh
cheating scandal yes yes well
I one story comes to mind I'm not sure I
can say
yeah so I got
I got Wall Street Journal
uh uh NBC you name it there was
everybody was giving me phone calls they
wanted me to do an interview and and
matter of fact after I leave here I'm
going to be on New Zealand television
with another call New Zealand it's been
so far it's ongoing but speaking of that
part of the world Australian television
reached out to me and
I did this interview and the
I don't know if I could say but we have
a 30-minute delay all right
in the middle of the interview he says
to me tell me tell me about vibrating
you know what beats like this is in the
middle of an interview which they ended
up being on air and I said I don't want
to talk about that topic you know like
sex toys
and uh and then he and I said that's the
way the brain goes now and he says yeah
you're right it looks like nowadays we
just go straight for the
[Laughter]
I guess they do it different in
Australia wow but he had no problem
talking about it and bring it up so
first time I I think somebody has
interviewed me and I was at a loss for
words of what to say afterwards because
you know me I always have something to
say but this time wow
Marie's question for you buddy have you
ever had a game whether it be online or
at the board where you felt something
was wrong with your opponent like you
were getting gained or something was
happening that just didn't sit well with
you online or over the board
uh I would say over the board never
never I've never felt no no over the
board no no but online when I've been on
stream it did happen that once I was
playing with uh Irina in hand and brain
and we were playing against a player who
was supposed to be about 17 1800 and all
the persons all the players moves were
like yesterday
we were looking we were you know it was
uh swimming yeah so we could see and we
were like um it's 1800 it's kind of
strong
they were dropping bars you know like
nuances I mean I could have been playing
we could have been playing you yesterday
right so so we kind of felt funny in
that one I must admit okay but that's
the only time interesting it's also
interesting for me to know Maurice what
do you think about women chess
championships because we have many
different players this time youngsters
foreign
love I love it when you see the
youngsters starting to excel like that's
the best thing you can have so the
youngsters showing it yeah we have
Fabian we have Dominguez and you know
and we have Irina and the Vets who we
love and we've been with for years right
right growing up in front of our eyes
and maybe even growing older in front of
our eyes but without the future then
there's nothing there's just it's just
the way it should be and so it's good to
see young blood on the on the female
side and women's side for sure seeing
them not be not be afraid at all like
just absolutely Fearless they're here to
show no respect to their to their Elders
in fact I mean this word disrespect has
been a part of this Championship who
knew that this would be the disrespect
U.S Championship but uh I think it's
right I think the youngster should be
like I'm here I've seen you enough I
played you enough now they're some
mainly veterans even the young players
are like veterans in the field they
should be thinking We Got Game Show Me
What You Got and so I'm excited to see a
sort of Shifting at the top I don't
think it's a full change of the Guard
yet you know you can't tell Fabi he's
old but but it should be that the
youngsters start to show their stuff and
and we know that the future is bright in
U.S chess absolutely Maurice is
wonderful to see you thank you how long
are you in town for I'll be here for
Until the End wow brilliant it's fine I
know oh my God
come to the cold in the midwest when I
could be in Florida
you know on the beach right but I get
the beach all the time anyway now that
I've moved down there so uh I'm gonna
hang out well we'll pull you in more
often uh were you hanging out over at
the chase
you know we can't tell where we're
sleeping oh that's right stalkers yeah
commentators are in great demand yeah I
remember we need to get you on the
podcast
lovely Maurice again great to see you
welcome welcome thank you thank you
absolutely and of course wonderful good
luck on the chessable courses I know
that uh Maurice is also a problemist he
likes composing problems and he
especially enjoys stumping the Masters
if you will and he feels great when
people like Fabiano said I didn't solve
it I guess I love that I love that uh
jumping to the game uh between begum and
Megan uh this was the con sacrifice
Community yeah exactly we left it after
A4 Kane castles uh by uh Megan uh takes
takes and obviously this a long diagonal
there's a you know part of gold at the
end of the rainbow as we would say let's
go for it and bacon did that with the
move E5 opening up the diagonal A5
preparing to make
room for The Rook Queen E4 the double
attack against the bishop on G4 as well
as the Rook on a force the move Bishop
takes F3 I don't want to take the rook
and lose your Queen Bishop takes F3 Rook
A6 so Megan rescued her Rook Bishop A3
Knight C6 Bishop C5 and I think the yeah
we're just about caught up Queen C7
setting up a rather attractive uh grab
of the pawn Knight takes E5 because the
bishop in that case would be unprotected
and we've caught up with the players and
I'm going to say that uh wow uh well
begum has compensation for the pawn I
find it difficult to imagine she has
Advantage I see a repetition going on
between Jeffrey and Lavon
and again
you know if I am a competitor and I'm
saying you know like LaVon I don't want
to see a resurgent Lavon so if you want
to stay
down there with just making draws this
is uh this is a good result for our
leaderboard
Jeffrey on the other hand comes into
today undefeated plus one
may be hopeful for something I guess he
didn't get much out of uh this opening
and our second result uh draw in that
game Christian what do you have for us
well I'm looking at this Fabiano game
because it's actually heating up in the
position and I think a Wonder might have
made the mistake let's take a look at
what happened not Knight takes F7 of
course the move that we were discussing
because of Rook df8 Rook takes F4 and
we've seen these lights before he played
the move H4 Fabiano that is
Bishop takes G5 immediately played uh by
a Wonder but unfortunately I don't think
this is the correct uh decision because
right now you're going to have some
problems with a Pawn on H7 if you give
me a couple of moves I'm going to go
Rook to D3 or Rook to H3 followed by the
doubling on the H file that's going to
put a lot of pressure on your position
you don't want to see that landing on
the board so he said okay yeah I'm in a
hurry I'm going to try to break your
structure he played the move F6 but
after root D1 makes a lot of sense
you're trying to go to E7 of course
right do you want to challenge on the
e-file probably not because I take take
root takes H7 that's a pawn up that's me
activating my pieces right you're
probably lost at this point so you
cannot do that what can you do well he
said I'm going to take on G5 Bishop
takes G5 and I'm looking at the position
and the main move that comes to mind is
Rook to f8 exactly create your own
threats the problem is and I think this
is what a Wonder missed from afar from
when he played Bishop takes G5 is that
after Rook to E7 Rook takes F2 right
boom Rook takes H7 comes on the board oh
that's a surprise that's a shocker
because you cannot take back on uh H7
that's a Checkmate in one move right so
you have to hide the Rook somewhere you
can give a check but it doesn't really
help you right it's not going to help
you you can go Rook to fa yes by the way
if you go root to G8 I'm going to take
you still cannot take right because of
Rook to E8 I'm not going to take on G7
so you have to hide the Rook with Rook
to f8 but how are you going to challenge
my Rooks on the seventh round that's
problematic yeah so for example if you
try to do Rook to d8 say okay I'm going
to preemptively defend that Knight on D7
yeah good luck with that I'm going to
capture on G7 with the other Rook
opening up the action of the bishop
you're in trouble I do have a I do have
a bailout Rook Rook check and Knight F6
let's see let's see if that works Knight
to F6 King to E2 and you take this one I
take this one and I'm attacking the C7
Pawn the Knight on H7 and The Rook on F1
that's a lot of hitting exactly exactly
so you can go Rook to H1 defend uh but
sure I mean the same game is probably
going to be lost foreign
remember you played Rooker instead of
Rook d8 yeah f8 after you move um
you take on D7 yes
actually I have my own checkmates no
exactly yes the question was how many
points you will grab on your way and it
seems like you took too many yes to one
against three from the starting position
with Rook f8 Rook E7 yes uh if I toss in
H6 you're just I presume you're just
dropping back with the bishop probably
just dropping back to E3 and he has
played rook d8 and Fa as he prescribed
yes Rook E7 looks like by far Yeah by
far the most challenging and once again
H6 Bishop there let's go Bishop E3 yeah
is just a good Bishop active pieces it's
a really good bishop and this bishop is
going to land on D4 I agree right
yeah Rook H4 and uh rookie seven is on
the board Rookie of course Fabiano may
be taking over in this end game I think
fabric heard somehow the the west of
Maurice who said it's a shame not win
this game yeah yeah you have to win this
game look look look look if ice could
kill if looks could kill right did you
see that look of Fabiano Corona exactly
because the Wonder is wondering right
now wait wait what happened H7 I cannot
take that phone on F2 yes of Rook to H7
am I just simply much worse right now
maybe the move F6 was just missed time
it was yeah he had to play Rook E8 Rook
d8 to E8 first or something but he's
definitely in uh trouble uh I just
wanted to also add ask the evaluation of
begum's position with Megan again this
was the pawn sacrifice essay very early
begum has the two Bishops she's got you
know nice control over the center so
there's no question she's got
compensation but does she have an
advantage I no you you assessed it very
well yes sir it's just compensation just
compensation compensation enough for
equality actually I see I see all right
so all right obviously you still have to
worry about things of like Rook to C8
for example like Rick to ca and that
presence reinforcing the threat of
Knight takes C5 which in fact wasn't a
threat if you would have played so take
a look at this move instead of Queen to
E3 Bishop to G2 was an option okay so
give me that I want to play three four
right yeah if you do take only five I go
Queen B7 and you resign really whoa look
at this yeah yeah
that was a nice little trick whoa that's
why Christians yeah well this is a
triple attack yeah this is hanging this
is hanging and this is hanging oh my
goodness uh verasan surprise that's a
good move that's a really strong move in
fact so there wasn't the threat but I
must say I fell for it I didn't say
queen to seven Knight takes e E5 was uh
maybe good strict I think everybody uh
did and to be honest I don't like what
beg him has done for the last few moves
with this idea of Bishop A3 Bishop to C5
that Bishop was looking good on C1 what
I would have liked to see from uh her is
an expansion on the king side because
that's where you have all of your pieces
aimed at right the king side and that's
where your opponent doesn't have as many
Defenders and that's what we have seen
from her before
who likes to play oh let's go this was
the time and it's very typical in this
type of positions you sacrificed upon
you have this Pawn chain c3d4 E5
stopping at the bishop on G7 just go H4
H5 King G2 Rook H1 I think it was set up
it was a very important point you made
earlier too uh Christian that when you
play H4 and your opponent tries to stop
you with H5 you G4 unhindered you just
go you go G4 and bring it you don't even
calculate at this point exactly G4 so
maybe just this whole it looks good but
maybe it's just not effective well what
is the bishop doing on C5 I understand
it looks nice put it on that diagonal if
black played the move E6 actually what
the bishop is doing for the move Knight
E5 maybe it helps to create this queen
with seven threads right right right
right
no that I think that was our analysis I
think we're up to date and Megan is uh
you just go E6 I guess actually now
sometimes there is a threat 95 no no
that's why I would like to play E6 maybe
right ah E6 okay yeah yeah E6 and F5
most likely and we get the wild position
as a grundfeld defense player I think
you'd probably like Black's position in
such a case when you have a diagonal I
also don't like moving my f-pawn
I really don't like moving my F5 and I
know beg him actually did that with the
black pieces yesterday against in a
grunfeld yeah
um and I told her that yeah I I maybe in
my gruffal career played F6 or F5
five times if that right so you have a
weakness now try to limit that F6 or F5
movement
always play F6 I'm a disciple of uh no
no I'm a disciple of Ben feigold never
play F6 yeah that's what I mean I think
we should teach Christian to play king's
Gambit yeah
he doesn't have a curious mind he needs
to expand his Consciousness
stagnate it as a chess player of course
I've never played the Kings game yes we
start or you know yanish defense in
Spanish when you play five oh that's
true
so then you play the fight
and I lost in a critical match against
Ray Robson
at the pan-americans oh that hurts uh
let's just jump to the game of Alice Lee
in Arena Crush for a moment because this
was the hanging pawns we left it really
just about these parts and let's catch
up with these two players
Alice going up against very formidable
rival
eight-time Champion Arena Crush
13 year old I can't even believe I'm
saying that we're the U.S Women's
Championship really 13 year old Alice
Lee uh first of all uh pause right here
regardless of what happens
Arena's very very happy why because all
the pieces are still on the board and
she's the one who's got ideas of like
Knight G5 Queen H3 Knight G4 in other
words she's attacking so Alice has got
and when I see this move Queen A1 I get
very excited I say wait a minute my
opponent's taking too many Liberties the
queen is is hiding hiding all by herself
on A1 and I've got an open hand
five no yes
Bishop takes and this is terrible this
is simply terrible you just I mean
Knight takes E4 and again you know light
squared Bishop is missing you've just
played the move G3 and all the light
squares are weak and you can never ever
you know think about these because when
you play D4 it's just it it's over on
the on on the long diagonal so I'm
thinking arena is really cruising right
now that she's in it has a really really
good position and the arena for arena uh
in this tournament it's like her draws
by the way she's had the favorable draws
like with mega mega
Megan uh our tournament leader just
barely drew that pawn ending and Arena
misses a one move Point against
in that Queen upon ending but let's jump
uh over to Christian with uh guest in
studio Christian thank you yeah sir Hans
welcome back to the show how's uh the
last week been for you
just playing chess
and how how is the chess going
well not that well but it could be worse
absolutely and today you kind of pulled
the brakes early on can you talk to us
about today's game a little bit yeah
well we can start uh at the small rookie
too
E2 so I was a bit surprised by this
queen B8 Queen A7 stuff and there was a
game due to the candidates
so I of course after Queen instead of
rookie two there's D4 and there's long
stuff but the
I had not checked this before the game
so I did not think it would be wise to
go into such a forcing line without
let's say direct concrete knowledge so
you were playing fast after this yeah
but usually if you're going to do
something in this D4 line you need
something extremely direct and uh I just
didn't check it before the game so
I remember checking rookie too because
it was played in the candidates A4
um yeah Knight G3 Queen A5 to take and
you were playing really fast yeah so I
remember this you're in your book well
um I think I remember
um here was where my concrete knowledge
ended
um I was just really struggling to think
remember but from what I analyzed I sort
of felt like um you can play this in a
very slow way a capture Queen C2 maybe
it was what I checked yeah
um and queen B5 C4 Queen B8 this I sort
of vaguely remembered
um and I think in this position of
course it's equal but
um there's not a lot of risk for weight
because you sort of have control
um over the major Palm bricks you know
if black isn't really going to play D
hover F5 then you're sort of maintaining
control and you always have Bishop B2
Rook B1 B4 and then there's you know I
remember checking you know the main
ideas of King H2 and I did four another
five so I remember the ideas vaguely
um
but I think this queen B5 couldn't be it
is actually quite precise
um how the Geo says the position right
now and did you talk to your opponent
after the game did you guys discovered
he didn't he didn't know I think in the
game I don't know if I don't really
remember the precise of The Duda uh Deng
game but I think it was something like a
bishop B6 if you want to go back
instead of uh I think he played Queen
Bishop B6 some some I don't remember
basically it went like Bishop B6 Queen
A6
um some that's what these are and
that's all I remember
um but anyways in the game I think the
critical moment is I played this move
not H4
um yeah allowing D5 which is just quite
stupid
um I just completely forgot that it was
possible so that was just a very Hasty
mistake um but instead of Knight H4 I
should play Bishop C3 uh just sort of
stopping that how Wild Bishop before
okay
so I guess I have to already play uh and
let's say not Bishop G3
numbers should be 4K so that I guess I
have to go B4 already before yeah this
is yeah before take take uh I didn't
like Bishop before yeah
um but yeah I saw D4 here but I wasn't
sure how to evaluate this
um still seems very yeah so let's say
after a b he goes Bishop B6 yeah I saw
this and then I go B4
um yeah Queen d8 Bishop C3
so what is black trying to do yeah it's
a very weird position on Queen A5 Queen
B5 Queen B yeah it's a very very weird
position
um from what I remember you're just
white it has a grip and I didn't feel
that natural for me to play for black to
play when I was analyzing this but you
know I was checking this back when the
candidates was happening so the
knowledge wasn't too fresh but yeah
after you played uh D5 I was like okay
it's time to make a draw I was trying to
learn from my past the transgressions of
over pushing with white
um so okay another three is that a
difficult thing to do yeah right yeah
you sort of have to just sort of you
know swallow your pride and admit your
mistake
um so I think my past games certainly
conditioned me to to make that position
much easier because I guess it's
tempting to go oh to claim oh yeah you
know I didn't make a mistake notified
yeah and then you're like pushed by
faith in your weight oh wait was my
knight doing an F5 and then and then
things you know you know it's important
when things to adjust your mindset uh
I've learned that from my previous games
it's very important to adjust your
mindset
um because I think your perception of
the position
has quite a significant impact on how
you play because for example I think
that if you had the ability to tell
yourself that you were playing a
different color I think that that's that
if you could do that as a chess player I
think that would like you know plus 50
rating points like in so many of my
games this tournament if I could just be
like no no you have black here it's time
to defend I would just make it draw like
very easily
um so I I think you started with white
you started with yeah and then you have
white and it just trust is more
psychological Than People realize so
that's something that I I think I
learned from my my two or two losses
with white uh they're completely
uncalled for absolutely and uh yeah so
he okay he repeated I was very happy to
see this yeah you were okay
I was like come on when you play 92.3
you're ready you're ready for the game
to be over
and uh I I also felt like this and how a
tournament was going he wasn't
in such a fighting mode as well okay I'm
seeing that after Bishop wait after
Bishop B5 I have I can Bishop no instead
of Bishop B2 I could have played
uh Knight to five here you mean
interesting yeah okay but okay I I think
it was I think it was time to just uh
call it the day cold today yeah because
actually I'm in my game against Wesley
in Singapore cup but I was told just to
make a draw you can call it a day and I
was very adamantly told this
um and I didn't listen and we should
happen so I think uh I was very much
in a crisis control mode and uh I think
that that's very important so I think uh
Beyond I think the way to improve my
chest is just to um become colorblind
and um wear some special glasses that
make me can't see color and then if I
cannot if I don't know if I'm white or
black then I think my chest will improve
drastically uh since we last talked any
ubereats Adventures for you
and uh it took like an hour then they
canceled it so that was unfortunately I
might have to switch to another app
um because ubereats has let me down I
haven't used it just because
when you order something and you're
waiting for it for like half an hour and
then
you watch the the driver like go in
circles
and then they and then they manage the
driver and then they cancel it you sort
of just uh revert back to actually going
outside and walking to get food and so
yeah I don't know I think it reads uh
has lost my business and how about the
Berlin defense did you analyze that
during the rest day did you find
anything new share we share it with us
no no I am
no nothing nothing to share
guys any questions uh just a quick one
uh Hans
um I don't know if you paid attention to
the game of a Wonder Liang and if you
saw Knight takes E4 uh if it if that if
if you saw it and if if it caused you to
smile this rookie is a rookie mistake I
really don't want to you know let's I'm
actually familiar with this
um and it's actually not as bad as it
looks and uh I actually have a very very
um specific childhood memory of this
game and I had a game
in this position and I play Queen E2 and
this was in the Netherlands and I
remember this is like any point out of
six
and I was like a kid
they might not have sex and I remember
this it's like it's so insane that I
remember this and I was playing the
tournament and I went 96 and I looked at
the kid and I was like what is this and
I also remember you know I've always
been a quite an opening this was an
opening novelty but I'd also like to
point out and this exact same program I
don't know why I remember this I had a
game e45
Queen H5 and I came up with a move
Knight F6 you know uh you know
eight-year-old me
so I remember this exact tournament I
had two identical games and I won a
beautiful game so you guys just brought
back some challenge memories
um is this supposed to be a good movie
it's Knight F6 well uh eight-year-old me
came up with it and was like I'm a
genius so uh it says no games
exactly you know why I'm Hans demons
but I remember this exact same
tournament it was like one of my like if
my first you know tournament where I won
a trophy and I remember two games you
know Knight of six Knight C6 906 Queen
E5 I don't know so you guys have but
it's actually not that bad there's a
someone made a trustable course on this
um I don't remember
maybe Anish no no no um but there's a
festival course on this and actually
checked it out and like uh I think the
trapism if you go to the game the Trap
is like there's some like uh so desync
no 94 22 D6 uh D4 tick tick uh Knight
six and like if Bishop by four there's
like G5 right this is like the Trap
right yeah yeah this is yeah and some
weird stuff yeah okay I Wonder has has
been quite creative uh I think you have
to get creative you know if you're you
know slaving away to Ivy League so or
university you know you have to get
creative because you're just being you
know all your time is being sucked away
by academic boredom so
um but yeah I know this is actually a
very interesting choice I think I was
very impressed but it doesn't seem to be
working well but uh I respect the uh the
creativity Hans thank you very much
uh nice that we all have these childhood
memories of Knight C6 check and winning
the queen and her rookie mistake I just
want to turn our attention to the game
between ashrita and Jennifer for just a
second because this is almost a dream
come true for akara Khan player such as
myself you you put this Pawn over on the
E6 Square you double your Rooks against
this Pawn on D4 and you go Bishop F6 and
you just simply take this Pawn off the
board it's not that easy for Jennifer
because her Pawn is double but
nonetheless once you once you get to
this position you immediately understand
that this Pawn on D4 is the Target and
you just hit it with everything you can
and that involved run me F5 and Bishop
F6 I think Sharif is in trouble and I
think Jennifer is doing very very well
here just again checking in the game
between Alice Lee and Arena Crush once
you see Knight takes E4 and Alice has to
play this move Rook on
E1 to F1 you understand her distress
because basically the light squares are
collapsing F3 might precipitate with
Knight takes G3 I think arena is doing
really really
and finally to just go through the the
list of the ladies who were in the lead
I like Megan's last move a lot uh this
move uh the night on C6 isn't really
doing that much but this move Knight to
C6 to go Knight to E6 kick this bishop
back and if ever you can get to play
first of all you stopping these ideas of
E6 we we saw that a moment ago but if
you ever get to play
B5 B4
it's like resigns I mean those pawns
just go uh marching up the board so I
see
um our tournament leaders are and I
think this move Bishop uh D5 again I got
to stop myself speaks for itself
is trying to play F4 and you know
eliminate that night on E6 but by the
way what will happen
if probably right yes because otherwise
you will close the bishop on G7 exactly
exactly
by the way I think anybody who's played
a fair amount of Chess in their life has
gotten into this uh distressful position
where you play a piece down essentially
for the rest of the game white plays F4
and H4 and the bishop on G7 is literally
uh entombed and it never gets out but
yes you would take with the Rook
and let's just uh re we remind everybody
what an extraordinary tournament uh
Megan has had she started with those two
wins exactly very very nice
and she lost one game only to Anna
satansky that was a setback and we
thought that she might start fading
after that not at all
draw you know just to make sure
everything is under control and then
three weeks ago yeah and I stand
corrected let me correct myself I said
Ray Robson was the hottest player of the
two events not true he has competition
in Megan Lee who also has won a trifecta
to get to this round nine so exciting
things going on here and what's
happening in the uh Sam shankland versus
Christopher Eugene Sam Shanklin is
completely dominating oh really it's
that bad he's he's breaking through
right now I mean
this last moment he could have played
the move H6 and that was actually just
finishing the game G takes H6 Rook to E7
you cannot really challenge my Rook on
uh E8 of course you can do it but I'm
just simply going down yeah yeah that's
too much material right also B6 is kind
of locked out so what to do after uh
this can you take on D4 not really
because I have this move and now if you
take I take on H6 or I can just simply
take on a F5 I take on F6 next on H6
excuse me and Bishop to E6 that's going
to be a Checkmate yes
game over yes so this one is not looking
good if you go H5 then I can just simply
continue I take on F4 and uh I will get
to your king at some point right I'm
going to take on C7 as well you cannot
move the Knight because you're losing H5
this is completely over plus seven plus
seven what the engine is saying yes this
is over he played the move Queen to D3
makes a lot of sense as well defending
the pawn on D4 you never allow Bishop
takes D4 and get the bishop back into
play I like this move very controlled
decision by Sam Shanklin black has to go
something like Queen H6 but this looks
horrendous for a young Christopher you
who I have to say he had a very
imbalanced tournament he started well he
lost the first one but after that he
bounced back with two victories back to
back so that was a good start for him
but recently in the last few games he
has been struggling especially yesterday
I remember that moment when he played
this move C4 that was very strange
against Jefferson just simply giving up
a pawn no compensation whatsoever in
that last team of the game
he's not putting as much practical
pressure on his opponents and you can
see that specifically in this game
against Hampshire
so of course I mean we raised the
youngers for being so so brave but at
the same time it's also about experience
you know like how to uh you know keep
your nerves under control how to stand
this pressure during the game let's say
it's it's not that easy all this how to
spend your even energy for Preparation
sometimes you can spend eight hours
preparing for the game and then you
cannot play simply your game after that
yeah
but staying calm I I hear you loud and
clear and that was a lesson I think
every chess player has to learn too it's
not just about good moves it's by
staying calm Under Pressure I want to
turn our attention uh quickly to the
game of darush versus Alshon a long long
time ago we talked about the square C4
and how I personally liked uh to play
Black side in such positions because I
never really knew as white were
ambitious with this bishop and I like by
the way darush put his Pawn on a five
fourth purpose
he wants to challenge the Knight on C4
but he doesn't want to see the Knight on
D7 going to B6 and then to C4 how does
he challenge the Knight of the C4 with
the move Knight F1 now if elshon just
played passively like for example just
played a move like A6 it might be a
useful move down the road now we can see
that darush is ready to At Last
and you know playing for the move C4 and
if you could magically put the Knight on
C4 you're happy with black but since you
can't well you're unhappy it's that
simple but I think elshon played a
really really good move this Knight on
C4 is fine this Knight on D7 needs a
square so he starts looking around for a
square and he played the move F5 and
suddenly we say oh this is very nice if
you take take look at this this
beautiful Square D 5 falls under into
Black's mitts yes you put the Knight on
C4 unite on D5 the bishop on C1 will
really really be crying and it's this
move F7 F5 that's taking a little wind
out of darush's sails at the moment uh
one of the things that you really don't
want to do
85 yeah no you know you get to D5 right
I mean I'll start to play C5 and I'll
start to play Rook to C8 and just
shutting down the center the bishop will
be
passive let's just let's just say so I
like what Alshon is playing in this game
he you know that's the problem sometimes
you're playing a person who's playing
very badly in the tournament but and
then they start playing against you
their best chess and you think why are
you playing so well against me and not
everybody else actually pay attention to
the time like 17 minutes against like
more than 40 minutes yes so it means
probably that direction is not so happy
about his position exactly actually
remember what Sabina said yesterday on
her interview that should never give up
keeps trying yes and she actually showed
with for example also to El Sean that
you should not give up even though the
tournament doesn't go well to keep
fighting in every game and I think this
is what he's doing today he's just
trying to play normal chess and to use
his chances he got a really nice
position yeah and she she played it in
her best game did Sabina against Pagan
yesterday you bet over to you Christian
we have for us speaking of uh Sabina
actually she just played this move Queen
to B7 and this is one of those tactics
that you usually solve when you are 10
years of age and trying to learn uh
patterns very classical patterns in the
position and one of them is just the
sacrifice on H6 Bishop takes H6 but you
have to calculate it very precisely
Queen to C1 makes a lot of sense you're
trying to get the queen to H6 that's
going to deliver the Checkmate there's
only one defense for uh black and that
is to open up the seventh rank take
advantage of the fact that the queen is
still on the seventh rank with this move
Knight to H7 if you take on H6 now I
will go F6 and not only that I open up
the queen but after root to G3 I also
have this move Knight to G5 of course
really to h8 loses
this is game over
the game is over but you do go Knight to
G5
and the position is not that bad because
you don't have the move F4 you can go H4
of course but now Queen to H7 is going
to come I'm forcing the queen trade
actually if you take like this I can
take only five first and I'm a piece up
you no longer have an attack in the
position with the G file closed you
cannot do that so what you can do and
this is pretty cool in fact is to start
with this move B4 okay
[Music]
exactly exactly if you think yes now I
go check first and once you go on ig5
now I can take take Queen takes G5 and
this is extremely difficult at least to
my eyes yeah
wow you get the queen to H4 okay and
this is very important you will
understand why in just a second king to
G7 okay and now the question is how are
you going to bring your next attacker
into the position
94.
why is the queen on H4 and not on H6 or
H5 Rook d8 is not possible in the
position not only that but also Queen to
E4 is not possible because of Queen
takes C4 so the queen on H4 is perfectly
placed this is not easy to see no this
is really really not easy down and why
we need that move before yeah exactly
so let's see what happens after King to
h8 now I go Queen to B2 Ah that's it and
this is the idea behind B4 double attack
attacking the bishop on B4 as well as
Knight to G6 and all uh
for example if you do this Knight F7 is
a Checkmate in one move you have to play
the move F6 and after Knight to G6 well
I'm going to take this and then I'm
going to take the bishop at the end of
it you're not going to have two pieces
for The Rook but rather you're going to
be on Exchange down with a naked King so
this one is just simply over very nice
move B4 not easy to see easy to see and
I'm sure Sabina was looking at these
ideas of Bishop takes H6 she did not see
most likely the move B4 and this idea of
Queen to B2 later on when the king lands
on h8 and said okay I'm safe I can go
Queen B7 but let's wait and see whether
Talia will spot This brilliant sacrifice
uh we're confounded by uh the situation
that's going on between
Lanier Dominguez and Sam Savion we know
Lanier yeah loves to think and think and
think but you start the game with 90
minutes that's the first time control
and you use 50 minutes
55 I'm sorry I I thought it was 50 but
you're saying 50 he's using 55 minutes
on one move and I I would be really
really surprised if after H3 C4 he
didn't have this position on his board
like at home I mean this is like this
could easily be preparation C4 and H3 I
mean you could expect that you're
analyzing this position then well he did
because he played B4 after a 10 second
think okay
now he forgot everything now it's 50
minutes yes it's a bit different wow oh
okay still it's not the world record
thinking for one hour 17 minutes which
is 77 minutes right I mean on his game
against one half on one move in the
opening you know like 12 in French
defense I mean okay why not to think for
one hour yeah maybe an hour 12 minutes
too I think he and Garcia are really
really close on this why is Lanier
thinking so much that is a good question
this is uh isn't this uh all part of the
prep uh Christian
um I'm not 100 sure I mean Rook takes D4
sure it seems to be like the only move
that you could be thinking in the
position
then I take on B4 and that's attacks at
the same time The Rook on D2 this is not
looking good maybe this is what he's
looking at D5 Queen to B6 route to F2
and trying to understand this position
after D6 maybe bishop to F2 maybe King
to F7 to get to E6 I'm actually
wondering myself how is this position if
if you take the exchange immediately I
don't have to take this it seems to be
bad yeah this end game after King F7
King E3 is just really bad for black I
don't doubt it and I'm trying to
understand why okay so I get the king
all the way to a D4 ah and I assume this
bishop is going to land on D5 at the
same point Bishop D1 Bishop F3 Bishop D5
this actually might be problematic so
the question is what do you do after
this move D6 as black and the answer is
you actually start with the move King to
F7 I'm still not convinced that black is
not worse here yeah so King F1 trying to
get to the same okay I mean just that
that is a good question yes take take
action yeah King to E6 let's say no but
this is the same position yes so you
have to go Rook to oh my goodness I try
to create your own place some sort of a
race Rook c a b I think you just want to
go B4 yeah
B4 B3 if you can and uh yeah it is some
sort of wild position that's crazy right
but but why sacrifice The Exchange why
not just start with the move Rook takes
D4 and then in case of Rook takes D4 C3
takes D4 Bishop takes D4 yep D5 and I've
got the same position without an
exchange this is killing yes okay of
course this is killing so what can black
uh do to point to B6 seems to be the
best move okay but still I mean we're
going to most likely get into this
position right root takes D4 okay and ah
Rook to D6 now
and how is this the seven normal
it's still okay because I have this move
G5
crazy stuff this is some crazy that's
why he's thinking that's why he's
thinking for 50 minutes I mean it's not
easy even when you can move your pieces
yes I mean we can see what the engine is
saying but assessing these type of
positions by the way the engine is
saying that with ft hd4 the position is
close to balanced anything else is
completely winning for white so for
example if you try to get your own
counter play which pay three B for B3
you're not in time I'm winning the pawn
race so it's a pawn race in this
situation and it's very difficult to
assess from afar this is what linear is
spending his time on and by the way
let's see what Fabiano did because he's
been he went into a tank as well what's
going on Knight to B6 was played so we
were looking at Rook 12 to Rook takes H7
we saw it that's bad he played the move
Knight to B6 and now he had a big Choice
Route 67 first or Bishop to E3 okay and
he spent
32 minutes on this one Rook takes G7 we
expect Rook takes F2 which came on the
board yeah this is the current position
we have
how do we assess this one guys
Bishop to H4 Bishops kind of easy that
that tickles the rook and it defends G2
and maybe on a good day you get to play
Bishop G3 and harass C7 Pawn now a big
question arises for Rwanda right now
where do you put their do you go to E2
and try to stay active but that's going
to allow Rook to F1 Rook to F7
and by the way the respawn H4 is very
well placed because it defends Rook to
E1 so for example if we look at ideas of
Rook to E2 Rook to F1 Rook to d8
actually not Rook to D A doesn't work
right the bishop on H4 is brilliant yeah
yeah so what about Rook Cafe to just I
go back and that's the best question
that is the best move yes Rook to f8 but
it's not easy it's very tempting to stay
out yeah I don't know what they'll do
after this
evening C7 hitting H7 I mean definitely
uh Fabby for choice but again a very
long thing by uh Fabi uh technical for
him right I mean he doesn't spend
normally half an hour on them exactly
maybe not to D5 after Bishop G3 in that
position
turning our attention to the game of Ray
Robson for just a moment this was the
position where I had I had advocated for
Knight E4 it's funny uh during one of
our breaks I actually asked the computer
uh what it thought and it said Queen D2
um
zero five Half Upon
Advantage for white and then I said okay
well let me play a move I I went I'm not
sure what I did I think I even went A5
and it went Rook B1 still liked and then
I went here and then it went O2 then it
went here and I went Knight F6 and then
it went oh one and it started uh liking
Black's position what uh what um Alex
did is he dropped back with his Knight
and repositioned it to the D6 Square so
that he's ready to play 94 but in this
case wants to recapture with the Knight
not to double his pawns and he
completely changed
um
the pond structure with his choice of
captures captures and C5 I thought this
was an intriguing move because I think a
lot of us would have been more happier
happier to play the movie E5 uh Alex
chose
C5 and then in this position uh those of
you who've ever studied ASA Hoffman
games I'm one of the victims of Asa
Hoffman uh E5 ASA loved to have the
blockade
he didn't do that after D5 uh Alex uh
borrowed a page from maybe the Fabiano
handbook remember
B5 and we're catching up with the
players now as uh lots of Trades have
happened and we're anticipating Rook
takes D5 and I feel that uh
well Alex and it's it's about even so
yeah it's about even yes the sip on
maybe can be a weakness or maybe can be
a power if it starts moving I said or
liability that's always the question as
we go on break let's just take a look at
the Open results and we're after this
we're going to see on the other side of
the break we have two drawers at the
Jeffrey drunk made the dragons live on
irony and then Hans Neiman Drew with
Wesley Stone exactly we'll see on the
other side of this break
thank you
when you visit St Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
back to the hotel would be a major error
instead Boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the at the national Blues
Museum Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know I can't play this
right St Lou is always exploring
in 1839 the University of Missouri is
steeped in Tradition the recently
founded Mizzou chess program is a
partnership between the University of
Missouri and the St Louis chess club
Collegiate Jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of Excellence
Mizzou has always strived for the best
Mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
Discovery and Excellence to the
chessboard
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everyone and we have a
current standings in women event because
no one has finished her game no results
no results and we have Megan list two
leading she's on the first place with
six points and then Arena crashed with
Jennifer you both of them five and a
half points out of eight Ellis Lee the
youngest player of the tournament has
five points and she plays against Irina
craft today and in the open section no
results right
no no no no no
yes but two drops yes there are two
draws but they didn't make any
difference for the standings so far so
Jeffrey drunk made a draw against Levon
or Iranian and has Neiman made the peace
with Wesley so
yes nice uh in the women's section just
looking and
whoops okay uh just looking at what's
going on with Jennifer Jennifer you is
just actually just taken over the game
uh there was some Desperado exchange
Sacrifice by ashwitha but at this moment
Jennifer's up in exchange as well as
upon so that game is really cruising to
victory for Jennifer Jennifer is going
to she's a half a point behind Megan
let's just look at Megan's game she's up
against big what are you
yes you remember this position yes
96 so white boy Bishop D5 and 96 well
actually we were just here we saw the
move Knight E6 and we were talking about
if you recap pardon me if we capture
we'll recapture with the Rook so they
can drop back with her bishop and this
is an indication what Christian sounded
an alarm like what good was your Bishop
doing on C5 turned out well not that
much and I was always talking about a
black ever succeeds in playing the move
B5 B4 that really it could be game over
just like that Queen d8 again tickling
the bishop again also intimating that B4
and Bishop Knight takes D4 could be on
the agenda unfortunately for black this
Rook on A6 lacks protection so B4
Bishop takes B4 is an answer
that's yeah very important right
otherwise Knight C7 Bishop C5 E6 Queen
F3 we're catching up with the play but
it sure looks like
Megan has actually improved her game
Christian over to you well absolutely
Megan has improved her position in that
one but there is an attack developing on
the king side as well that H4 H5 is
coming quite quickly and you don't have
as many Defenders on that side but let's
take a look at what's happening in the
Fabiano caruana versus a Wonder game so
this was the position that we uh finally
reached Bishop to E7 not Bishop to G3
Rook 28 this is currently the position
and the big question comes what about
Rook takes H7 right let's take a pawn
Rook takes H7 Rook takes H7 everything
is forced I will go Rook to G8 put some
pressure on the pawn on G2 you have to
defend somehow there's only one way and
that is Rook to H2 I attack you once
again there's only one way to defend and
set up your defense not with Bishop to
C5 because after Knight to F4 you do
lose the pawn on a G2 that's going to be
an easy draw you cannot of course take
on A7 don't do that because j6 is going
to come King B7 that's game over
actually uh for white black is winning
so you cannot do that you have to go
Beach page four Knight to E3 G3 Knight
to F5 still attacking the pawn on
g32 because you lose exactly you cannot
do that of course so or Rook to H3 the
problem is that you don't have a way to
create anything after that so you got
your Rook on H3 but there's no way you
will get G4 in the position because I
come quickly with the king I go King E6
uh King E5 take full control of the
middle of the board and then you're not
going to be able to make any progress
actually maybe even black is like well
actually black is not slightly better
because at any point white can go Rook
to H1 give up the pawn on G3 and make a
draw uh so you have to go Rook to F2
right now how is this and game I mean we
know that technically this should be a
draw right right Brook to F4 Rook to H2
King to D3 this should be a draw but
will a Wonder know how to make a drawing
this position I've seen it being lost
plenty of times by top level players
sure if I remember correctly it was this
came between ivanchuk and Nissi Pano and
I know the game because nisipanu was my
compatriot also Romanian and I think Mr
panu lost that game so there's
definitely some chances but from a
technical perspective we know that this
is a draw and Rook takes H7 everything
is forced
let's see if they're going to storm into
that variation right now it's actually a
good moment to check the technique
skills of a Wonderland
and yes on the other side of the board
you know he's just enjoying his extra
Pawn but I mean you have to make a draw
it's still it's more difficult I think
the situation absolutely
come actually was an interesting moment
like why he didn't play Rook G8 right
it's a protectant Pawn on G7 a couple of
moves before
um but we can show it uh let me let me
bring that game up on my board by the
way I think Sam Savion played a really
really wonderful move at a moment ago
that is worth uh thinking about but you
were just saying uh here because I think
you were making a very good point like
why
and I was thinking the same why didn't
he play Rook G8 yes because I think Rook
H7 yeah will come yes I was just asking
this question but I think it looks
beautiful in this position and the
difference compared to the game is that
anytime you take one of the Rooks white
will take on G file always protecting
his Pawn right like that so for example
you take crooked rocket G7 I will not
take this one I will take Rook on G7 and
then you don't have Rook G8 exactly yeah
so that's that's the difference I keep
protecting my Pawn
yes and uh let's jump to Christian who
has a very special guest thank you
Yasser we are with Stephen burgard the
president of Cardinal Glennon Children's
Hospital tell us about uh what you do
there and your connection with the Saint
Louis chess club sure so I'm six years
now in St Louis as president of Cardinal
Glennon and uh Colonel Glennon is one of
the country's top 50 Children's
Hospitals full service and we represent
the care and needs of children
everything from routine doctors visits
with a primary care pediatrician all the
way to heart transplants and neonatal
ICU trauma services and everything that
the children throughout our region might
need with a special emphasis in heart
for the most vulnerable and what is the
connection with the Saint Louis chess
club talk to us about that so um so one
of my children was very interested in in
chess and a very close friend of mine
was involved with the annual chess event
and so I actually joined up in support
of his work and enjoyed the event and
had the passion that everyone had for
helping children
realize their full potential in every
way in this case through chess that I
chose to become involved about three
years ago you are also the chairman for
this year's strategy across the board
Gala that we used the race funds tell us
a bit about that sure so for this
classic chess programs you know funds
are needed in order to create the
support for the program staff and and
the work with the kids and Colonel
Glennon out of the 600 000 kids that are
in our region we serve over a hundred
thousand of those kids every single year
in primary care and about a hundred
thousand kids in you know the hospital
and other places so the idea was that we
have an opportunity also to help
children become more engaged in chess
and the event represents such a great
way to connect with the community and
give back that my wife and I felt very
passionate about this work absolutely
and we see some graphics about strategy
across the board how can people join how
can the public join so go to St Louis
chessclub.org so all the information is
there it's at the chase sin is in the of
course I'm ballrooms gorgeous a very
famous room here in St Louis and there's
also a chance to participate in our
silent auctions for those who aren't in
St Louis you can participate as well and
support the kids and donate and help
expand programs Stephen do you play
chess do you play with your son I only
play with my son and he wins who's
winning that was my next question it's
just been a great experience and a joy
for me and in fact at the hospital now
we have a program with the chess club
more than 60 children just in the very
first year have been engaged with
someone to Mentor them in chess and it
has created great relationships with
their parents so if you're hospitalized
for seven days ten days and you're a
child and you don't get to move around
so much what do you do in your free time
learning and playing chess with your
family is a great gift and something
we're proud to share with these children
that's amazing thank you for everything
you do guys any questions yeah Stephen
first of all once again our welcome
welcome good to see you on the show
thank you for everything you did you do
I remember as a 13 year old I went to
the Children's Orthopedic Hospital in
Seattle and I once did a chess
simultaneous against uh the children in
the ward that I visited and it was a
really endearing experience do you have
programs like that where chess
Grandmasters can go to the hospital and
play with the kids yes so that was the
heart of our share of the partnership
was to invest in bringing Grand Masters
and excellent chess players like
yourself into relationship with our
children again since they're there for a
week to 10 days on average it's just a
great opportunity for them not only to
experience the Journey of their health
concerns but also
participate in learning new things so
whether that's music dance art other
creative therapies but certainly chess
has been an extraordinarily positive and
popular program for us we have an events
coordinator that works with individuals
to get them to participate with the kids
and schedules everything so it's just
been a phenomenal to give these kids
that type of experience and I'm sure one
of them will be winning one of these
very soon nice for sure for sure no
that's a great program thank you for
that Stephen very very nice and good
luck with your strategies across the
board and again
folks can it's called the silent auction
you'll see all kinds of items and things
that the people
can bid on and everything that's raised
goes to the program there so again
Stephen thank you for your leadership
great
uh wonderful jumping right back to the
game of Lanier for a moment and this was
like an amazing moment this was to my
mind you know you you have these
positions where
people play brilliant moves to win the
game and then everybody says wow that
was great what a what a fabulous
performance you made that brilliant
attacking move but sometimes you have to
play brilliantly not to lose as well and
in my opinion right here right now Sam
came up with just an absolutely
brilliant idea not to trade the rook and
invite this uh passer pass Pawn to go to
D5 but rather to play the move A5 I
really whoa I that just blew me back
because we were looking at those
positions and they were very favorable
for white Lanier did the best he could
but the best he can get is actually to
get into a bishops of opposite color
ending he's a pawn up so obviously he's
he's enjoying the moment but can he win
I have a I have some very serious doubts
that you're going to be able to win this
position as white blockading king
this bishop you know patrols these
diagonals you don't want to let the
bishop coming into the position so your
king is rather stuck so basically it
means you have to win this position with
your Bishop yes
[Laughter]
and see how you can do that in fact so
uh that was an amazing move that A6 A5
uh moment and uh Christian I see that
you've got that game between Talia and
Sabina on your board did tell you make
the bishop takes H6 sacrifice followed
by B4 no no that was too much that was
too much it was so deep and it's so
difficult I mean this is a position that
you give to 2700 Grand Masters and you
let them think for 15 minutes and maybe
they will come up with the precise
sequence of moves that delivers the
Checkmate or the decisive Advantage but
you did not find out she played the move
Queen to C1 which makes a lot of sense
right now Bishop takes H6 right so for
example if you go to d8 sayonara after
this one is game over you take on H6
Queen takes H6 Queen goes to h8 that's a
Checkmate so what Sabina did was to play
the move H5 this weakens the position
but at least for the moment you will not
have any of these sacrifices for example
if you go Bishop to H6 right now which
by the way it's not such a bad move
because if you take I will take back on
H6 and I'll Rook to G3 is coming
queen takes F6 of course if you try to
defend uh against Rook to G3 then I just
simply pick it up I'm going to Checkmate
you in a couple of moves you cannot do
that so I'm looking at the position
and from a player's practical
perspective I will probably be thinking
about playing this move Bishop to H6
Knight to E4 seems to be the best movie
in the position taking away this G5
Square from the queen there's no more
Queen to G5 uh and delivering the goods
now the question is how do you do after
Rook takes H5 you cannot take once again
Queen takes H6 that's a Checkmate we
established that so you have to start
with the move F6
kick the Knight back then take on H6
then at least you have the queen ready
to go to G7 and defend your position but
still it's not clear you go Knight to G4
you take perhaps Rook fd8 is also a move
this is a big moment and if we do see
Bishop to H6 well the pressure is going
to be on Sabina Sabina only has nine
minutes right now on her clock and how
many moves
no 20 more moves to go nine minutes on
the clock this one let's see this is the
big moment
she played it right yes
again from an objective point of view
this is actually equal but it's so
difficult to defend with it exactly it's
so difficult
I mean you have to play Move Knight E4 I
mean all you all white species are
trying to Checkmate you and you move
your night ideas
really difficult to make it from Human
perspective I mean computer finds such
moves but yes exactly I will try to I
would maybe think about like give up my
exchange like playing G6 or something
like that you know take it take this
rook and just let me go yes I just want
to run away something like that you know
I will consider something like that you
know just to get rid of this attack
exactly yeah
um I'm just looking at darush versus
elshon looks to my eyes like elshad's
doing well uh darush is probably
thinking oh my gosh he's playing so well
against me and defending nicely but some
time ago we had expected Sam's
Sam Shanklin to wrap things up against
Christopher uh you and I've been waiting
waiting waiting for the announcement
that Sam has won he hasn't won it yet I
mean Christopher is fighting and holding
as best he can King E2 wow
some whoa what's going on here what is I
thought the King was good on F1 Sam
decided uh to take a walk yeah
it's very healthy you know to walk
stretch the legs
um yeah Knight G8 and well I I still I
think I like white but is it as
convincing I mean it was the advantage
that's convincing it is plus six okay
because what plus six The Rook is about
to land on G6 precise Bishop to D3 and
Rook G6 okay
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay it's completely
winning position yes I mean it looks
like that with the with your queen on H6
I see that the the systems really uh
resetting yes the system lost its mind
and this is it so it it it's still
convincing is what what I'm hearing you
say yeah yeah yeah but it's it's not as
clear-cut right I mean there's no
immediate breakthrough no why I mean
Bishop districts like wow
well no Bishop to D3 I'll go Queen F6
with the idea of trading the blockade
blockaders but the Knight on H6 and
don't forget when the King was an F1 I
didn't think there was any tickles and
that's probably why you want to go
Bishop to
c24 maybe even well there's no um
there's no media check like if you could
go queen of six Queenie photo yes yes
and you're threatening me and you're
about to land with Rook G6 as well
precise I like it all the stuff okay and
if you go to F6 yes because that's nice
yes
ah yeah wait a second Logistics
not so fast precisely and that's why
they play Queen to F1 now yes
wow to defend your rook and then you
have the room oh that's nasty but it's a
nice move on it's a beautiful very very
not easy not easy to see why not Queen
E1 because 64. it's not it's not as
clear-cut it probably is still winning
but it's not as good yeah because I
thought about Queen E1 for some seconds
well you know again the idea of Rook G6
and taking I mean oh I can't do that yes
but the move Queen F1 is really
Bishop C2 oh sorry it's really nasty and
that's a really
you know I mean it's a simple move but
it's Charming I like it just do you just
defend the Rook H1 and you go okay I'm
ready to play Rook G6 there's nothing
black can really do to stop Rook G6 even
if you move your knight I'll still land
on the G6 where and I'll be very happy
to capture your queen for the two Rooks
thank you for asking and the Knight to
go with it too very by the way well this
is what ellisley said yesterday that
sometimes you miss this moves when you
when pieces go backwards right The
Retreat this and this kind of moves you
people keep missing so like move Queen
F1 it's really easy to do yeah um
absolutely you might start thinking this
is the big one here he's ready to pounce
he's ready to pounce right now no Queen
F1 that would be normally he will find
out oh yes he's going for it is he doing
the hover that's the direction that he's
pointing his hand at yeah he's doing the
Christmas
oh Queen F1 is is a big money move right
now exactly
it's beautiful in its own way right
exactly it really is and imagine you
resign imagine you finish the game with
the move Queen to F1 oh so nice so
pleasing oh he found it great he found
it he's solving puzzles every day
well uh these former Champions what can
you say Rook Queen F1 that is very very
uh
um speaking of Alice Lee uh I just
wanted to see how she's doing with Arena
because when we left it I really thought
that Arena had this but guess what Alice
is still fighting it out what happened
and she's a pawn up
whoa Okay so
Arena played C4
Knight takes and she took with a on
did it I mean this is very easy to
calculate if you could imagine the that
the that the queen and the bishop or put
it the other way around put the bishop
on F3 and the Queen on H3 uh you're
winning very easily but okay Arena went
four
okay I'm a little perplexed so for
example if you put Queen F3 immediately
now white probably has defense like
rookity two and queen D1 right something
like that okay so like if you go
immediately forward like you try to give
a Checkmate yes you can do this yeah
there is still mine neither one also
okay but I like it's not working
I just I just want to bring this queen
something exactly back to the game like
maybe it's wrong maybe this queen
belongs to this diagonal maybe it's
gonna be a Checkmate one day with D5 and
Bishop h8 right right the southern I
mean Alice is like delighted to be in
this position
and uh I understand Naji and Naji has
made a draw but uh
Alice I thought was strategically lost
here she's a part of and well I'm
looking looking give me another move or
two and I can see instant counter play
either with Queen D6 and queen H6 which
is Rook C1 trade off those Rooks and you
won't have enough pieces that is to say
Arena will not have enough pieces to
deliver a Checkmate this could be a huge
huge turnaround Megan by the way
what's going on okay we we left it with
H5 coming on the board yes it was H4
Bishop back okay White's Pawn structure
is spoiled but on the other hand this is
a huge pond
I start to like White's position by the
way Megan only five minutes on the clock
is that correct
um
[Music]
like five minutes and 35 I believe Megan
Megan yes and uh still 19 moves to go
yeah oh sorry five minutes on that card
yeah if I have premature blindness I
mean
a lawsuit I mean I'm telling you it's
like you see that font on the top there
like so small
um what's going on uh first first uh
perspective is it's much easier to play
begum's position because this Knight on
E8 is so for Lauren exactly and uh in
fact even from an objective point of
view this position is uh winning
it looks like that's what I felt like
you just give a Checkmate no yes yes
that is one way all the pieces of black
hole are on the queen side so it's time
to just deliver an attack I I'm hearing
Echoes of Hans Neiman you don't just
look at the position you know you don't
have to add
just give the Checkmate you open up the
H file and Away you go by the way night
to night G7 on the board
I would like to play actually the move
G4 and just maintain the tension what's
my idea is that maybe unless I'm
overlooking Queen text E5 and I might be
overlooking Queen text E5 I thought I
was going to be delivering Checkmate or
something sorry I've just seen Knight G7
I went for G4 maybe I pre maybe I did
something premature a Christian Bale I
think G4 is is a good move now check
what the computer is recommending it's
not the best ah thank you very much H6
is the best now the idea is that if you
go on F5 I will continue with G4 that's
clear the same idea you cannot go to E7
because you get checkmated yes the game
is on that's good uh What if we go by
the way stage G6 was played by began I'm
not sure about this movie I don't like
this open up the H file what you said
yes I can take with the F Pawn right
okay I mean you have to take with the F
Pawn because Rook f8 is also coming
queen
I would keep the potential my guess is
that her idea is to go Rook to D1 after
F takes G6 which was played on the board
Rook to D1 and now after Rook to d8 to
go Queen F6 Rook takes C8 and maybe
Queen to F6 was that dsc7 no this is
yeah
that stops C7 even this position seems
to be winning after P1 no yes because
it's like wow I think it's like this
black is kind of stuck the question is
do you have anything better yes maybe
you don't need to think taking Rook to
B1 seems to be completely devastating
yeah ah and if you go Rook to B6
yeah now I just simply drop back to F3
and I'm setting up this Rook D1 root D7
wow
not easy stuff not easy stuff so from an
objective point of view why it is
completely winning
practically not that easy I can ask you
something without computer like when
Rook did Rook D1 Rook did was played yes
like Queen F6 here is it possible yes
like I mean yes yes and what if I go
here
just should be something you know this
is precisely yeah
you have a feeling that this is let's
see but but this is not easy to do right
really Bishop C6 is the only way to
defend you have to spot all these
tactics right but these moves are coming
like normal like objones yes the queen
F6 they have a flow absolutely but at
some point you have to spot that
critical tactic yes I don't see it yet I
must tell you but it should be something
I have feelings is on the board right
now
Belgium seems to have found something
now
we expect Rook to d8 it makes the most
sense yes okay Rook to f8 according to
the engine is the best movie in the
position but I don't believe in it
you're pushing the Queen the G5 yeah it
feels like you're helping white exactly
yeah no but also a good idea with Queen
F3 a quick win before to bring the other
Rook on D1 using the fact that Queen is
on g80s as well like after you take and
then yeah
and she's playing by the way she played
and you're saying you you like this also
this one looks also logically just to
drop your Rook on D7 that's the same
idea that's very very compelling but I
also like what you said with the queen
jumping the F6 that looked really good
maybe it just means that white has a
good choice yeah it's nice to have such
uh great options right and I think we
were looking at Rook dropping back and
then Rook coming in and you're
threatening made so there's no choice
you have to take with the Rook hanging
there's no choice you've got to defend
and the bishop drops in you can't take
the bishop but you're ready to take and
just you're stuck
you're stuck you have to probably play
something but now I take and then I go
Rook A8 yes right I'm not sure this
seven is this okay seven
take on K7 look at this okay seven Queen
B6 or was it Queen B6 would be seven
years
look at somehow holding you know until
the end this feels like one of those old
study like problems before you take the
phone exactly probably it's time to take
it yeah Harvest you actually don't have
any moves as black right you don't but
somehow you are not collapsing even
though you it feels like you have to
yeah
take yes
so you have to be a bit careful because
now you take on D7
I I let you bail out with yes you're can
you yeah
so we can give seven yes yes and there
is G7 does a great job at defending and
this is a critical moment right now
Beckham has 22 minutes on her clock yeah
it's not the thing that's a lot of time
so she needs to stop and think and try
to figure out not play on intuition
because at this point everything is
concrete exactly yes if you give black
one move they're going to play A4
secured the pawn on A5 you don't have
any Rook takes A5 anymore free up uh the
movement of The Rook on A6 and at some
point if I manage to give that exchange
with Rook takes C6
it might not be as easy
by the way in a game that flew under our
radar we do have a result between
Rochelle Wu and Naji that was a draw
yeah this first result isn't Rook D6
extremely appealing from the classical
perspective oh very much so I the thing
that stopped me on this one was Knight
E8 and who I takes and queen F7 uh I saw
some tricks with C7 but Knight takes C7
defends the rook and maybe The Rook is a
little bit weird maybe I have a queen G5
now uh Queen G5 I didn't I didn't look
further
than this but Queen G5
inviting the trade
also looks very very strong she is
playing according F6 of the queen G5 wow
okay so the same idea right what is the
difference exactly maybe not much of a
difference you still have to go Rook a
there is no there's no choice otherwise
The Rook is dropping oh excuse me The
Rook is
um if you trade Rooks I will follow up
with Rook to D7 and queen to E7 and
that's just devastating so we're
expecting Rook A8 we would expect
thereafter Rook D7 no choice all of this
is remarkably forced it's what um
Bishop C6 first sorry excuse me uh
Jonathan Levitt in his book you know
genius and chess talked about flow there
was this idea of a very narrow path and
each player you know just uh with each
drum beat had to make the moves and we
did see I think Rook A8 yes it was
played and I tried to still understand
the difference in some variations black
has moved Knight to five and then you
don't have Queen takes C6 let's say but
maybe it doesn't make uh that much the
difference between queen of six and
queen G5 that's let's say E6 spawn is
not hanging correct insomnia but
whenever you go Knight F5 G4 comes yes
no I think I just go Queen F6 then okay
the Knight is still not doing that much
it looks pretty right on F5 but it's not
anywhere it's not doing much I agree
so now I think I'm just winning a Tempo
I go Queen F6 you have to go back okay
ignominus Retreat yes
yes
um wow uh again guys this would be huge
for our tournament I I when we came on
the show I talked about how the Women's
Championship has been really tumultuous
with the leadership you know who is in
first uh trading hands Fabi has been
gliding and cruising even in those games
that he doesn't win like the moment
today he's enjoying you know the
superior side of a draw
and uh the only guy who's really giving
in if Bobby any trouble yes it's not as
his opponents it's actually been Ray
Robson uh we'll keep an eye on this game
I think Jennifer was really so much
material up some time ago uh yeah she
still maintained all of her material
advantages and she's doing a while yeah
she's doing well she's got this but
let's just jump to the yes one section
just for a second yes um go to the Talia
game yes remember that was the bishop H6
exactly yeah okay just because things
have uh developed a lot simplify the bit
and we now know that white is completely
winning yeah so yeah she managed to
break through this was this bishop H6
moment 94.94 she only moved before yes
there goes the pawn F6 from being up
upon now she's down upon and she's
getting checkmated
and Christopher you Sam has won his game
right
Rook takes aha this is that now yes now
Talia uh with an extra Pawn in hand and
also still by the way it's a very nice
looking attacks Rook is threatening to
come to G4 G8 and by the way Belgium has
found Rook to D7 Rook 37 yes great
actually I thought about one idea in
this position but you can speak about it
not in this one oh okay I also check
what Christian is checking but anyway
okay like begging position yesterday
later we'll also I understood that after
all these movements with Rook sometimes
we have this idea to bring the Rook on
F4
sometimes you know like uh remember we
were taking all these phones
like Bishop C6 remember like before yes
this was our Rook A7 version okay seven
yes and then for example here uh seven
okay Queen uh
Rook to B7 number seven yes Queen went
to and we we were kicking yes and after
move C3 remember yes then I thought
about looking for but our Queen was on
F6 and there were some Checkmate ideas
maybe Queen F7 Queen f8 yes so it came
to me later we missed something very
basic what really Rook A7 Queen B6 yes
and now Rook A8 there is no more
pressure on D7
this just finishes the game yeah so my
relation was too complicated
yes
simple simple Simplicity yes look for
Simplicity of great that is it that is
pretty because uh as you just said uh
Christian uh a moment before if we if we
jump too quickly or too hastily rather
with the move Rook A8 uh it doesn't work
because the queen just Scoops up the
pawn on D7 but by first playing the move
Rook A7 kick the queen away from the
Pawn on D7 Bishop C6 is on the board
okay great you know I have the
impression I mean begum uh was
brilliantly I know seriously brilliantly
outplayed by Sabine in the previous
round and you know she's just feeling uh
terrible what does she do she comes back
with a great game of her own I mean and
it's like these players are bouncing
back despite you know the worst outcomes
I agree with you yes sir I mean this
this you know ability to fight uh to
recover so quickly normally it takes me
now months to recover
if it looks like this I mean I will not
sleep for one month right yours and the
next day they come and they just win can
win now this is the difficult part for
Megan because uh things have really gone
against her slow down right right you
don't have any forced moves anymore and
you only have two minutes for the next
six moves okay but your opponent needs
to play a move I mean exactly you have
to make a move right now so yeah well
she do exactly like you know again I
mean I I can't move my queen really I
mean I'm I'm fearing that my opponent is
just going to play Bishop takes B5 and
then a developer Rook
I can't really move our my night night
just allows the queen to go to F6 yeah
so before it's like a tempting move but
what about if you take C3 exactly this
is this I wanted to go in this direction
yeah I mean I would probably as white
just played before takes D7 was played
the tree the world after episode and
Rook takes A5 I think all your practical
chances have dissipated vaporized yeah
not only that but you're actually
getting checkmated yourself really hate
is coming
yes and we've got Rook A8 on tap
um Christian you have a guest in studio
we do have a guesting studio indeed that
is Sam Shanklin after his important
Victory against Christopher you Sam
welcome back to the show finally it's
been nine rounds but you're on a plus
score yeah I mean how do you feel even
still it's been a pretty lousy
tournament overall I mean I just I had
two incredibly frustrating games with
neyman and Savion where I prepared
brilliantly both times I missed the win
when it came I was like well you can
work as hard as you want but you can't
fix stupid so you know it's nice but
still your preparation seemed to have
paid off in this one because you got
almost a winning Advantage out of the
deal all sort of freestyling pretty fast
like I didn't I mean I track Knight F3
and then I I didn't expect him to play
this I'd seen him play it before I
didn't think it was great so after
Knight F3 I just knew that I only
tracked E4 like this was just dealing
with I had looked at and I so like G5 I
think that's a little risk I've wanted
that too far but I didn't put much
effort into this just because
Christopher is playing on this event
just sitting at the board like what the
heck do I do if he plays D6 and so I uh
he played it yeah I mean my suspicion
was the position was fantastic for me
after Bishop G5 but in practice it was
not as easy as I thought it would be
like here F6 was I mean yeah Bishop E3
castles it seems like you guys are
following some sort of uh topical
variation you shouldn't realize this was
a dang Yang Yi game I know the game now
it's a toy beer game from the World Cup
but I didn't realize we were following
it so Bishop D3 yeah and queen C2 and I
just thought here we're still just sort
of playing and I was absolutely shocked
by age sick or by F4 I thought this
should just completely lose but actually
it was not nearly as easy as I thought
and this was the critical move when he
played Queen E7 instead of Queen E8 he
was supposed to yeah and after King F1
what's the big deal just to have Bishop
to G4 and ideas
yeah not so easy not easy I mean I
should be better but it's not that easy
yeah fair enough yeah because after this
I mean you've installed it was very
complicated I mean my first thought was
I should just be winning but like it's
it was not easy at all so for example
after 97 H5 if he plays Rook ae8 like I
know the computer like if he plays
rookie another computer will got nuts
but like I just had a lot of trouble
finding a win here I mean what I
ultimate came up with was rookie eight
rookie 8 Bishop G6 I wanted and it's
then uh Rook E7 I found Rook H4 I
thought was important Bishop F3 Rook F4
and I was trying to make bishop G2 King
G1 work but he has uh after King G1 he
has Bishop B4 which sort of ruins my day
so I have to go King takes G2 and then
instead and I thought after Queen G5
check and just King moves somewhere like
F1 or I wanted F1 but probably it
doesn't matter uh I thought I'm winning
but I mean okay it's one thing to know
to have you know plus two here but it's
okay there's yeah so I was expecting
something like this and in the game as
well it felt like I should be winning
but it was never that trivial and he
thought back well
so but you did find this brilliancy at
the end yeah I mean with Bishop to C2
this sequence yeah so it's actually very
clever I was almost about to play Bishop
D3 so that it doesn't hang in this line
but actually I found a problem you can
go Queen F6 yes now maybe really this
still works Queen E4 Queen B2 and Bishop
C2 Knight F6 Queen G6
and then Queen D4 and how do I get out
of the truck soon the computer just
finds a way yeah okay wait what
King A1 yeah yeah
but how does that actually no rookie it
King F1 uh Bishop D3 that's the point
yes not King G2 Queen C2 and resign no
then no longer have made it there's no
questions okay I mean I thought Bishop
C2 is just best practice so that in this
line after Queen E4 uh he doesn't even
have a check on B2 so yeah I just had to
take the but after Rook F6 I just take
the queen and that's that Sam Chris for
you is only 15 years of age how would
you assess his play what are his
Tendencies did you analyze him at all I
thought he was 16 already I don't know
uh well I mean I've worked with him
quite a bit actually uh no I'm not like
I'm not like his main trainer or
anything like that we only work a little
bit but I remember he came like I was I
think it was like 2015 or something that
uh someone asked me what can an
eight-year-old join your Adult class at
the Berkeley trust school and that was
the first time I met Christopher and
actually uh I felt really bad but I made
some comments about like his banana
looked really rotten and he started
crying and I felt really bad but I mean
ever since then it's been such a
tremendous Delight to watch him grow up
and you know I've it's been a huge
privilege to to spend some time with him
and work with him and uh I mean he's
just getting incredibly strong and I'm
glad I beat him now
beat them while they're young yeah he's
already pretty tough like you know he's
he's winning games here absolutely and
where do you see his potential land uh I
mean it's so hard to say
um you never know how how far anyone
will get uh I think he's very dedicated
and very talented so I guess we'll just
see I just I don't like to make
predictions like that you never know
what you just you really just don't know
player by player it I think it will come
down a lot more to his choices uh
growing up than anything else he's still
a bit young to making big Life Choices
or anything like that but you know we'll
we'll see I I certainly foresee a bright
future for him and I hope I can help him
any way I can Sam thank you for joining
us congratulations on the game we'll see
you tomorrow quick question for you Sam
you have a very very deserved reputation
as a great theoretician did you see what
a Wonder Liang did uh today against
faviano in this
Petra I saw that he played Knight takes
E4 instead which I haven't checked
actually this uh I actually faced it
once yeah but played it against me and
then I told myself after the I had never
checked it and the game quickly got
stupid uh I told myself after the game
go check this line and I don't think I
ever did possible
but yeah uh I wonder is definitely uh
he's he's straying far from the while
trodden paths this tournament that he
did against me as well yesterday too
yeah all right thank you so you know we
had today this question about tactics
and maybe we can ask also Sam what is
his favorite one okay I know that you
were very famous to for solving puzzles
and finding uh such moves like Queen of
one very quickly so what is your
favorite tactics favorite what sorry
tactical theme what is your favorite
character today I don't know I mean I'm
not the guy who cares about Aesthetics
at all I just want to win games I don't
care if the tactic's pretty or not it
just if it wins it wins um I guess uh I
think if you made me pick a favorite it
would be
um when you have like a rook end game
and you have say for example uh pawns on
H7 G6 against H4 and uh G5 one after H6
that H5 is the only winning move I've
always liked that way you have to
respond like that I guess that would be
my favorite if you even pick one thank
you that's interesting thank you Sam
good luck at the remaining uh rounds uh
your favorite tactic I'm gonna show you
here it comes this is the game of Talia
versus Sabina and you told me night
Forks yes and then uh Christian said you
know what I really like the night Forks
as well here it comes you ready for this
yes tell you play Rook G4 okay check
check hello
yes and she is now in a winning position
of Queen versus uh rook and Bishop that
is to say Talia thanks to that nice
little night park it is charming uh
those uh Royal forks I want to say yes
uh begum and Megan for a moment because
when we left it
um uh Megan had just given up in
exchange but we've thought oh dear that
makes uh White's tasks considerably
easier as their checkmating threats with
Rook uh to the eighth Rank and queen of
six let's see what happened
and after check well there was no choice
and well uh just uh May uh bacon is just
gonna clean up on the queen side
all those phones will dominate and uh
for Megan that will knock her down open
up an opportunity for arena or Alice
Alice Lee is only a point behind what's
going on in her game with Arena we left
it here as well as for Jennifer yes
exactly as well
a winning position so I was thinking
that Alice might might go for these
rooksy one she went immediately takes
takes Queen E7 Bishop C6
and whoa
look at what's going on here
uh excuse me but I think our eight-time
U.S Champion could be going down this is
a really really pretty move oh my check
this out Knight F4 don't even reach for
the night
exactly that's a check made on the on G8
and now Rook today after Bishop D7 you
cannot touch the Knight you can never
touch them oh the Knight is the yeah the
night is taboo Bishop to D7 sorry
Christian help me again
right
oh my goodness
oh my word Alice Lee is upsetting the
eight-time U.S champion in the and by
the way let's take a look at this
movement
like nine minutes against four or what
even right nine minutes uh and 30
seconds for Alice Lee and she's just
about to make a move four minutes for
Irina Crush uh and why wait what are we
interacting
unbelievable very quickly too wow it's a
wow it's the best pool
because look black wanted to to play
maybe bishop C8 sometimes roxy8 you know
closing what happened
yes please Christian jump in never mind
don't leave us hanging never mind
C7 yes
on the board but Rook C7 yes I thought
the idea was to go Knight to D5 but
actually 95 just loses check my spot yes
so be careful
and uh King H2 at your choice of mates
in fact a bit oops yes no so what to do
like so The Rook d8 Rook C7 Queen
ah now the bishop cannot move because
you lose the Rook so I get I go Rook to
f8 now
rook f8 and the bishop cannot move
so you can give me a check let's see how
that is you give me a check I go to
where do I go it doesn't matter yes
let's go there and now you go Bishop E6
yes your thread you protect and then
what can I still but can you take that
96 is not possible 26 Queen takes F2 oh
yes yes wow so you have to be careful
this is still not over what just a
second I I I must have something cleaner
than this after Rook C7 hold on why
can't I play Queen f8 yes let's check it
queen f8 I'm threatening queen of I know
Queen Jade and
I'm threatening me you're only I the
only move I see is Queen F6 then I have
Queen g king H6 yes Queen AJ King H6
how come
I I I'm I'm I'm putting myself in a
corner here just a second this has got
to be simple all right
all right check this out I'm ready I
just checked it with with the engine so
and
I'm not gonna take credit for this one
all right once in a lifetime I don't
know I want to find it you want it yes I
feel like Sam just give me the win I
don't care if it's a pretty ugly for
example no no okay it's not possible
because you'll just take the night no
that's me you are correct yes just make
the move came to H2 or King to G2
reinforcing the threat of Rook to f8 now
you don't have check on C yes right nice
congratulations very nice very nice
Chris bird I want an Arbiter check I
want uh my my co-host Anastasia to be
secure we have Fair Play Here Anastasia
nice
I had absolute confidence
first you move your king and then you
very nice no kinji too and it's kind of
a zoo
I was waiting for you
say this word right that's why I wanted
you guys to see because you know we need
to tap our producer well there's no this
is why you can't move the you can't move
the bishop
oh Arena actually maybe helps yes by
giving a check first so kids age two
where the king is going or King G2 yeah
so again the Knight is Untouchable
because of Queen H4 okay there is one
trick though right please so now if you
go Rook C7 back by the way only one
minute on the clock so what one only one
minute
check I mean seriously uh we'll have to
double check in our archives what is
historic in terms of the youngest player
to win against a uh um a former Champion
yes yes but so now this actually is as a
threat sorry
after Rook C7 black has a b h three
check no no Queen quinnish 3 actually is
a good one as well but Queen takes F4 I
was thinking ah Queen takes F4 and in
fact what if you after 2 f8 what if you
go Queen to H3
then I
trans
well I would rather not no no we don't
want into that end game so we do have
King G2 on the board Bishop E6 was
played Bishop okay sorry
okay but now about how about your move
or even D5
isn't D5 just it's crazy to to realize
that the the pawn on G5 just put it out
of your mind you can never take the
Knight because mate will occur after
Queen H4 my goodness be careful D5 I
don't think you have time to do that
Queen to G4 comes yes also Queen two
four is a threat yes because you don't
have checks but Queen to have faith seal
the deal because Queen f8 threatens mate
it forces Queen F6 I mean there is I
mean everything else is just Checkmate
Queen h8 and Rook G8 is made this is a
force deal now you cannot capture you
can't move the Knight because Queen F3
is a nasty response so how do you how do
and maybe you just went through the
ending no I don't know I want to
exchange everything to trade the Queens
but then at the end of the day
exactly at 92 I have somewhere well the
nice part I always have a check yes just
to make the time control and I believe
two moves are needed which move number
are they no this is actually move 40. oh
they made time control oh my goodness
Irina escaped what oh my goodness what
happened I really actually escaped
King G2 was the big blunder she was
supposed to go to H2 that's the
difference oh my God
why is it so different uh okay let's
start th2
[Music]
guys what was my first instinct after uh
Bishop to E6
I don't know what was the move that I
proposed Queen D5 D5 yes that was the
move right the problem is with the King
on G2
black has enough time to go Queen G4
Queen F3
give it a check with the King on H2 you
don't have time to do anything okay
that's a difference yes yeah because
there's no chance if the king is on G2
your threat of Queen G4 comes with a
threat chess is unforgiving oh my God
and King King G2 felt a little unnatural
in the sense that again your opponent
has a light Square Bishop yes why are
you putting your King on the light
Square that's just the Instinct just to
put your King on the dark Square no it
just yes like you should have this
you know like if your opponent is a dark
Square
guys
Bishop E6 wait a minute I'm still having
a hard time imagining that
wow you have to make a draw here this is
what you're trying to do yeah
wow let's keep going how is this a draw
check okay okay I always have Queen f8
but if I wanted to make uh if I'm
playing like crazy all out for a win
uh why uh G4 Bishop to G6 Bishop to G4
I have to be wait a minute this is oh my
goodness check this out so now okay if
you h8 yeah so if you go into the end
game yes you still have this idea of
Rook to H1 at the end right yes to
protect let's let's say uh oh that's yes
that's cute right go to H1 and now if
you we have a switching zoo I think you
take you take only six and how is the
same game King F6 you take on H1
you take only six and now you run
towards the A4 Pawn
oh you're in the Square you are in the
Square yes oh my goodness so now winning
I'm not sure because once you go to B4 I
go D5 and I give you the pawn back and I
gain a few more tempies okay so let's
see let's check it yes
one queen king C4
can be talking before but wait a minute
you go go ahead and win the pawn yes
Kingston Street then no can't I just
like uh zooks won you you know it should
be waiting for a while no is it though
all right let's you might have one of
those moments where you can't push me
away from A5 no no but that this this is
losing I think I go King A4 and I go D5
buying this structure is just very bad
ah as I I attack you from the side right
right
sorry for getting uh way way off the
Beaten Track here we've got this amazing
position on the board and wearing a king
upon and gig yeah what happened a little
bit uh a little bit too fast right right
right right right sorry about that but
uh
um so King H2 how much time did Alice
they just reached uh 40 moves oh so I
know I know but that's important but she
had I mean she played King G2 rather
quickly yes she did she did play quite
quickly but really it's like to Spot the
Difference like I don't know I would
also play properly King tutu
it's an easy it's just an instinct you
want to protect us I mean that's just
just trying to defend her choice you
know like you try to also defend because
look when you play King each H2 there
are some variations where you want to
move your knight and you cannot because
of also over Queen F2 so I cannot
explain you it's like a fear that you
will kind of lose something so you try
to defend everything yes yes
next to each other yeah yeah close to
one another bonding but yeah for me uh
King H2 is something I've just mentally
alert that you've got the light Square
Bishop so I stay away from the light
Square stay away from the light oh
that's a good advice very very good
advice actually to get this in your mind
yes but I'm just kind of uh
stunned actually I'm just totally
stunned that with one
easily easy to slip I mean that wasn't I
mean we would all make King H2 King G2
and make it without thinking and that
one slip and wow okay hold on we got
Mega losing we've got Alice and Irina
drawing this is a huge uh result by the
way and a huge Escape for Irena yes if
she makes this and we've got Jennifer
winning I might not catches Megan at the
top and Jennifer surpasses both of them
and Alice remains on five and a half
right half a point behind I I think
she's going to be in Seoul third
position yeah it sounds like this
okay so and Jennifer's is still in oh is
winning that game yeah easily easily
easily by the way uh because we I just
have to see did Italia play that uh
uh It's Italia versus Sabina that was
the I remember she got the queen yes yes
exactly the Royal Fork this is the
ending we think that tell you will win
this pretty
handily show she's got to pass Pawn of
the position King G2 B3 just nailed down
everything without this Pawn maybe black
could have some chances but exactly
winning the H Pond running that should
uh work out very very nicely for Talia
what's happening in the open section uh
after after a few draws three draws in
one win how's Ray Ray doing Prairie is
applying the pressure
right now sure he's applying the
pressure Queen to B5 I really like uh
the bishop is better than in that
position that much is clear and I think
that's the Talia versus Sabina that we
have on the board right now yeah that's
Talia versus subpoena I'm over on the
Ray Robson versus yes
uh where we're just going to play Bishop
C4 and there's going to be some Queen to
B8 looking at that A7 Pawn looking at
potential of Rook to die Rook to h8 try
to Checkmate team somehow exactly
that's the threat right
Queen B8 is really getting uh my
attention if I have to play Rook D then
I like this idea that you could put your
Pawn here your Bishop here and your
queen very nice it looks uh like Rey is
enjoying a clamp linear versus Sam that
was the bishop and pawn and whoa whoa
whoa whoa
huge programs but how did he manage to
do
we left it here and I thought
that
black was going to
no he's just oh that was not that was
nasty the king managed to okay
and let's catch up with the play
man end games are so difficult
and then you die and then you die let's
keep it alive
let's keep it alive uh oh an extra no
computer no proposes F3 yes to get rid
of this Pond but to get some space but
sometimes it's important
check this out
three with
wow I'd like to make sure the king
doesn't go anywhere right chess is hard
so can't I spear this point but then I
go King F7
and anytime I put my Bishop here then I
go back uh-huh yes wow this night
to go forward because you you have to
protect Pawn on the street okay wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait a minute
just a second okay you're telling me
that White's King can't enter I can go
but but what about I will have my
control play I think no how are you
keeping my my Bishops Bishop F6 okay
I'll go over you'll go Bishop E5 you'll
just hang right yes and now eventually
all right
I mean this one's tough but aren't I
eventually just gonna go B uh-huh
but it may happen that you would just
happen yes well no you just you end up
in a fortress right you're two pawns
down yeah but but there is no way to
make a progress yes like that would be
crazy
that would be crazy you put your Pawn on
H4 your Bishop on G3 that would be crazy
uh could Sam make a draw in this ending
two pawns down oh yeah it's a draw
Etc but still have to kind of find it
right
oh I was but I was going to win this
Pawn on C4 how do you get it yeah like
okay well uh I was I was gonna go King
eighth no no but I say on E5 yes and
then I go B4
and actually yes Bishop D6 maybe what if
I continue Bishop D6 yeah Bishop E5 and
then I go okay uh
and King A3 yeah so no better we start
move I like you the idea to give up the
C4 pawn and blockade everything Tom will
say this one
it looks like the time and now I guess
the question is can I go King E7 yes
this was the question I had you see I
told you I was going to have two
connected past bonds and you will get a
dark Square blockade yes yes and I think
that might actually be just enough right
now even this one even this one well I
go H5 I put the pawn on H4 right and
then I put the bishop on G3 that was
what yeah this is what yesterday
I don't know I understand I understand
you're looking at Bacon's game it's your
students that's okay it's okay I get it
I get it now we check this relation
twice it works fine yes
wait a minute I don't think it does okay
okay let's go to that variation once
again we've got it I'm thinking about it
and let's get the King on the other side
the white King on the other well okay so
let's go queen king C2 yes how do you
play King D3 okay once again I get the
king to E4 yes now I put the pawn on C6
yes
you can give five at certain point yeah
you staying
King E5 and B8 next move
really and the fact that you do it when
the bishop is here V8 and King D6 that's
over right yes beautiful
that is the easy win
mm-hmm no problem so you better don't
let this Pawn go to all the way to B7 no
we could stop it way earlier uh yeah but
that was a I mean you're doing a good
job at keeping my king out and it looks
like you're locking but b6b pardon me B5
B6 B7 uh you're you end up uh in I think
I understand so I keep the pawn on H6
okay and then whenever you attack it via
G6 igobish Buffet so you want to you yes
you you want to go two pawns down I'll
do the same thing yes I just keep the
pawn on H6 but why can't I go and just
that's one round six
five
how do you round it up I go straight
after like yes and how you will protect
it if I'm Logistics
so you're gonna have to move your king
okay only move yes okay King of Beach
Buffet think of something
let's let's that's fine King C7 that's
uh how do you say nail it down so it
can't move it can be eight and now we we
will show yes we will show okay and King
seven
um
the Missouri Tigers but I could beat
Gary
[Laughter]
You're just showing off right now yeah I
guess who has not the leader of uh her
Purge I tell you the Women's
Championship has seen an amazing uh uh
tumultuous uh changing of the the guard
at the top is the crown does not rest
easy
wins your game and you can see it it was
a slight smile I mean she could I did
you know like after yesterday Sabina won
a very very good game uh begum comes
back okay we'll keep an eye on this
Alice Lee just froze after Queen F6 she
hasn't made the move she has not made
sure she just froze she has something to
think about that she has time now right
look at her she understands that right
she's actually not easy at all apologies
if she's still even winning oh my
goodness and look at her she's
so disappointed well again it you know
you get those shocking moments in chess
where you just had this sudden
realization that the moment that you
thought you were winning your opponent
has a move that surprised you that shock
move and suddenly it's a draw
um let's just take a quick Gander at the
women's results so far we've got a few
games remaining but but beg him just uh
the leader of the tournament and
Rochelle who made the draw with Niger I
apologize because I was actually looking
at the open uh tournament and there's
three draws in the open one win so
there's only three games remaining I
wanted to turn our attention to Fabi
versus a Wonder Leanne uh Fabi has been
nursing an extra pump yes and still
ambitious
but we do think that the
the drawing chances are incredibly high
now because the threat of Knight takes
going into I think a drawn rook and pawn
end game are really high at this moment
we'll keep an eye on that one Lanier
well the controversy is is this winning
I'm going to say yes I I would be really
really surprised if Sam can hold this
and finally Ray Robson is enjoying an
advantage a nice advantage against
Alexander Lindemann quite the rounds so
far isn't it yeah but like every round
is full of um you know it resolves a
crazy game center whoa whoa whoa whoa
trails and Spills drills and Spills and
I know you've been playing around with
this bishop ending there uh Christians
with you well the conclusion at least
according to the uh the engine is that
it's a draw now how deep is it looking
right let's by the way he did not play
the move F3 yeah but let's take a look
so we were discussing this one right
right and now you run with the King
right Bishop six King B2 Bishop B5 and
now you yes Curry B5 right
Bishop C7 it wants to go immediately so
that after K3 Bishop A5 stops the king
from uh okay maybe yes a lot of sense so
what if I catch you with a bishop ah but
I have two squares E5 and F6 that
reached that diagonal whenever you push
B5 right so you will never be able to
put me in at Sousa
that makes sense
but this is a producer says no Zoo
oh man he's very upset he's gonna come
down and beat you up
I have bar defending me very important
very important uh you gotta you gotta
keep protection
because once again show show why after B
so you go B5 I and I go well wherever
you put the bishop right right Bishop B5
uh Bishop C7 I need to touch this
diagonal whenever you play B5 I cannot
allow you to get the pawn to B7 if the
pawn gets to B7 you are winning
so after King to A3 I go Bishop Bay five
King to A4 Bishop takes C3 B6 yeah B6
and now I'm actually in time
King B5
King d a and you no bd8 is losing
apparently what wow okay 88 is losing
wow oh my God okay my goodness right why
is it
your king was on D7 you could go to Blue
C8 and C6 right and that makes all the
difference in the world right remarkable
even maybe bishop so C6 and C8 you touch
the B8 square right once you touch the
B8 score it's okay
wow no no but I mean F3 is a typical
idea but still it's not easy to it was
not easy to spot and look at this lineup
on the five now so you don't have this
idea anymore okay but by the way this is
kind of typical this is kind of the same
thing right yes we're in the same
situation more or less oh yeah oh yes so
how it happened so we might actually go
into the same the same variation which
is kind of transpose yeah
just gave the pawn this way yes now yeah
but yes but the difference is is that
now White's pawns are
connected and it would it would have
been more intuitive to at least played
FR F3 in order to make sure that H3 is
weaker than uh the pawn on F3 this is
really really a tough ending I've I've
I want to run away I want to run away
and hide and wow what a game uh going on
there by the way it's apologies to uh
Sophie and Anna's
fans because we've been following these
games as the leaders we haven't paid
much attention to this one
first blush I'd rather be white yes it
looks like five pounds against four but
also and this is
actually really nice I mean it's if I
ever get a rook to the seventh rank with
a check that's uh All She Wrote and uh
Christian over to you we have a quite a
happy winner in studio we do indeed we
are with Guru back him to his Genova beg
him welcome back to the show a win
against the leader of the tournament
going in this round Megan Lee how do you
feel right now after such a victory oh
it feels amazing yesterday I couldn't
sleep after I lost the game so I had to
like I had to win it didn't matter who
I'm playing I just came to win the game
and
luckily this tournament especially the
ladies section is so topsy-turvy the
leadership position always changes what
is it about uh this event I think we are
not as strong as professional as a like
men's section we have like almost all of
us has different things that we do so we
really don't Focus maybe you're in a
crush she's the only one who's and young
girls or who work on chess more but I'm
a student too so I can feel others who
do something else in life that's why
it's kind of like yeah that opens up the
possibility for more decisive results is
what you're saying yeah we are not
stable I understand okay let's talk
about today's game because it was quite
tense and I didn't really know what's
happening in the position how did you
assess it I had no clue after she played
Knight E4 that's that's a weird move you
usually like everyone plays Castle so I
decided to just uh play something
logical like C4 Knight C3 it's it seems
to me seems like very logical and I need
to just develop my pieces and we'll see
I I thought she's gonna attack on C4 but
but it felt like my position was always
better and it was indeed taking on C4
was a bit uh dangerous yeah but she was
nervous I I do understand her situation
he's she's like uh she's trying not to
lose the game but she needs to score
some points as well that's why she
risked a little bit for no reason I
guess so you felt her being in the lead
puts extra pressure I mean you can't
even see the way she's moving it's just
like she's writing down the most she was
just very nervous to play the game and
you're playing quite fast up to this
point how did you assess it especially
at this point okay an extra pound for
her but you do have your own
compensation with this attack coming on
the inside yeah I thought two Bishops
okay I don't understand she has extra
pawn and I'm not getting it back like
uh I don't know in a few months or
anytime soon right so I just said I'm
just gonna play the game and it feels
like her night is not that well placed
as well so I I had h4h5 ideas but I
thought I'm gonna develop and at some
point it just happens
and you ladies went into this she was
setting up some ideas of Knight ac5 you
define it with this move Queen to E3
that's so weird here I
have a feeling that I let her like go a
little bit maybe bishop B4 at some point
would be better
Let's uh take a look actually at this
point it seems like she is slightly
better yeah that's so weird because I I
felt like I did all the natural moves
and I ended up being not like
even better yes because it felt like I
was better and Bishop to E4 Knight to C7
uh yeah I I wasn't happy about Bishop
before I thought it's the worst Square
because after Knight C7 she's
threatening like B4 and I cannot even
play Bishop D2 or something like that so
for example if you go H4 P4 comes yeah
and then A6 is protected yeah yes my
plan was to attack on B4 with the bishop
so that's why maybe bishop B4 would be
better for me than uh Bishop A3 at some
point
um maybe earlier right maybe here we
should before
uh unclear it does say like okay seven
yeah that actually improves the
opposition for uh black but still very
tense position at this point and uh this
felt like the critical moment if H4 like
H4 H5 was a good idea but then I
like spotted that if she plays Knight E8
which is a very natural move she's just
losing after uh D takes C5 yeah
I I thought she could miss it because
she was like she was in a Time trouble
that's why it was very hard to assess
the position it's so weird because if
you do something else you're kind of
okay you're holding the position well
only with this one night yeah I thought
after Knight D5 it's just equal yeah but
I wasn't sure if she's gonna give away a
poem
so you felt she was trying to because
she was trying to hold some chances of
winning the election that was that was
the thing I guess and she couldn't
assess after Knight D5 it seems like and
you found this idea with route D7 Bishop
to C6 which was critical and after that
converted a nice game began
congratulations uh right now you will be
one and a half points behind the leader
most likely Jennifer you going into the
last four uh what Ambitions are you
harboring about the last four rounds I
I'm just trying to play uh like chess
but unfortunately I'm not playing well
that's why I just want to play I just
want to show some good games because it
was a disaster and I'm very upset about
my games so I don't I don't really care
about the results it's like I already
missed my chance I guess but I tried to
do my best to end the tournament well
guys yeah just uh
game wow we really enjoyed it all the
way throughout Vegas and good luck in
the rest of the tournament absolutely we
enjoy watching you play and I don't know
Anastasia I think it's just time for us
to get a break but before we go on break
let's just refresh all the results let's
start with the ladies we have one
decisive game so we just so beg him who
won against Megan Lee the leader of the
tournament yeah yes and then Rochelle Wu
made a draw with nice bike he said look
at this I mean five games are still
they're battling hard and in the open
and in the open
Christopher you and two more draws
between Darius fears and Del Shan as
well as Hans Neiman against Western salt
and our two leaders in the open section
Bobby and Rey still hard at work as well
so we'll see you on the other side of
the break
foreign
as part of the World Chess Hall of Fame
lecture series author and international
Master John Donaldson will be doing a
live presentation on the 1972 Fisher
spassky match examining their early
lives and careers leading up to their
classic match you can join John live on
October 18th at the World Chess Hall of
Fame or watch the live stream on the
World Chess Hall of Fame YouTube channel
that's October 18th John Donaldson live
more information at stlouischessclub.org
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back to round nine of USGS
championships are very and then for
round going on in the Ladies as we've
just seen uh begum upset Megan and uh
opening up the door for arena or
Jennifer and Alice was going to walk
through that door until we reached this
moment check this out Chad King here and
we were looking at this line with Queen
takes Rook takes King G7 and we were
going into this crazy
King and pawn end game that would have
occurred after Rook H1 and Knight takes
E6 and we didn't come to any CR any
conclusions in that but Alice
is is heading for a king and four Pawns
versus a rook let's check this is going
to be a final one guys okay
and we're expecting them I was expecting
Rook C4 uh so it's a race I want to take
this Pawn as soon as possible takes okay
oh sorry excuse me first
and Alice uh by the way obviously
rejected the Perpetual exactly yes uh to
go into this ending and
uh
uh Knight C3 probably not well I'm
afraid that if you don't take it right
here right now it will so it may not go
and so I have a funny story about this
please end games okay I think I was
something along the lines of 14 years of
age okay I was going to my coach's house
every week three times a week
three to five hours wow
one of those days uh he gave me this
book I don't remember exactly by who I
think karpov was one of the co-authors
of of that book
and he told me yeah I'm gonna go walk my
dog just for you know 20 minutes 30
minutes you you started this type of
Rook end games right three versus uh The
Rook three points versus The Rook four
pawns versus the rook and so on
and it took him three hours to walk his
dog
and I was supposed to go through these
lines and at some point I got so fed up
with all this oh yeah if the pawns are
on the fifth rank if the pawns are on
the sixth rank then you're winning if
they're on the fifth one then it's a
draw my mind was just completely blown
and I had I still have no idea how to
assess this type of end games right so
we will have to wait and see how this
one develops but the engine is saying
zero zero but with four horns yeah and
this is not going to be easy also The
Rook is pretty powerful so
I mean what is your prediction yeah
let's just put it this way what is your
prediction do you think we're going to
see a decisive results for versus The
Rook
wow I'll let you uh
it tells you in an unpredictable
Universe yes I mean an unpredictable
Women's Championship you've gotta you
you've got to tell me what's going to
happen I don't know I have feeling that
phones are quite dangerous
okay you take the pawns I'll take the
road okay right I'll take it yes I'll
take the draw
because my table base tells me this
position is a draw it's a draw yes right
an amazing number of moves one almost
every move white makes including G4 F4
King F1 are all drawn but the players
yes I could imagine it's easier to play
before and this looks very natural my
eyes and it's a Pity nobody can turn to
the other one and say like drawing yes
everybody knows all right I mean no you
can't no draw first no no and we do have
Rook C4 on the board so they are heading
directly into this line and again Knight
takes F7 check this is the current
position Rook C4 has been played Knight
takes F7 check we can all imagine that
it shows the fighting Spirit of Alice
actually it does maybe she was thinking
that this position is was chances well
wow uh this is uh this is a crazy thing
to not take that perpetual and this is
just the update by the way Jennifer you
did win the win again so Sharifah goes
down Jennifer takes
lead at the moment it looks like a clear
lead right I mean unless Arena wins this
you know rook and Rook versus four pawns
I know
um my friend Jonathan Mesto loved to
play the dragon and he loved to make
these types of Bishop takes G4 where
he'd sacrifice one piece and then he'd
sacrifice an exchange on C3 so by the
end of all of these sacrifices he would
have four and
maybe even five ponds yes for some for a
couple of pieces and then of course he
he'd win with these pawns rushing up the
board but this is a this is a
uh
uh uh a mind-blowing uh I never had it
yeah I mean that's an interesting
situation maybe three against true
never had that before I mean I've had a
lot of examples of two versus two pawns
versus The Rook where you know the
result was clear it was a a draw or a
loss I mean just very very clear but
I've never had an unclear four pawns yes
sir you haven't played enough Jazz
obviously I have to come back I have to
come back and get to it
um
Christian we have a guest in studio we
do indeed we are here with Jennifer you
Jennifer another victory for you
congratulations you never know which
Rita you're going to get the one surging
three victories in a row or the one
that's just like giving pieces like that
how do you prepare for this type of game
I actually
such a dilemma yesterday because I I
didn't know what
um against her just also because of that
and I do think she has one of the
strongest repertoires like of the field
um which made it really difficult so I
like ended up playing um the Kara Khan
which
it's a bit of a weird choice because she
already played it twice this tournament
and she like won both of those games
really nicely but
um I just thought like I I felt this is
definitely something she would not
prepare against me for sure so that was
just kind of my goal to not get killed
at the opening and then you know I think
if I got like a nice end game position
um uh I would be really happy which is
what happened and that's exactly what
happened and I think she played E5 in
her previous games right yeah but I
think she used to play Knight C3 like
five Bishop for an H4
and you prepare this night with Knight
to F6 not Bishop to F5 which seems to be
the main line
and uh what was the critical moment
where'd you feel like you took her out
of her opening
um well I I knew like around here I
think Bishop F5 is not the most common
move like she because she started
thinking here after Bishop F5 which I
looked at a little bit but I
um didn't expect Bishop C4
um so I
I think I might not have played the
beginning part of the game really
accurately but after she played the C4
um the Pawns in the center started to
get a little weak and then I hear
I have to remove C4 yeah often C4 um so
now it like it doesn't look so obvious
how I can attack them but I have
something like nice regrouping ideas I
can like
um sort of like what happened in game
put my Rook onto the file and then at
some point maybe go F5 instead of six
which is what I was planning and then
she played this which kind of gave me a
chance here which was nice because
otherwise I was just gonna do
um something like Bishop to C3 let's say
yeah like F5
um three and then and I was gonna go
other than that like maybe move tonight
to be successful or Bishop F6 but it's
just like yeah it was just gonna be like
I felt like it was gonna be a lawn
maneuvering game and then I kind of got
a chance here so you felt quite
comfortable at this point yeah I was
fine with it um like I you know I don't
think I was worse I thought I was like I
might have been slightly better even
though
um just because the way the position
felt like it was easier for me to play
because I have a Target on D4
um
and she played this movie five it
definitely felt off
um and I think right now you're just
winning some material yeah so
um before 94 and then
Rook t7 I just didn't understand like I
thought Bishop D2 was going to be a try
um because I I still think I'll be
speech six right yeah like I think I'm
better here but um
but you know you still have some counter
play but after
um this Brook sock I just it's just over
after this one not only that you're
taking the exchange you're also taking
on D4 and breaking through so it's very
puzzling why she did this and after that
I think you just converted uh flawlessly
Jennifer congratulations uh beginning
for you now you're back in the lead it
always changes every single round the
leadership changes yeah why is that I
think it's um this is kind of the nature
of this field like you see it every year
when there's a different person that
wins too it's just there's a lot of
people around like similar strains and
everyone just kind of like depending on
storm over performs and then performs so
it's just kind of who's you know kind of
got the the street going and then
there's always a little bit luck but
it's definitely not like set in stone
anything
guys any questions for uh Jennifer yeah
of course first of all Jennifer
congratulations uh for getting back into
the lead I want to turn your attention
to this crazy position between Alice Lee
and Arena Crush for a moment
uh have you ever had a game where where
you you you you had uh four pawns for a
rook
because we're about four or three I
think actually
oh you've had three that's pretty good
um uh just your quick assessment of this
position because uh the the the panel
here have all taken different who's
better uh positions like I've taken a
draw
Anastasia you thought that Alice will
win yes and Christians
why not so you gotta break the tie yes I
mean I think it is four versus Rook then
I think Alice might be because it's you
know as long as you don't lose all your
pawns you're not losing well if you lose
one then well three versus Rook is still
like kind of took our chances yeah how
did you break the tie you're with me
right yeah
thank you golly thank you for coming Jen
bye
yeah
yes yes
our current leader yes I have one small
question is it possible to take Rook C5
uh
ask you something yes here instead of
them before your king is what in the
Square you mean Yes mine yes what about
yours I don't know
I'm I'm about to ask you the same thing
are we in the Square yes so let's go
okay let's go because I thought about it
that maybe we don't even need to go to
the same thing at the end of the day you
do actually yes because guess what ah
yeah uh so why does two bridesmaids in
this case so yeah you can go into the
king upon end game but it's just one but
it's important to check because you can
lose like that right easily I mean if
your king can stop my passer and you're
I think you're just it's a it's a Tempo
it really isn't it I wonder if both of
them check this out maybe sometimes you
can be afraid to play Knight C5 exactly
but unfortunately in this case it's kind
of Easy A forced forced
for circumstance yes so not to Rook C4
she played Rook before I would still
play Roxy for you know very like
confidently like asking my opponent okay
now make this move yes maybe there is
Rook C5 exactly you have to think now
again I don't think Alice can play any
games either after Rook Rook B4 Knight
C5 don't think oh I can you know catch
that pawn on A2 I will play Knight D3 or
so no no no I think after A4 you just
take it yes and uh you go into this F4
is important yes here we go here is
coming A4 on the board and I wonder if
Irina who has a great deal of experience
has ever had this ending in her chess
career uh by the way Christian I don't
think you you you had it you said
yourself you you told the nice story
about your coach going walking his dog
and saying you you analyze it did you
ever have a a practice of four versus
Rook of course not no not even close no
you get that once in a lifetime right in
a classical game yes in an official
classical game I think you could get
this again and look at it right made me
analyze the same games for three hours
and I never had them okay can you say
the name of the coach just in case yes
yes my coach was Mikhail ginda
yeah I know what a nice coach you know
[Laughter]
nice nice nice
wow okay F4 by the way played very
quickly by Alice as she's prepping uh
the obvious King F3 G4 and Talia has won
boy what a roller coaster Sabina has
been on it's not been a good one wins
the second game in a row I think she
liked to come here and we've had a good
time right internet I think very
friendly now plus one or plus two I
think plus one for plus one I believe so
but we'll double check that uh in a
moment seems to be breaking her spell as
well she was having a rough tournament
up to this point
two Rooks on a bishop has plus one notes
okay okay
with this result yes with this result
yes
got two Rooks two Rooks his great
compensation with the queen but a bishop
as well
so she should materially speaking
it's uh it's good enough and you just I
assume you just defend the bishop for
now King C8 and eventually this Rook
will get to some kind of good
thinking about Rook F7 was the idea
Bishop C8 some clicks you know oh you
look at you maybe you don't need it yes
but I just just check uh nice and just
realized it's possible to play right
okay so materially speaking uh Tata
should win that game
um instead more serious more serious uh
but this Alice Lee encounter is just
that I'm mesmerized I'm really really
curious
um did you have you been playing some of
the variations Christian like how give
me a circumstance where Alice could push
her pawns to to quickly and maybe
like losing one of them or
maybe some Perpetual check like you okay
here let me just show you before we do
that yes I just want to show you what
happened in the thought of game okay
okay because uh this move 39 she was
completely losing
she was completely losing she was
getting killed Rook to C5 check this out
Rook takes A6 still operating first of
all you can just simply go Knight to G6
and this would win on the spot as well
because after Queen to C7 now Rook to A6
there is no more Escape square right so
you cannot take on B5 because I have
Queen to A7 but even after Rook to A6
okay which was played in the game Rook
takes uh B5 Check Yes Point Way Seven
King to C7 and even at this point you
still have a wow look at this rugby six
with 95 idea this is really beautiful
this is a fork again family Fork yeah
not just the Royal Fork it's a family
photo that's the one I like yes that's
the one I like and the key is that you
will get your Rook to B2 so you're going
to go King to D7 I take your queen you
go Rook to B2 I move the king and now
after you take on E7 I have this check
at the end surprise yeah this is key
queen 283 once again a double attack wow
number six is nice yeah it's it's
beautiful yes uh Rook to B6 it was the
only chance and by the way
this was move 42. so she got some big
big Miss by her and I have to say she
played it instantaneously for absolutely
no reason she had two minutes and 16
seconds uh from her first time control
yeah so she couldn't she can think for
32 minutes if she wants right right and
find the move Rook to B6 yes it's
beautiful move she saw this check and
she got drawn to it but now it's
completely different King D7 Rook D6 and
we're getting into the same situation
but right now you're not taking any of
my Rooks and this is just losing so
probably just thought it the same
because she didn't see this queen A3 at
the end yes but you stop and you think
that's the key you stop and you think
you cannot play in such a difficult
position such a complicated position you
cannot play a critical move in 30
seconds yes that's just a lack of
experience exactly yes
um yeah just I I sorry I was just going
to say that in the game between Alice
Lee and arena for just a moment I was I
was I was about to set up a position
where you can get stuck with the pawns
by moving them too quickly yes uh how
was I doing that actually I don't know
but now it's clear that black wants
maybe to I don't know I was thinking
about King F5 but then you still play E4
and D5 yeah yeah you're helping them I I
was I was actually expecting that we
would probably drop the Rook down
so this is like maybe one way you can go
in the wrong direction yes I could be uh
wrong about this is something like this
this is where you kind of I feel like
misstepping right maybe even Rook a for
how would you pretend I know
like this this is how how by you you
could push the pawns too quickly sorry
which move did you no I'm just after E4
checking G4 and Rook A4 also I thought
yeah
no let's jump to Christian
we are with atalia Cervantes after an
important Victory back-to-back victories
for you uh Talia and an important one
against Sabina a wild one as well you at
some point play this move Bishop to H6
out of nowhere tell us about your
feelings right now
um I'm feeling great so far I'm glad
that I had this game it was very
exciting kind of breaks from the
um well I already broke from my sequence
of draws but it breaks from that from
that style a little bit
um yes and probably that Quincy one
Bishop H6 is probably one of the
weirdest move sequence I've played
um
yeah here I felt like my position was
nice out of the opening and yes so I was
thinking for a very long time
I assumed it was winning but I wasn't
sure exactly how this was the critical
move which is quite difficult and the
idea is that you go here all right let
me remember
do you guys remember the idea I think it
was something like this G3 and if you go
King h8 now I have Queen right and I
attack here and I think I noticed that
those ideas after playing Queen C1
because I think after Queen C1
um for example I thought that
let's just say Knight H7 yes and
um Rook G3 King h8 I don't think is
possible because then I have Queen C3
stuff Quincy so I saw that type of idea
maybe a little too late
um but I I mean I assumed it was winning
I just couldn't figure out how but still
very nice move after this H5 especially
from a practical perspective she only
had nine minutes on her clock 20 moves
to go and you played this move which
page six what oh it's actually not
losing I'm glad
it's actually a draw but
and I think she made one mistake and you
capitalize on it immediately Queen to F6
Rook to H4 and this move work to d8 she
was supposed to go Queen to G6
yeah so I imagine Queen G6 and Bishop E3
and then
um
I knew that my attack was gone but okay
I have a pawn and we're on time travel
and she has a lot less time than me so
you're feeling confident at this point
right I assume they would be good yeah
but after definitely after
Bishop G7 everything just seems to fall
apart yeah
and this end game is winning I don't
know if I play the best way but I mean
once you start pushing the H Pawn and I
think trading just a pair of books is
good there's no stopping that Queen and
two pawns against uh rook and a bishop
she's probably not going to find the
Fortress Thalia congratulations big uh
back-to-back victory for you and uh
we'll see you in the remainder of your
games thank you so much well done tell
you indeed and uh by the way big uh big
result in the game between Lanier and uh
both of those players were plus one
hoping you know to get clear third let's
say put it like that and uh despite his
best efforts uh Lanier with an extra
Pawn on this bishop ending uh made a
draw and I must say that uh for Sam
Savion these last two games he was on
the precipice of losing was he was close
to losing against file B's close today
but he held uh yeah
they're waiting for an Arbiter to come
and uh approve uh their uh three there
we have it so Sam wants to show that
with the next move he's going to repeat
the position it doesn't seem like
is linear okay with that is that that's
a good point I mean sometimes like you
you ask your players like if it's fine
this seems to be an incorrect claim of
threefold repetition and right now it
seems like linear will gain two extra
minutes on his claw yes so no Drovers in
this event I mean
yeah
um just to be clear how it works is if
you make an incorrect claim which I
think is fine I think you should make
the incorrect claims just because
sometimes you gain you know this idea of
like how many moves have been played and
when it is it going to be correct your
opponent gets two minutes the penalty is
that your opponent is awarded you know
two minutes it's a big deal you don't
lose any time yourself that's important
no but it depends you know I mean there
is some still psychological trap here
I've seen also like once Alexander
Casino claiming uh three times
repetition against uh juven June and the
final round of Olympiad and and then she
realized she was wrong and actually I
think she was really upset that she even
tried
yes I mean if you take it easy really on
the way like okay I actually even want
some time while the Arbiters are
checking you have plenty of time to
think about your position but I think
she took it like really seriously she
was not happy with the disclaim and then
she made a mistake and the laws of this
game quite quickly after that yes so
it's also depends on person I believe
that sometimes it's a good idea
especially when you try 50 moves yeah
then it gives you an information
yeah you're two away yes funny you
should mention uh Alexander costen York
because in Baku at the Olympia there I
was the women's team captain and such
was the case that it was Russia versus
uh United States and uh Arena
claim to draw yes against Alexandra
costing you also also and it was a wrong
claim it was a long grain and
Alexandra wanted to continue the game
okay but the correct result was the draw
okay but she she forced the play and
lost the game yes because her opponent
wants to make a draw but she doesn't
want to take control so she had to play
for a win instead of allowing the
repetition so yeah it's funny that yes
was victimized twice yes so it was in
Baku and the one what I'm talking about
this match was in Batum I think Olympia
so it was just a couple of years later
yeah and this game was actually decisive
for all results in women's section
because it was China against Russia
Russia lost and then it affected
everyone everybody everybody was
impacted okay so the game between Lanier
and Sam
how is Fabi doing uh Fabi uh rook and
pawn end game
according to my
um table base the table base is just
saying draw like all kinds of ways that
this game should be a draw but how about
Ray Ray has got four versus four
bit okay come on this should be a draw
too so
um you you can try for it a little bit
but that's yeah yeah
exactly it's just something
let's go back with the King and then
wait for an opportunity to attack these
pawns when you don't lose the pawn on A7
with a check so since we might be seeing
three grass yes that means that Ray
despite the fact that he put on a lot of
pressure on Alex landerman he would not
be able to catch Fabiano Caron right
that's close super close to catching
Fabiano but he's not going to do it no
not this round
yes no it's still it's it's a race I
mean they will still compete and I like
it you know I like the situation when
you don't have the only leader like okay
we have the leader but still we have a
chasing group and people who are still
trying to catch you and even know now
that Ray Robson he has a dream he wants
to become the US champion and it helps
me you know when you have your goal
exactly I don't know he was there
already
well it's a the irony of course is that
Rey's
um uh goals in chess whether to play on
the U.S Olympic team in metal yes
achieved to become an elite player at
the 2700 class had to win one U.S
Championship
uh well he achieved a second game goal
which was to become a lead player of the
2700 level now can he win a U.S
championship and make it a complete
trifecta
I wanted I'm very disappointed with
Jennifer
he could not take my my my uh position
you're you you picked her for the whole
event where's the Loyalty where's the
Loyalty so I'm being yes right I'm being
forced to poll our audience and get
their support Alice Lee versus Arena
Crush very simply what's the outcome
going to be we should have some kind of
a poll that's a good idea yes right
viewers join the good guy
yes they have three choices okay let's
do it you went I went with victory for
white and Jen as well as January also
yes uh Christian went for a victory for
the Rook that's you know I think he just
wanted to build a different size that's
the experience speaking I think you
might have gotten this one yesterday yes
and then okay goes with so I was I think
it's going to be very very calm like
guys guys guys but we just see how this
move D5 yes and okay if I'm in Alice's
position
I'm thinking G5 E4 let's go
it's all very very very exciting how
exciting is it uh it's a draw with
anything
that doesn't give the Rook away yeah
like Ruchi to Rook G3 Oru G4 anything
new movies to draw yes okay but still
which is a bit strange I was expecting
much more
um right A Clash right
so what if I go rooked away the results
are in I'm being told by Tom our
producer extraordinaire and the internet
you know they joined the Winning Side
this is great draw control yes look how
big support you have I mean it's tough
it's tough it's tough
that was a two people responded
not true not true
this is how fake news spreads yes sir
because we are we are on a 30-minute
DeLay So we cannot know
what uh what our Paul says yeah we will
know in 30 minutes from now our producer
I mean he's having a lot of fun at our
expense it's true it's true I'm gonna
talk about I'm going to talk to my agent
about this misinformation yes okay help
us try to understand why it's a draw a
Christian well for example if you go G5
we do have G5 on the board yes yes so
what are you doing King 2 D6 I would say
and then I gotta go E4 right now I start
giving you tracks
oh look look look okay okay
yes because you don't want the king to
go to different foreign
you just have to calculate these very
difficult moments and I like to torture
my students as well but not this type of
events
that's actually my checklist well I was
just thinking uh okay I understand that
King E4 but also like after Rook G3 I
think I can sit right King D4 ah of
course you just wait King D4 Rook G4
yeah before G3 maybe we see this this
type of a draw and I I was thinking you
you could get into these positions where
you you know pawns were over extended
but uh you you did this or I can do what
I did
with five phones we will be winning
right I've got to ask for you
having a very cheap price it's in
Romanian but I've got a memory you're
gonna love it if you have three hours
nice nice nice okay I I mean the human
move is to play E4 yes I mean you just
uh because King on the move one right
okay so E4 what about King C5 if I play
for win because we remember the
Christian he took on Black's side yes
now what I feel like enough yeah five
cost you the Jeep
yeah
yes and then I will just kind of repeat
your skin gets free that makes the
easiest draw yeah she plays for victory
I like it Alice she declined a Perpetual
earlier in the game to go for this four
versus Rook ending so what about Rook D1
then G6 and you this is how you lose
right I'm just trying to find a way how
to win for white
I think G6 is still a drop yeah G6
groups G1 oh you have to go back yes yes
and then after F5
I just wait maybe I can get five right
oh sorry king of five king of five yes
give me the pawn right and this is
probably before check before I'm going
to go
well wait a minute before wow sometimes
it's not a bad idea to go from
um
to avoid any checks not to step into a
check but
wow I don't know okay is time a factor
and Associate actually no I can't be but
at this moment they have uh if I see it
correctly
for four and a half to eight minutes yes
okay so just to remind the audience if
Arena wins the game yes she'll be tied
with Jennifer for first yes if Alice
wins the game she'll be in second place
yes
it was six points yes yeah but she'll be
joined by Megan at six yes Megan yes oh
it's already at six so
is
Arena gonna join me or not yes that's
right yeah wow
yes
the more we checked before right so make
sure that this phone the thing doesn't
go forward yeah this is probably the
most accurate move uh Rook G3 and if you
go King then again a very accurate move
the pawns are frozen yes and this might
be the easiest way for Irina to make a
draw
you go away but eventually at some
moment you have to
uh win my Rook
this is how we get to naked Kings yeah
so I think we should catch probably the
final please moves from that game
between Fabiano and wander yeah
absolutely uh
that is the Ray Robson game pardon me
for just a second as I pull up Fabi this
is a rook and pawn ending and wow
you have to be careful
everybody if white wins this Pawn
but white doesn't actually make that one
very easily check well as soon as you do
win it uh I get my king but I also go
Rook C2 oh yes
sure absolutely and King went back to C5
that's interesting okay
after
sorry after King F5 so how do you win
afternoon
they're just repeating probably
of driving my uh King away King away
yeah
wait but can I go see three now that was
my question too c3b3 I try to I try to
uh steal the pawn so maybe that's the
only way to like try to lose yeah
I wonder
all of them should be a Dropbox right
question is how difficult it is to make
it to draw yeah I'm trying to make a
draw by by force but uh
probably it wasn't necessary King F7 by
the way on the board I think that's a
very clever move uh by a Wonder as well
a very nice move yes yeah and I would
assume Fabiano is going to try it
continue King D6 yep Honda King until
well we have a check and we'll go back
and I think okay so now maybe this is
three is even better oh even C3 but I
think the the check-in back to C1 is
what he's going to do he doesn't need to
calculate a different type of position
right that's uh that's basically what I
think he's trying to
to achieve
okay yes check yeah
he goes back yeah but just actually in
that moment I think C3 is actually
pretty darn clean isn't it before Rook
B1 Kingston questions
I mean this pawn and The Rook is ideally
placed so that uh
like if you drop back with the Rook for
example and now I'm threatening Rook B1
I'm sorry one and now I just quickly
crawl towards the king side but towards
the promotion Square
but okay with this game uh being a draw
Sam Savion tried to make a a claim
uh of a draw a three-time repetition he
wasn't successful according to the fide
rules no great pity of course but I
found a plan for fabul like to play kids
games three uh
for example for black then you go King
A3 well in fact it's way to move so okay
King A3 you're welcome that's the
problem is through K1 yes but I just
thought that go ahead three Rooks
history okay so if you could get in yes
maybe I mean well okay you know I can
win a phone well guess what Fabi fabby's
thinking the same thing so he started
exactly yeah but now I play Rooks two
and then King A3 yes right and then once
you put the Rokon C3 Exchange I go King
E6 king before King D6 King takes C4 and
King C6 I get uh the opposition and
that's a draw yeah
it's probably the final try that Fabiano
will attempt
[Music]
ing this is
well known
this is like one of the very very first
most basic endings you have never
studied be a little bit careful yeah
because
where is the king the king's on F5 right
so if you go King F3
the king is honest yes yes yes yes
so the king is on F5 right now maybe you
can reset yeah I apologize I will do
that right away
yep and after Rook C3 yep
Rook takes C3 King E4 don't go this is
very yes
before King D3 is black yes
please sign the score sheets that's a
how that's what we call a howler moves
that's so bad that the you're after
gentlemanly like conduct you resign the
game you can congratulate your opponent
yes sir and then you walked me are you a
meme connoisseur
no so there is this meme that says
ambulance not for me
my opponent yes yeah
so I I I once saw a cartoon where the
chess player had come to the Arbiter and
said
excuse me uh I'd like to claim a win on
time
as well as you know call an ambulance I
believe my opponent has had a heart
attack
I waited until his flag fell
and they are going into that King King
ending King E6 he's not even trying
he doesn't want to pursue his winning
chances it doesn't seem like he does he
doesn't even
flaking before right
again C6 okay
what was your worst howler where you
just felt like the whole world was
against you you may you had blundered a
winning position away and it was a very
important game what was your worst okay
the worst ever memory yes one of the
first I remember no no actually it was
the one event my first International
Event in Minsk to your first internet
yes like when I was 13. okay and I
played this game can you imagine just a
Bishop Eddie we had only one bishop and
one bishop and I had let's say five
pounds against four bones so it was the
ending with extra pound for me and I
managed to play the move and he gave me
a Checkmate in one move so how you can
do it I will show you after like the
position how you can get checkmated with
one Bishop one Bishop yes okay that was
a shot no that was a shock and actually
I was I mean I was really shocked I
couldn't sleep after that of course yes
and I see the scoresheets are signed I
drive Ariana will make straw
um with some
and you could see a bit of a
disappointed Fabiano right yes it looks
like yes a little bit but I mean he'll
have a good winning chances he will
appreciate the fact that he was the one
uh pressing still yes for six hours
again he's making draws
but if you think about the draw he had
yesterday with samsa beyond the draw
yesterday he's enjoying the tournament I
mean he he's on driver seat yeah he
could be plus five if he had gotten a
little bit extra Lucky in today's game
or yesterday's game so I mean that's
usually the mark of when when you're
playing well it's like all of the the
positions yes seem to be going in your
favor as well it's nice to be at least
to make this type of draw not to be the
one who is different exactly exactly
that does however narrowly it does open
up the door for Ray Robson to say hey
can you win and tie for first uh
with uh by winning that is to say and
again I think we're in a table base at
least something popped up on my screen
the moment I flashed on this game after
the move Rook H1 apparently it's drawn
the king is somehow
um
I want to say I'm stuck here what can
you do like okay
I guess Ray wants to come back with the
Rook
and
cleverly play King G7 and exactly how
he's going to do that I'm not sure he's
not going to be okay look I mean King is
six you're just King E6 might because it
just sounds exactly yes
no no no I understand uh-huh
is it so that's that's his only trick in
the position right I think you just have
to stay with Rook H2 Rook H3 that looks
like the the most simple right stay on
the H file the king never goes to G7 I
can
no I mean the moment I check you away
you're ready to go excuse me you're
ready to go King and King so this must
be once you go to G1 I think I can go
King E5 also and just start running my
own ah
so once yeah
yeah you go King G7 I go F5 you go HC
because I go with four I don't I don't
think you're even close right and he's
done it's the same topic yes bounce
against the Rooks yeah oh my gosh how
could we uh how could we let this uh
moment uh slip by the Alice Lee and
Arena crash what has happened nothing
nothing so good so we haven't missed
anything it's going to be ah yes it
actually looked something happened let's
refresh the board yes exactly we have
had Okay so
after King D4 look at Alice saying no I
don't want to try I want to try yes boy
she is
really she's a fighter absolutely
absolutely again I'm imagining Rook
[Music]
G6 and now King E4 yes
G7 that would be the simplest yes okay
we have to admit yes that's yes sir yes
probably it's going to be a draw well I
mean I I don't want to Lord it over
yourselves you know these type of things
they come with experience
no but also through the story Irina who
found the exact way how to defend
against those crazy pawns right I mean
she found this trick with haruk you know
trying to
make sure that these pawns will not
advance so easily exactly I just wanted
to say another result was Sophia versus
uh Anna zatonski that was also drawn and
we we left it we I kind of liked uh
Sophie's position better draw in that
game again that leaves us with two games
Alice Lee versus Arena crash weeks I
think that came to be
uh no we're just up to date uh and then
we've seen tatav with two Rooks that's a
lot two Rooks and a bishop versus queen
and we think that uh well from a
material point of view she should be
easily winning this game if she doesn't
win this one I cannot imagine yeah
you're just having a bad tournament and
you can't win you know there are still
some Chucks I mean yeah there are checks
and that's a problem yes it's not that
easy really yeah it's not that easy
I mean there's so many checks coming
your way no but now we're after rugby
seven
no more checks no more checks
so many checks no more checks coming
here no more no more uh I was wondering
it it wouldn't it be just possible to
kind of uh warm your way slowly slow
slowly up the board yeah
nobody likes all these checks
exactly stop giving me this check or if
you want to give it on d8 and I will
take your queen and I will assume we're
going to see some Queen E5 trying to
centralize the queen
it will take time you still have to make
the progress yeah how how do you make
the progress
I I thought it was about bringing the
king yes up the board if you can get to
B3 you're waiting I see some Checkmate
ideas with Rook these three Bishop C6
Bishop G2
nice yes so if you go King A5 idle Queen
C5
ah that stops me from stepping on uh
that's a mind Square I like history to
make sure but not only that you know
just to make sure that you don't blunder
a rook you know like buy a check and
you're picking up the Rook yes okay
maybe F7 maybe F6 to
um disturb no but I thought that it
helps me to put my Bishops to six foot
unfortunately I mean after you take take
but then you lose H6 pawn and it becomes
unclear and I think it's very important
notice that Tate only has 45 seconds on
her clock really no it's really bad
shape literally I mean
yes okay this is a little bit nervous
minute and 10 seconds
and there are ideas like you guys
pointed out of F6 yeah and then it's not
so easy because H6 phone is but look she
found an interesting idea to bring uh
the second rook and try to play yeah
don't go on the a file if you go on the
a file I go Queen A8 be careful yeah
absolutely no I don't like the circuit
one wait a minute oh wait wait wait wait
is this just forcing a repetition no
because I can I can I play King C5 do I
walk into some but nasty now I go Queen
E5 and that's a repetition right yes no
I'm gonna put my Rook on D5 yes Queen
take your Pawn okay
and I don't have any meat do you
Checkmate I would be shocked with 40
seconds also it's not easy
you're right it's it's not you can never
lose this position if you're not careful
yeah those phones will just run F6 well
there's one thing I have learned yes
it's almost possible to lose any
position you know like I wow uh okay
hold on I'm gonna refresh my board
apologies to our fans
um
yeah
not easy like it's not it's gonna finish
in the drawer
wow
and again how much time did you say one
minute underneath
one minute 15 seconds and then and her
opponent is yeah 19 minutes oh really
young guys got a lot I I thought it was
it was like one nine and I'm thinking 19
seconds and no no 19 minutes sorry sorry
okay so linear took the second Pawn
he did he did that's a good thing
so here we are in this in this position
yes isn't this the ending that we want
needed to avoid though I thought so too
but now my king your pawns are not as
advanced yes yes remember
right like we couldn't find a way for
white to actually make any progress but
it was respond on F3 that's right that
was the difference yes so this is a
technical position uh apologies it's a
little bit dry it may it may be a win
for linear but this is much more
exciting this this game between Rue Yang
Yen and Tata with
how do I hide how should Tata hide her
King
Anastasia ah you asked a difficult
questions
come to my rescue yes I think she was
she played A7 yeah so maybe Queen E5 and
Bishop by six but then Queen C5 also
okay this is what's going on well King
B8 Queen d8 check if you right now if
you want to exit the repetition you have
to give up a pawn uh oh how do I do that
so you have to go Queen C5 Rook B6 Queen
C7 Bishop B7 that's going to allow me to
at least take either on C4 or on G7 well
I like taking on G7 that's for sure
that's kind of like uh giving white some
chances of her own so this is tatv's
next big decision
right will she give the pawn and try to
break the repetition or will she take
Direction
she obviously is playing for the win no
no I don't know Quincy let's see whether
she's going I'm not sure
I think she can still come back to the
the same line with she's trying to win
some time to be able to think now if
Bishop B7 is possible okay well she's
about to yeah so of course goodness okay
so
Rooney says look I'm not interested in
the C4 Pawn I'm really interested in the
but that's an interesting decision why
not Queen C7 exactly oh yes okay
and uh well all about these thoughts
that gives up the pawn
yes yes okay
everybody wants to be a hero yeah so the
queen G7
what's going on Rook G1 I don't because
wait wait wait but I do have Queen A3
also
so this is what that's why she played
cool
excuse me she's just saying that wait a
minute now I already have the Perpetual
I does she that would be remarkable
because so you can get out of the
Perpetual with King B8 and Bishop C8
right but then I take on G7 and it's a
worse because the bishop is uh not
active not a very active business yes
yes so that was very smartly done by uh
actually yes
wow impressive impressive stuff yeah and
and to considering the fact that that
doesn't have time
she's making the Right Moves yes like
only one minute now look at this 58
seconds
yeah no I think she should make a draw
at this point but you know how hard Tate
wants to win this one yes of course and
this because I mean
right it's a difficult difficult
situation right now and look she's she's
very struck by something by the way I
see a slight shaking of the camera I
have this image of Marcus get you know
there's 20 kilo babe he's just holding
it
as best he can
he's not working
I thought that they have those wonderful
tripods you know that they keep I don't
think the camera was shaking I think
that it was shaking ah okay and we have
at last a result Arena crash saves the
game yes Vindication it was a lack of
respect by my colleagues
yes
yes yes with the great support with the
great support of our internet audience
not Jennifer you no shame on her
so and Alice looks disappointed like
like this is the worst thing that she
let the wind escape and it wasn't that
clear all the games almost over he only
thought he was fighting so we have three
decisive result that Lisa lost against
any for you
um beg him won against Megan Lee and
then won this nice game against Sabina
for sure two three draws against Sophia
and Donna Ellis and Irina and Rafael and
Nazi
and in the open there are two games
remaining where we have five results
yeah we have five results and only one
decisive result today Sam shankland won
against Christopher you all the rest of
the games finished in draws they still
have a linear Dominguez play and trying
to win this ending against same Savion
and Ray Robson against Alex it's trying
he's trying but we don't think there's
much going on here as Alex has just
played this very fine move F3 45 seconds
for uh oh tative
lets me bring up a Tata scheme will she
no I think it's something I think
already already white we should just try
to play for we know with Queen G7
no no
no
I will explain you why because uh like
oh because he wants to draw Anastasia
you're getting greedy
because of the talent this yes place
with 30 seconds increment and you can
see that she's nervous I mean she
doesn't like what's going on maybe Queen
G7 tried to find the easy way what to
play against F6 F7 right a minute to
practically it's not that easy no
and I think the results are actually
going to uh pour in right now because
all of them are just finishing quite
everybody will finish quite soon let's
just uh and again in our open section
Ray Robson
um
uh could potentially tithe at first but
not after that
no we're going to go to and I think
there's another Rook on the board
somewhere yeah it's way over here on A2
it's kind of hidden by the case right it
looks like it's off sides
page seven King G8 King G6 okay now Rook
takes H7 okay rate right in this game
but uh good fight good fight great fight
great fight he put uh Alex under some
considerable pressure yes for quite some
time we have a draw
and which leaves us with one game
remaining yes just uh linear and Sam
yes and Sam Sam is asking this question
like how are you going to win this
ending I think so exactly so if I put my
king on C5 and even if you were to win
the F4 Pawn
G3 wow there's no way to break the
blockade there is is it I think so well
so maybe not as easy but I got the idea
yes I'll try to get the king all the way
to the other side and once you move the
bishop I go Jesus G4 yes and then we
could we could get this far yes right
let's defend the pawn on B5 justice of
course of course
and uh let's just put some moves on the
board and like this so you're saying
what would you do so King C5 for example
uh King again sorry King Esa King e6s
yes yes and uh okay I I I pass yes now I
go G4 that is G4 you have to take and
then H4
yes but no no but that's actually I
think the way to make a draw I have to I
have to force you to marcher King
but that's the way to make a draw I
think
so right now you go Bishop F2 you allow
G4 take no Bishop F2 Bishop F2 I
apologize yes so let's say Bishop F2 and
when you go H4 I go G2
and
if you do that probably I lose
[Laughter]
I go King King C5
King cc5 yes
well if I go King C7 you go King takes
and then you you make a b line to the h8
square at least I hope that I make a b
line two right
I don't know if I gather but it's it's
kind of a one tempo situation right
is is
time a factor no this game I think
they're fine two minutes and 30 seconds
versus three minutes and 43. uh but the
position is quite simple right
simply complicated you mean
yes there will be a moment you have to
find out before and I bring my king and
I try to pick off the F4 Pawn but I
don't give you the effort I know for
example it was a bit too nice to give
you this yeah I agree for example you
bring your king all the way to G4 I play
Bishop G3 and then I only move my king
right yes and then it's there is no way
exactly put your Bishop by G3 and you
oscillate between B6 just move your king
be 65. so I can keep the bishopone F2
and G1 and whenever you go to D5 I keep
the bishopone G1 A7 diagonal whenever
you go to E4 I go Bishop H2 or Bishop G3
okay we just have C4 on the board we can
imagine that
King will go to Pardon Me it King B6
what's the last move
King E4 Bishop here and your king will
just wait yeah
they're waiting I can even move my
Bishop to which two now right we also
have this chance to do it I don't know
if not I'm just wondering where my
Bishop needs to be so I'm just putting
my Bishop for example yeah
now whenever I go down here
I play Bishop of two in King B6
right
just I mean then you have yeah so for
example like here King King B6 okay I
you want to trick me away okay let's try
Bishop F2
and you try Bishop F2 okay even though I
didn't see the threads but for example
I can't see five I'm I'm trying to run
yeah
then your your Bishop's not going to be
on G3 that's why you keep the bishop
either on F2 or G1 okay so you go yes
ah so I have H2 and G3 to jump again
this one you go here I have two two
squares I only need two squares exactly
you've got uh F2 G1 H2 yes nice
okay I think he saw it I I think I'm
just refreshing my board yeah but they
will still play I don't know maybe 20
moves no no way no no I think linear
will
will test him no that's what I mean
force him to get the best punishment get
here he will get there
the
uh we we've been kind of uh fated and
treated in these previous rounds we had
a huge number of decisive games like 60
of a combination of the two events and
uh yesterday we had all of these
decisive rounds today it was more much
more tepid yes it's only four decisive
games only four so far
we are so spoiled let me tell you about
a few sync field cups uh where we're the
players and now this is the key moment
you play Bishops
simply by the way this just shows I know
I know where I'm supposed to be yeah I'm
not even going to think about it I know
what you were trying to get to another
one
no okay
very nicely these guys are very very
um
strong he's
pretty good yeah in this book Grand
Master preparation left Paul guyowski
was telling a story uh of a you know
German that he had with bent Larson
and he had it was just an incredible
Bishop ending with so many extraordinary
subtleties and he had laid this very
very carefully prepared trap for bent
and there was only one move only one
moved that one and bent played it
instantly like not even waiting right
behind the move just instantly played it
and it was like
he had seen it as well and Sam right now
I remember at the beginning of this end
game he was shaking his head he was
taking his glasses off right
tired right very very tired very
difficult to calculate this anyway right
now he looks like he just defused the
bomb yes he's energetic he plays fast he
doesn't have any problems okay it's time
to go home so can you imagine I lost
this type of ending like how to get
checkmate right I mean in one move you
know there were like some kind of thing
like I played King A5 and white poems
swear on a4b3 C3 and my pawns were
somewhere like A6 and B5 and Bishop C7
Checkmate followed can you imagine yeah
imagine 20 years later this person who
gave me this Checkmate found me in the
internet and said do you remember this
guy who gave you this Checkmate it was
so exciting I cannot say the same
exactly leave me alone
everybody remembers the beautiful
victory that Nigel short had against Jan
Tima of course moved his King all the
way up in a middle game to the H6 square
and check made it beautifully yes his
opponent Yeah Tim and what people don't
remember is the game that Nigel short
played against Alexander bellyevsky from
Linares where Nigel in a much better
position moved his King all the way up
the board and walked right into
Checkmate in one
that's a good point right you have to
show both of these gifts too exactly
for the balance yeah right just moving
your king up the board does not
guarantee you Victory exactly you know
uh Bishop too to be careful still
is a very nice story it makes a it makes
a good pairing let's say Nigel will not
like that I reminded him of this pasta
feliowsky yeah uh we I had asked
Anastasia and she she very bravely yes
answered the worst moment a Christian
you've got to share your worst moment
in the chessboard my worst moment as a
transplant yeah there's something that
you've made the howler of a lifetime
that's a good question all right I'll
I'll tell you a funny story so
um I was playing my teammate and I was
having a terrible event I think it was
two and a half out of nine in a closed
event
um close to the end of the tournament
and I was playing my teammate
um and I wanted to win I wanted to do
something great in that game right I
also wanted a tournament to finish I got
into a completely winning position and
then I blunder a piece in one move now I
get into a losing position
but there is one last trick and if you
place that move I make a draw with some
study like a solution and my opponent
fakes that he's going to make that move
and immediately goes and plays a
different move and presses the clock
and at this point I wanted to hit him
snap him
I I I got up I resigned I did not shake
the hands okay this is the only time I
did not Shake uh the hands against my
opponent and uh that was it I didn't
speak with that guy for a couple of
months he apologized after that and we
kind of moved on but I think that was
the toughest moment at least it still
hurts still hurts that's fake you know
that face that fake move you're already
winning and why do you need I'm already
getting brutalized right I mean I have
the tournaments
me yeah yeah this is where chess boxing
comes you know yes yes very good this
idea
it's a very attractive idea yes imagine
it was chess boxing then you enjoy the
next part right
actually no once you resign on the chest
but you don't resign
you wait for the round to finish yes and
then you go in boxing and do your your
best right you're very motivated right
exactly yeah
of this game guys yeah you throw a low
blow and oh I guess I'm forfeited
there we go Bishop 26. I've seen this
position
all this way I think we might see a
repetition perhaps
for sure
yeah and let's not forget I mean
repetition can be the repetition of
moves or the three times the repetition
of the position yes it's important that
sometimes I guess you can try C5 right
now and then other 50 moves yes you can
you are allowed to play the bishop takes
C5 King E5 King takes B5 I mean for
Bishop F2
not much of a chance in that one
and then do the same G4S okay with upon
less
I guess it doesn't really work not
exactly terrible okay just don't flag oh
that's Terr how much time two seconds
yes no yes two seconds how could you let
Lydia are you trying to flag what if you
can lose like this you know something
absolutely that's crazy maybe he just
fell asleep oh yes no this can happen
really this is a completely weird
situation maybe he's just it happened a
few times yeah he's just an adrenaline
no way you have to play Make a Move two
32. no you have been because I think
he's messing with our minds he is our
emotions that this is crazy what what a
great time I mean feeling
yeah yeah yeah yeah he has a special
feel for for two seconds two seconds
he's trying to give us a show in the
last few yes okay thank you for being
here for that last few minutes yeah our
hearts skipped a beat there right you
know wow
and it's really nice okay I actually
think I know what he's trying to do
what besides so giving is a heart attack
King F5 or King G6 let's say right okay
now if you go Bishop H2 I go G4 no no I
will not do this King C5 now okay
because this is my favorite yes original
plan I just moved my king from now on
yeah yeah but good try
okay that's a luxury seven seconds
everybody can do it try to do it with
two seconds imagine something went wrong
you know like you're peaceful down I
don't know no that I I always had that I
mean in my mind that this could happen
that you know in this case let's say
linear runs down as clocked as two
seconds and suddenly the opponent makes
this incredible sneeze
and you know your hands going in the air
and it disturbs you just for that split
or just move something like it will hit
the board
yes yes I heard this story as well you
know two seconds on the clock somebody
hits you and then they're like shot and
two seconds goes and then oh I'm sorry
that was a yeah
oh by the way it also Flats yeah I'm
sorry yeah
now Sam is just boy I mean he's like six
minutes
clock I I'm playing as fast as I can we
I mean look you want to play with fire
sure I'll play with fire with you yeah
maybe he can now again Ask for three
times your position you know you can I
know you can you do it second time yes I
don't think he wants to no I think he
wants to give his opponent a chance to
flag right now no for sure but that just
means that in general how many times you
can actually ask for three times
repetition
keep keeps getting two minutes on the
clock for every fail
time but I don't think this is a
restriction but no there are no no I
don't think so I just want to say
Anastasia was right
um it does seem like Lanier kept trying
for 20 moves yes
I predicted that he might do this you
know trying to make his support actually
what he is trying to do he wants his
opponent fall down from the chair
I mean because he is exhausted okay so
at some point he's going to go G4 I
understand what he's doing right so King
B6 King D5
Bishop F2 now ng4 and then you go all
the way back with your king no but I
mean I'm going to take with the F Pawn I
guess this is yes but then he's trying
to get but then you go look all the way
back to G4 and you take H4 but you don't
you don't because I move diagonals I go
on the other diagonal okay I go on the
d8 H4 yeah yes yes it's possible also
exactly because now there's no more G4
coffee
that was a mass G4 that you could play
and well I mean drawers draw but you
know when you make a pass Pawn on G3 yes
uh don't be surprised if something
terrible terrible terrible happens 46
seconds yes this uh we're invested we
have to see it to the end we don't we
don't call the broadcast and say it's
it's been a draw for the last half hour
I mean we want to see uh will linear
flag or not
I'm saying no by the way
yes oh 23 seconds
yeah here we go so Bishop F2 G4 will you
play it
Again Sam is just like hey I I know this
is a draw
are you sure you want to play Emoji four
really uh
uh I would be reluctant but okay
no even if you come all this way and you
take the spawn on the tour then you put
G2 yeah
once the bishop comes you take on C4 B6
okay some
I think what Christians said to put the
bishop on d8 with the pawn yeah 18
seconds he's doing it again no come on
does he have like I don't know maybe I
don't know what his adrenaline
adrenaline rush here uh death
wishes he does he is very important I've
seen it also before yeah actually it's
it's nice that the son of the son of
valineer he also plays chess already
yeah
what an adorable kid actually I came to
the club once and he was watching the
game so his father it was really cool to
see him there I played ottos with him
when he was a little toddler it was
great 14 seconds
I mean Sebastian's gonna say daddy why
did you let your clock run down to two
seconds
okay this is how you learn
right everybody can do it with 30
seconds try to do it with two right okay
I think he has to play C5 check C5 check
Bishop takes C5 King E5 uh-huh that has
got to be his
last winning attempt with 15 seconds
honestly and then you put the bishop on
G3 12.
come on eight no really and here comes
the sneeze no come on look at this two
seconds
that's ridiculous he's making fun of
myself
one second and again if you know you get
kicked under the table something happens
so once I will do something like this a
little I will just make a draw
immediately and just rush to away the
way I mean of course this is absolutely
ridiculous it's just a sign that I'm
just completely crazy
use this game and five seconds you can
four okay of course Bishop E2 and Bishop
F1 takes 29 seconds each time for you to
play Bishop F1 and Bishop E2 look he's
trying to find me the best moment this
is one of the weirdest moments and yes a
great cast I've ever experienced I mean
the position is so draw right and he
risks by letting his time run down to
his last one second it's so strange it's
still counting C5 of course he does
no but here it comes again
this is absolutely
he is a really a thrill suit I don't
know what about us but what about seven
four seven I mean he can see him every
time to play with one second two seconds
two seconds once oh he did it with 18
seconds that time I mean
I couldn't believe what's going on
absolutely wild that is crazy
wow that yeah right right right right
yeah you feel this uh suddenly
Adrenaline Rush as well yes I hope our
viewers have been fun you know just take
your pills guys if you need right
because it looks like it's getting
Wilder and Wilder it's crazy all right
dropping down to his last 20 seconds
anyone who has some problems with heart
I mean you better don't watch it exactly
because again it's coming after 15
seconds okay okay G4 here at the
strangest moment and fall to play the
move G4 he does it now
wow all right okay let's stand up now
okay so we by the way 14 minutes for Seb
right so we play I mean now I take on
okay
always with the F1 okay oh wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute there is a
nice trap if I take with the H Pawn yes
and you play Bishop G2 I have F3 correct
yes
but if you think with the H Pawn I go
King E4 and you might actually lose that
I understand I'm just saying it's a 50
50.
King E4 uh okay so who's so Sam's saying
well let me just make sure that that's a
trap so King E4
all right well we think uh this has been
a dead draw for some time yes but uh I
have to say unfortunately all good
things have to come to an end honest us
yet you're going to close us
very very very eventful one it has been
yes uh final thoughts uh as we
oh first of all our current standings
for women and Jennifer you enjoys her
first place so lead 60 does boys and
then Arena crash together with Megan
leecher the first second place what a
great uh fight Alice Lee gave us is she
pushed the eight-time U.S Champion all
the way yes and she's on the fourth
place right now exactly
and in the open Fabi still leaves by a
half a point uh depending well no Rey is
already drawn yeah so Ray Robson is on
the second place yes Christian final
thoughts I mean what around first of all
you know I was kind of falling asleep in
the last 20 minutes and then Lanier kept
waking me up and waking me up and waking
me up uh but what a tournament we have
what two tournaments we have both in the
lady section as well as the open section
the open section is a two-horse race
right now it's Fabiano caruana and Ray
Robson and they're keeping very close to
each other and in the latest section of
Journey for you but also begging she has
won her game and right now only one
point and a half behind the leaders
still plenty of Chess to play and we
will be here to call all the action in
round 10 tomorrow
thank you very much Christian you said
it all Anastasia once again what a round
has been terrific thank you all for
sharing your day with us be sure to come
and join us tomorrow for round 10 and
we'll have a break on our weekend uh
Sunday will be a rest day for us good
night everyone good night
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited